foreign
wow
okay
good morning everyone
welcome to the house committee on Health
and Human Services and elderly affairs
we have a number a couple of bills very
important bills to be that will be
conducting hearings on today but before
we do that I'd ask you to please join me
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands
one nation under God indivisible with
and again I'd like to thank all of you
for being here today and coming and
attending this this hearing
uh just a few remarks I'd like to make
before we get underway
whether you intend to speak or simply to
observe or provide model support for
someone who is speaking here today we do
appreciate your attendance
we have two bills for which we'll be
hearing testimony
as is the case with all of the bills
that come before the legislature these
are important and citizen input is very
valuable
before I open the first hearing I'd like
to explain how we will proceed
it has become the established practice
of this committee to recognize the main
sponsor of the bill and give them a
flexible amount of time to explain the
background of the bill
why it was introduced and so forth
after the main sponsor speaks and has
finished answering questions everyone
who has completed a pink card is
recognized one by one
as a matter of fairness and in order to
ensure that everyone has an equal
opportunity to speak
we have a time limit for each person
thereafter of three minutes
this time limit will be enforced
strictly
when you have spoken for two minutes and
45 seconds I will advise you that you
have 15 seconds and to begin wrapping up
your remarks
at the end of three minutes I will ask
if you are accepting questions from the
committee members and if you are I will
then ask the committee members if they
have any questions
when the committee is finished asking
questions of one individual we will then
move on to the next person and the next
and so on
well three minutes may not seem like a
very long period of time it is the best
way for us to give every one of you an
equal chance to speak
I would ask all of you to please be
respectful of one another while someone
is speaking and the words you choose
I know that there are strong feelings on
all sides of the legislation we are
considering here today
although there may be disagreement let
there not be disrespect
finally in keeping with decorum
especially here in the house chamber
please do not share or jeer or clap in
response to the testimony you hear
Plex also reminded me that a gentlemen
are wearing hats please remove them
again it's a matter of the decorum of
the house chamber
now the first bill for us to consider
today is House Bill 619 and I would like
to recognize representative boy the
prime sponsor to introduce this bill
representative Roy
thank you Mr chairman thank you members
of the committee thank you members of
the public to come out for the this
important discussion my name is
representative Roy I represent
Rockingham District 31.
I brought this bill at the request of
parents in my district
at least five different sets of parents
came to me a year ago and asked me to
bring this bill
I was very hesitant to bring this bill
because I knew of the controversy that
it would cause
what sealed that for me was when I got a
call from a doctor in my district
and that doctor asked me to bring this
bill as well
I bring this bill not with the intention
that it will necessarily end up as
Banning these procedures I bring this
bill with the intention that we have
something that heretofore we have not
been able to have and that's a public
discussion about these treatments
heretofore parents who have tried to
bring it up at school boards or with
medical professionals have been shut
down canceled threatened
and the same goes for doctors I got an
email from a doctor a prestigious doctor
in this state who told me that he
supported the bill but was afraid to
come forward because he might lose his
position
in this country we should be able to
have a rational discussion about what is
best for our children without people
this treatment and gender affirming care
for children
is a relatively new area of Medicine
it's not proven it's debated in country
after country no one is exactly sure
what is best no one is sure the
long-term effects
but what we are sure of
is when someone goes with it and takes
it to its fullest extent they cannot go
back
every day we hear new stories of people
who started this process as children and
wanted to de-transition
and at that point all the medical and
support groups that were there for them
to transition are no longer there
and since their parents have been
alienated when they were left out of the
discussion they don't even have them
and the toughest question for this
legislature and we as a public to answer
is when a young girl or a young boy
comes forward when they reach adulthood
and they ask how do I get my breasts
back
how can I have babies now that I'm
sterile
we need to have these conversations and
if this bill was the only way for us to
have this debate in discussion and then
so be it
if it turns out that this gender
affirming care is the best thing for our
children then prove it and then it will
be so
but if it can't be proven then we need
to put a pause on it before we do damage
to our children that we cannot repair
the different parts of the bill speak
for themselves I will be submitting a
detailed testimony online that's all of
your time I'm going to take today and I
won't be taking any questions on this
thank you
okay what I'm going to be as we proceed
with a testimony from other individuals
what I'm going to do is call up a person
and after that and I'm gone also at the
same time announce the person who will
be speaking after them so that that
person who will be speaking next will be
able to stop moving near a microphone
and again to expedite the proceedings
today
next up to speak is representative
good morning I rise in support of the
bill
first off I off I just want to tell
everyone that we don't hate anybody here
we don't
we have great concerns for the kids
I have family members who identify as
the opposite sex
I myself was a tomboy when I was a kid
and I outgrew it
I also want to mention
a woman named Renee Jacks who was born a
male
I met her and her story broke my heart
she's been taking artificial hormones
hormones for well over 30 years now she
still has to shave every morning so she
doesn't look like a man
the hormones are wreaking havoc on her
body because it's so unnatural I I can
it would take a long time to tell all
the things that have happened to her her
body
from this from these artificial hormones
but you can look her up when you have
time so I don't want to take up too much
time Renee Jax is her name she's also an
author
and I won't be taking any questions I
have to get back to my own committee
thank you thank you representative Narda
next step to speak is Dr simran Baal to
good morning honorable members of the
committee my name is simran ball I live
in Hanover New Hampshire I am a
physician and a member of the American
College of Physicians New Hampshire
Governor's Council and the New Hampshire
Medical Society and today I'm here to
testify in strong opposition to hb619 my
testimony also represents that of the
two organizations that I have mentioned
which also oppose this bill
today I'm testifying that as a doctor
I'm highly concerned about the
repercussions of this bill in terms of
the effect that it may have on New
Hampshire's youth as a physician one of
the best parts of my job has been caring
for people of all walks of life and I
wanted to just share one small anecdote
from my time in medical training when I
was early in residency I was working in
the emergency room and took care of a
young adult transgender patient who was
coming in with blood kind of seeping
through the long sleeves of their shirt
and from their jeans and after examining
and talking to this patient we learned
that this patient had had severe
suicidal ideation from shame and
bullying that they had experienced in
not having supportive social
environments and supported family
structures to me that was just
incredibly like unfathomable and
heartbreaking and it represents to me
what happens too often which is that
transgender youth are not able to access
supportive social environments and have
difficulties accessing gender affirming
care and this results in anxiety
depression higher rates of homelessness
and higher rates of self-harm rates of
suicide are as high as 40 percent in
transgender use which means that if
there are a hundred people in this room
imagine that 40 of us would have
attempted suicide to me that is again
heartbreaking
this bill proposes to ban gender
affirming care it would ban those
supportive social structures in school
and it would legalize conversion therapy
and thus it would exacerbate the health
care disparities that I've already
pointed out I want you to imagine for a
moment putting yourself in my shoes as a
physician or as a parent a teacher and
remembering kind of that pain that you
may experience if some child's life ends
too early because of suicide due to the
harms that this bill propagates I do
want to point out it doesn't need to be
this way at all in medicine we follow
very careful evidence-based protocols
that show us the importance of accepting
transgender identities that also involve
the use of medications which were
carefully used to put a temporary pause
on puberty these physical changes that
happen to youth can be distressing and
it allows us to temporarily halt those
changes we've also notably used these
medications for the past 30 years to
help children who are diagnosed with the
early onset of puberty or Central
precocious puberty I also want to point
out that there are studies Studies by
recognize that point out in large
cohorts that accessing these medications
is really crucial and is associated with
lower odds of suicide I think with that
I want to go ahead and close but just
recognize that this bill would put
medical decisions into the hands of
government rather than between the
patient family and physician
thank you are you taking questions
any questions from committee members yes
representative Leon thank you very much
for being here and thank you Mr chairman
could you submit those evidence-based
guidelines for this care to the
committee thank you I will do so thank
you
other questions from committee members
I'm sitting on thank you representative
Barber
thank you Mr chair we're all getting
used to the space
which is not our normal home
um would would you please could I ask
you a bit about what kind of Parental
involvement there is when you see a
minor who wants this kind of treatment
yeah thank you so much so I think when I
see patients in clinic there are two
sides of the spectrum I think one side
is that we really carefully want the
child to have all of the supports in
their life that help them make this
decision and that can be parental role
models who often accompany them to
appointments and help them step by step
think through this decision on the other
hand we often encounter patients who may
not be supportive and in that case the
child turns to other trusted role models
in their life like teachers peers and
others in the community who are leaders
so I worry that not accessing those
supportive social supports will mean
difficulties in accessing care and going
through a potential transition
thank you
other questions from committee members
yes representative Murphy I believe it
is thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question you mentioned the
medications are reversible is there a
time Beyond which they are not
reversible once they are started that's
a good question I don't believe so but I
can look into that more definitively and
get back to you we use them often for
children who have had early onset of
puberty and so we wait you know a number
of years until that time of puberty like
is like to catch up like if they went
through puberty at age six for example
waiting until age 12 but I can get more
like definitive information to you too
representative McLean
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question so obviously you know
a person who's going through this
there's going to be a lot of confusion
and you talk about the bullying as well
um so could you maybe describe for the
community the process that you take to
go through to decide this is going to be
the decision because for some it may be
seen as an easy way out so what what's
the process that you go through to kind
of get this is the road we have to take
yeah thank you so much for the question
I think when we think about transition
we recognize that it is not an easy
decision to make and we look for
sustained kind of evidence where a child
really feels that they were not born
into the right body that fits their
gender identity going back years often
patients that I've seen in clinic will
report that this began in childhood and
that the people around them felt like
they could not listen to them for
example or that they felt unsafe in
bringing these concerns out so we listen
to that narrative and we help patients
sort of sort of understand the Journey
of where it began and I think the other
parts too is that we typically have a
number of different office visits where
we talk through this and we think about
other like comorbidities for example
anxiety depression things like that that
may make it harder to transition as well
follow-up
thank you Mr chair so
um so part of your testimony said we
really don't want to have the
legislature involved in this but from
like medical rules and I'm not a doctor
so but medical rules and practice are
these kind of is this process defined or
is this pretty much different you know
doctor or doctor or is it a defined
protocol thank you so much for the
question again and I think that this is
why it's so helpful that we are having
this discussion because it really is an
evidence-based process we utilize
guidance from the American Academy of
Pediatrics which is well recognized and
the endocrine Society itself which also
put like publishes protocols that help
us think through the transition that may
be medical involving hormone-based
medications and the psychological
transition but we use well-recognized
evidence to make the decision and to go
through the process it's not like an
individual making these decisions it's
really a body of evidence in the medical
other questions
any other questions for committee
members okay thank you very much
thank you
okay next step to speak is Dr Wankel to
uh good morning to the members of the
House Health and Human Services
committee my name is Brett Wankel I'm a
resident physician of internal medicine
and I live in Lebanon New Hampshire I'm
here to testify strongly in opposition
to hb619
prior to becoming a physician I was a
volunteer with the Trevor Project an
organization dedicated to preventing
suicide and gay and trans youth as
you've heard by now
40 percent of transgender individuals
report a history of suicide attempts
within this group those who are rejected
by their families and their communities
and those who are deprived opportunities
to transition are even more likely to
attempt suicide
these are ramifications I'm sadly
however transgender individuals who are
received with acceptance and support are
protected and experience severe mental
illness and attempt suicide at lower
rates in a country where deaths of
Despair are rising among young people we
should not codify their isolation and
limit doctors abilities to help
for those of you who are asking why not
wait until adulthood the answer is
simple gender incongruence typically
presents during adolescence if not
earlier
this bill would restrict both education
and health care for young people when
they need it
this bill as it stands will Outlaw best
practice medicine and would punish
Physicians who attempt to give their
patients
the best care possible
these standards are not experimental but
are established by the Pediatric
endocrine Society the American Academy
of Pediatrics and the academic Pediatric
Association based on a synthesis of data
in gender affirming care
while this bill highlights the risk of
medication it overlooks the benefits as
well as the risks in action poses
it is up to patients and their doctors
to determine the best path forward
this legislation will remove a central
pillar of the American Health Care
System autonomy
many adolescents possess the requisite
insight to participate meaningfully in
informed medical discussions and
participate in their health care
decisions
this would take away this decision from
patients and families and leave it with
the state
this is not only bad medicine but it is
an infringement of Liberty
thank you for your time I'll try to
answer questions if there are any
thank you Doctor any questions from
committee members representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking this question my understanding is
that the predominant
um medical or surgical intervention
would be puberty blockers before age 18
and I wonder if um you're aware of
research about the long-term effects of
puberty blockers and if you are if you
would be able to comment on it and
forward that information to the
committee uh so I'm not off the top of
my head intimately familiar with the the
research as Dr ball highlighted in these
puberty blockers have been used for
decades and children in the treatment of
central precocious puberty and it's not
believed that there are long-term
irreversible
consequences for delaying puberty
thank you
other questions
any other questions from committee
members I see none okay thank you very
much sir thank you
next up to speak is Dr Conway to be
followed by representative Murray
good morning honorable members of the
committee my name is Heather Conway and
I live in Enfield New Hampshire I'm here
today to testify in strong opposition to
hb619
I will be testifying today as a
physician as a New Hampshire resident
and as a sibling of a transgender person
about my concern for the potential
negative consequences of this bill on
transgender Youth and all those that
care for them
it's a well-known Trope that every
unhappy family is unhappy in their own
way growing up much to my regret now I
would have described a lot of my
family's unhappiness to my brother's
Behavior he had so much internalized and
externalized anger that my parents and I
just could not understand
he would get into trouble at school and
I would see the distress in my parents
faces as they tried to help him well we
did not realize then was that every time
we called him by his birth name or he
was instructed to go change in the wrong
locker room we were compounding his
Indescribable hurt Indescribable because
none of us had the language that we
needed
when my brother came out as trans a few
years later and started receiving gender
affirming care the transition within my
whole family was equally Indescribable
he is so much happier now and more
comfortable in his own skin but I can't
help to wonder how different things
might have been if he didn't have to
first suffer through all of those years
this is just anecdotal data from my own
personal experience but now as a
physician I practice evidence-based
medicine and what the evidence shows us
is that providing gender affirming care
to trans youths saves lives
you've already heard the studies
conducted by the American Academy of
Pediatrics have found a significant
reduction in moderate and severe
depression and a significant reduction
in suicidality among transgender and
non-binary youth who receive puberty
blockers and gender-affirming care
bills such as hb619 that aim to
legislate against LGBT education and
safe learning environments for
transgender youth do not prohibit
Children and adolescents from the
experience of being transgender but it
does limit their access to the medical
and educational interventions that they
need
I would like to reiterate my opposition
to hb619 and sincerely thank you all for
your time and attention and I'm happy to
answer any questions if I can
thank you any questions from committee
members
I'm seeing no questions thank you very
much
next step to speak is representative
Murray to be followed by Kearney
ponierney
Sandra Rodriguez Marine I represent
Manchester Ward 9. and I'm a trans
non-binary person many of you my
colleagues may not know that
um yet I've been able to make good
friends on both sides of the aisle does
hearing this now change your perception
of me negatively does being trans negate
all the qualities you have seen and
appreciated me
I know for some it will as I found out
after tweeting about this bill yesterday
after saying how scared I was to be a
trans legislator in the New Hampshire
state house in a time where bills like
this one just work to destroy me and my
people I received dozens of hate
comments and emails and I'm going to
read one of them to you now
hello Alessandra you should feel lucky
that you are able to hold any kind of
public office when white nationalists
take power someday and
homosexuals will not be able to hold
public office or be around children in
any capacity I submitted online
testimony today and supported the three
bills that will protect children from
your degenerate filth I discuss it at
the link below and urge all white
nationalists to submit testimony as well
and then he includes the link to the Gap
post that he made using my content to
encourage people to support these bills
clearly these bills enable hate they
enable violence they dehumanize and
ostracize trans and queer people making
it even harder to exist in a world that
is set against us you are not protecting
children with these bills you are making
it harder for them increasing suicidal
ideolation and mental health struggles
it has proven that validating a child's
trans or queer identity can be
life-saving if you all pass this bill
you are saying you would rather a child
die than be trans
validating trans children does not mean
immediate surgery getting gender
affirmative care is actually extremely
difficult I am 28 years old and when I
tried to get a consult for Top surgery
it took a year to get an appointment and
then at that appointment I found out
insurance wouldn't cover the procedure
because I hadn't proved that I was trans
enough
this is me as an adult facing immense
hurdles to get the health care that I
deserve now imagine how much harder it
is for a child to do so
I urge you all today to see that trans
people are not a threat we are your
community members your state reps we are
people who care deeply about New
Hampshire and want to make it better and
safer for all
I urge you all to vote itl on this
legislation and let the decision between
trans patients families and providers
stay between them thank you
thank you you're taking questions
yes any questions from committee members
saying no questions thank you very much
thank you
next up to speak is Kearney and
hopefully I'm pronouncing that name
correctly to be followed by Zachary
Terrell close but not quite uh Karen
pokorny from Derry and thank you for
your time this morning I wanted to come
in today because I am a transgender man
and the fact is as I knew that I was
trans at the age of four years old
um for me going through puberty was a
very traumatic experience if having the
hormone blockers to be able to stop that
process and not have the long-term
effects of the health that
having to go on to hormones and the
cancer risk that does come from being on
long-term hormones if we can start
earlier for those that do truly know
that they are trans and that this was
not a thing that I consider this was a
life or death thing for me this was
something that had to be done I knew
from the age of starting to be able to
explain who I was as a person Elementary
School for those that actually want to
go through this whole process of
transitioning it's never a question in
their mind
and we need to make sure that we're
being we're giving them the best
resources that we can to have a full
healthy life
I also want to speak on the part of this
bill that goes into
um
relative to sex and gender in our Public
Schools I think that teaching gender
identity in our Public Schools is an
important step in creating a safe and
inclusive learning environment for all
students gender identity education can
help students better understand
themselves and their peers while also
providing them with the tools to
navigate the complexities of gender
identity in our society the fact is that
this is our new reality or this next
generation is a lot more comfortable
with being gender fluid and being able
to not have to fit themselves into one
sex or the other and
we should we should allow that to be
expressed and learned about so that the
bullying and the shame that comes from
that within our Public Schools is to
diminished the fact is is that this
argument is a losing one we are going to
continue to evolve as a society and
become more accepting and more accepting
and if the house is not going to get up
with the times and this next
generation's expectations of you then
the next generation is going to come and
take your seats and make sure that you
this isn't accepted so I hope that you
committee members
next up to speak is Zachary Terrell to
be followed by Leonard small or Dr
Leonard small
good morning thank you for having me uh
Zach Terrell Plymouth New Hampshire I
stand in a strong opposition of this
bill
um
my my daughter last year came out as
trans to our family
the least surprising thing
she could have done excuse me
[Music]
at two years old
um
she approached us and actually her
grandparents and said
I the one thing I want for Christmas is
a dress
um
two years old that we've known
for 13 years
that this person in in their mind
and and who they were
that may not be what they were assigned
through every interaction with this
person
they they chose to watch cartoons that
had female protagonists they loved My
Little Pony they chose all the sorts of
things that you might consider
stereotypically feminine
through their whole life
we were very supportive of that but we
also knew it was something that they
held very personally
um they didn't necessarily tell their
friends that they chose to sleep in more
of a nightgown style pajamas instead of
the athletic shorts that their brother
wore
this has always been her reality and who
she is
so when she came out last year to to my
parents
my father a blue collar worker formerly
a firefighter a gun shop owner
his question was
can I still call you buddy and she said
of course
um
so this bill
to me is concerning that she won't be
able to get the care right and and the
doctors have spoken this isn't this
isn't a situation where she gets to
um you know show up at a hospital and
say you know give me give me gender
affirming care it's a process there's
there's psychologists involved there's
many many doctors involved and and we've
been a year in this journey with her and
the medical
boards uh but of 13 years of
experiencing it in our in our lives uh
she's still not on puberty blockers
there's still a process there's so many
people who have to sign off the medical
profession takes this very serious 15
seconds Sir and they're very careful so
so please consider that there's real
people in your districts who would be
negatively affected if um if this bill
was to go through so thank you for your
time and I will take questions if there
are any yeah any questions from
representative Weber
thank you so much and thank you for
being here thank your daughter for being
here
um and
I guess my question is if this bill were
to pass would you feel that your rights
is apparent to be able to parent your
child would be infringed
yes I very much so
thank you thank you for telling us your
story
other questions from committee members
I'm seeing on thank you sir
our next step to speak is Dr Leonard
small to be followed by representative
Granger
pediatrician I graduated from Dover High
and I practiced in Dover for 34 years
I stand in opposition to this bill very
strongly
there are many false and misleading
statements in this bill but two major
areas of concern one is suicide and one
is the government practice in medicine
I won't go in more to the suicide I'm
going to written in my statement because
I think others can express that very
well can express the distress that they
grow up with knowing that their identity
is different from what people want
but I think if you all think back to
when you were two to four years old you
knew who you were as a person you knew
you're a male or a female
but just think of that knowledge was in
contradiction to what Society said and
what uh you bought your physical body
says so that can lead to a lot of
distress and suicide and I won't go into
that more
my other concern is the government
practicing medicine
New Hampshire gave me a license to
practice medicine after acquiring
College medical school and residency
that training and that license carried
the expectation that I would act in the
best interests of my patients relying on
evidence-based medicine
when faced with a problem I would rely
on a search of the literature
and the policies the relevant medical
societies
not doing so could subject me to
malpractice
for Trans children
evidence-based medicine is clear that
gender affirmative care is the standard
for the mental and physical well-being
the American Medical Association
Association
the American Academy of Pediatrics and
the American Psychiatric association all
endorse gender affirming care and
opposed government intervention
this bill forces the physician to ignore
or deny that standard
it forces the physician to commit
malpractice in order to avoid civil
penalties
it is a government practicing medicine
for
non-evidence-based medicine
which would be unacceptable in any other
situation
trans kids are born with a certain
identity
they did not choose it
is who they are
it cannot be changed
much of society does not accept this
fact of medicine and science does
this bill these trans kids at
significant risk of suicide
this makes government not evidence the
determinant of the standard of care
for the mental and physical health by
children
and for the ethical well-being of our
physicians
I strongly urge you to defeat this bill
and I'll think any questions thank you
I'm saying none uh sir do you have a
copy of your written testimony or yep
thank you next up to speak is
representative Ranger to be followed by
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee my name is Michael Granger
representing Stratford II it is often
said that history never repeats itself
but that it often Rhymes Eugenics has a
long and interesting history in the
1930s Germany had a euthanasia program
that involved excluding the genetically
unfit Germans from the national
Community before the end of the decade
over 5 000 physically and mentally
disabled children were murdered through
starvation or lethal overdoses of
medication
but in the United States at the same
exact time the concept of euthanizing
social undesirables was also a popular
idea it was almost always countered
however with humanitarian sentiment that
the lower classes shouldn't be killed
but merely prevented from breeding
this lowly logic is all the rage during
the Progressive Era after all why bother
murdering them when you can simply
sterilize them instead this was the
geogenesis Viewpoint back in the day
from their Viewpoint that's nine tenths
to benefit with one-tenth the risk of
social condemnation
after World War II and the full horrors
of the Holocaust became well known and
well taught the idea that we should
engage in any eugenic activity to
prevent the propagation of undesirable
traits felt to an all-time low in
popularity the ideas themselves didn't
die however those who held on to these
Progressive ideas kept it to themselves
and took time to modify and adapt the
viewpoints and make them more marketable
the GI generation who fought in World
War II is mostly dead and when a
generation dies Society loses memories
there are less than a quarter million
Americans Alive Now who fought in World
War II and that number is unfortunately
decreasing every day each time one of
these people dies Society has one less
person to ask about the ideas that the
generation defeated
we forget ideas that are incredibly
dangerous incredibly evil and Incredibly
wrong and if we don't remember we can't
recognize them when they come again
the ideas that have been sleeping since
World War II now have an opportunity to
come back for there are none left who
remember them Eugenics is wrong it is
wrong to sterilize minors even if they
are exhibiting what some consider
non-gender conforming Behavior so what
if a boy thinks he's a girl children are
full of imaginative thoughts and if they
want to play pretend that is not a crime
let's not punish a child's creativity by
amputating their sex organs these
children's are incredibly valuable their
genes are worth spreading frankly it's
cool to take advantage of confused
adolescents and trick them into
destroying their lineages every single
person alive today comes from a long
line of survivors every one of us had a
father and a mother both of them
survived long enough to produce
Offspring each of our parents also had
parents who survived long enough to have
kids this chain goes back for at least a
couple dozen years probably much longer
and each one of our ancestors survived
long enough to have kids kids with
gender dysphoria are no different they
should not be called from the gene pool
I repeat do not call non-gender
conforming children from the gene pool
there's nothing wrong with a boy who
likes baking and sewing and wearing
dresses there's nothing wrong with a
girl going fishing and climbing trees
everyone in this room engages in
non-gender conforming behavior from time
to time and that's okay if you truly
care for these kids and want them to
have full meaningful lives don't let
them be castrated before they are able
to breed
they deserve to have an opportunity to
have kids of their own many of them may
not make it and each time each one that
is not able to contribute genetic
material to the future of humanity is a
shame but to deny them the ability to
even try that's just evil Eugenics is
wrong so please OTP hb619 thank you for
your time I'm available for questions
okay any questions from committee
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking the question are you comparing
the extermination of Jews and others
with giving gender affirming care
correct both of them were attempts to
reduce please correct both of those were
attempts to remove people from the gene
pool both of them were genocide trans
genocide
as a Jew I find that hey please please
again no disrespect everybody had the
right to breathe even my enemies have a
right to breed they disagree with me
they have a right to breed any other
questions
thank you sir
next up to speak is Courtney Tanner to
Dartmouth health is is opposed to House
Bill 619 in its totality
Dartmouth Health provides comprehensive
quality care to patients across the
state as the state's only academic
Medical Center we are proud to provide
Specialty Care to patients who need
complex care
we provide high quality gender affirming
care to both pediatric patients and
adult patients we're the only Pediatric
Endocrinology program in the state
our met our multi-disciplinary program
is the only program that provides this
type of care to this population in
have a team of doctors nurses social
workers psychologists that actively work
with this population they are highly
trained highly skilled professionals who
provide care that's grounded in science
all of whom deeply care about our
patients in the work that they do
in the packet they came around I
provided written testimony from three
doctors Dr Francis Lim Liberty Dr Jack
Turco and Dr Brian O'Sullivan there's
also testimony in there from Jessica
Smith on APRN
Caroline Calvary a registered nurse and
Alyssa herwertz who's this ID
as legislators you're tasked with a
great challenge to balance individual
liberties and government intervention
it's a hard balance
but House Bill 619 would directly impede
our patients abilities and their individ
to access care and their individual
liberties it would interfere with their
personal freedoms
I want to applaud the father who came up
here to testify on behalf of his
daughter those are our patients those
are the patients that we treat and we
see
as parents can you imagine not being
able to access care for your for your
kiddo that has a complex Health disease
I can't I'm a parent of a kid who has
one
um as an adult a patient can you imagine
living in a in a state where you can't
access health care that you need and
that you want I can't imagine a state
like that
our patients come to us because they're
seeking care they want and they need
parents come to us to consent to
treatment because they want to need this
for their kids they are trying to
support their children
Dartmouth house is proud to provide
those evidence-based care and um we work
to lead for best physical and emotional
outcome to our patients I'm more than
happy to take questions we're strongly
opposed to have spell 619. thank you any
questions
next step to speak is Peyton Durkee to
hello my name is Peyton jerky I'm a New
Hampshire college student and a resident
of Nashua New Hampshire
I'm here today to strongly oppose House
Bill 619 and to explain to you why this
bill is dangerous and discriminatory for
New Hampshire Youth and for their
families
this bill claims quote only a small
percentage of the American population uh
defined experiences distressed and
identifying with their biological sex in
quotes
.005 to 0.1014 of males and
.002.003 of females according to the
American Psychiatric association who
also all supports gender affirming care
what this bill refers to as a small
percentage it's actually hundreds of
thousands of transgender and gender
non-conforming Americans if this bill
passes thousands of trans non-binary
youth will be denied the medical care
they need in New Hampshire
why are these medical services so
necessary
I'm looking to 2020 study from the
Journal of adolescent health
in this study 9019 Trans non-binary
American Youth between 13 and 17 years
of age answered questions about
receiving gender affirming hormone
therapy
quote Depression was 17 higher in youth
that wanted but did not receive the
gender affirming care compared to youth
that did suicide attempts or 11.7
percent higher in youth that wanted this
care but did not receive it compared to
youth that did
but gender affirming hormone therapy is
not the most popular form of gender
affirming care it's just one of the many
forms of transition that this bill is
aiming to ban
the language of this bill is very
concerning calling young trans girls
children threats to their cisgender
teammates by claiming their inclusion
would be quote dangerous and unfair to
female athletes
the safety of every single student in
New Hampshire is in the hands of their
coaches their referees their teachers
and their parents this bill also claims
that allowing transgender young girls to
participate on their preferred gender
teams quote diminishes female
achievement sets back women's rights and
denies cisgender girls their recognition
this blatantly discriminatory saying in
so many words that transgender young
women and girls and their athletic
achievements are not to be considered
legitimate or real like their cisgender
teammates
and claims their personal achievements
take away from or harm the subsist
gender girls this is not true women's
rights include transgender women's
rights trans women and trans young girls
are not a threat to cisgender women
trans youth in New Hampshire deserve
medical autonomy over their bodies
modern medicine has made so many
evidence-based gender affirming
procedures safe and successful and more
accessible unless this bill were to pass
it's up to trans kids their parents and
their trusted medical professionals to
make these age-appropriate decisions
that are in the children's best interest
the government should have no
the government should have nothing to do
with these personal medical choices and
this bill will strip these freedoms of
New Hampshire kids and their families it
does not need to exist in the state
gender affirming Health Care has and
will continue to save young lives thank
you and I am accepting questions if you
have any thank you any questions
next up to speak is Vivian Murphy to be
good morning
my name is Vivian Murphy I stand today
in opposition to this bill and I speak
from my personal experience as a trans
woman
first we were considered deviants
dressing as women only to gain access to
female spaces to inflict harm
then we wanted to engage in women's
sports so we could steal their
accomplishments
now we have child abusers for wanting to
create a more comfortable path to
Wellness rather than the confused and
heart-wrenching ordeal that we as adult
trans people were forced to endure
who comes next why is our experience so
through our existence so threatening
have the people proposing these
uninformed and mean-spirited laws ever
met a trans person or a child
where does their authority to impose
pain reside
where is their compassion and morality
it was once believed that women's bodies
were too fragile to ride in a locomotive
the blacks lacked intelligence to vote
gays were child Predators Mexicans were
lazy etc
etc
all these beliefs have been proven false
I quote the voice of the majority is no
proof of justice for a direct shower
philosopher
loss to force de transitioning have been
passed in South Dakota and Tennessee
there are hundreds of anti-transgender
laws being composed around the country
motivate motivated by fear or worse yet
by people who are willing at all costs
to maintain power and position
the rights of parents to seek
life-saving medically appropriate health
care for their child and being trampled
medical evidence is being attacked
mocked and ignored anyone trying to help
these trans kids are being labeled as
groomers what does that mean why are
these people that knew such things and
why are there tiny numbers with loud
branched self-righteous voices being
listened to
when this is in when we crawl back in
our holes and suffer in silence because
some are uncomfortable by our presence
we do not identify as women or men we
are women men or even sometimes we fall
in between
this is not a choice it's an innate
knowledge of who we are that is carried
from birth at 72 I have never had one
moment where I have felt comfortable as
I'm sorry
okay Banning something is the argument
of the uneducated or bigoted mind
compassion and empathy is where the
majority of society resides
we've been here before women blacks Jews
gays every ethnic group that has come to
our Shores and those that were here
before us have all been demonized
dehumanized legislated against
physically attacked and emotionally
tortured
the fourth time I've come to Concord to
testify on trans issues
this bill does not affect me personally
but having lived through the guilt shame
and hopelessness of being trans growing
up in the 50s and sadly still today I
want these kids to receive the dignity
and care that modern medicine and
enlightened social awareness makes
possible
to remove and criminalize the right of
self-determination to be who you truly
are what is the real child of news here
sorry please wrap up my voice my beard
my body shape my male features are all
on display bringing unwanted attention
and threats I'm willing to endure this
as judgment
to live the life I only dreamed of cried
about as a child I had to hide from the
world and adopt a false Persona just to
be safe from school and ridicule and
harm being transgender is nothing new we
have always existed the evidence is
there if you look we are simply a small
portion of the Human Condition with
every right to exist and flourish okay
thank you for your testimony are there
any questions
I'm saying Don thank you very much
appreciate it
you ever written testimony you want to
thank you
next up is the Reverend Eliza Tweedy to
sorry I thought I hit that already I'm
here to stand in opposition to House
Bill 619. the house bill is full of
Faith language so I respond in kind
the disciple Philip one day in the
earliest days of the church encountered
an Ethiopian eunuch studying scripture
now the unit would not have been allowed
into the worship space because of
cultural perceptions around his gender
and sexuality does that sound familiar
y'all
but though eunuch asked Philip what is
to prevent me being baptized and Philip
baptized them made the eunuch a full
member of the body of Christ because the
ways of God the ways of Grace and love
aren't always the ways of humans now you
might say that that was Philip not Jesus
but in Matthew 19 Jesus said that there
are eunuchs folks who fall outside of
our gender binary by birth by choice and
even by faith those are who are outside
the binary quote for the sake of the
Kingdom of Heaven a statement which
holds no condemnation in the Greek or in
the English
Matthew's gospel goes on with famous
words about how our treatment of one
another reflects directly on our
relationship with God I won't quote it
all here it's in the 25th chapter and it
ends with the note just as you do to the
least of these who are members of my
family you did it to me now Beyond
noting that there is no judgment
attached to the people whom we are
called to care for it's not those who
are sick unless they're Samaritans or
those who are hungry unless they're
queer it's interesting to me that Jesus
is calling us to love those who are
specifically not like us to learn to be
in relationship with those who are not
like us and that there is nowhere In
this passage a call to conversion of
those people
so I am at a loss today that we are
debating the rights of parents to keep
their children from those relationships
the rights of the state to keep those
children from those relationships in the
name of the Christ who calls us to love
now Paul reminds us in a very famous
passage that love is not arrogant or
boastful or rude that love does not
insist on its own way rather that love
seeks the truth perhaps indeed the same
truth that Jesus and Philip knew that
God's love cannot be confined in human
cultural understandings even about
gender and yet we debate here today
about removing the right of parents to
love their children and support them in
who they know themselves to be we debate
about communities loving children and
giving them the space and the safety to
explore who they are we pervert the
concept of love into something that
would make Jesus flip tables because
frankly creating laws that would
absolutely lead to increased rates of
suicide and self-harm Trauma and fear is
anathema to the gospel
and the fact that it's being done in the
name of Christianity despite Jesus and
Philip and Paul is abhorrent
scapegoat in one Community for the sake
of scoring political points targeting
vulnerable people to create a monolithic
culture has been tried
it never ends well
and this I know it is the mark of
fearful not faithful people it is the
mark of Temptation not discipleship and
Jesus never stands with those who are in
power but always and forever with those
who are being harmed and excluded so I
call on you today to stand with love
inclusion and Justice if you ever wanted
to say you stand with Jesus and to
please mark this bill as itl thank you
so much
representative Weber
are you taking questions Reverend
Mr chairman my question could be
answered by the clerk I just didn't get
the name of the person who just
testified
I'm the Reverend Eliza Tweedy I'm the
pastor of First Church Congregational in
Rochester thank you very much and thank
you Freda any other questions
next up to speak is Joy Douglas
Robertson to be followed by James
Marshall
hello members of the committee my name
is Joy I'm a member for the party uh of
the party for socialism and Liberation
and today I'm testifying strongly
against hb619 but I would note that what
I say speaks the entire slate of hateful
and reactionary Bills currently
disgracing these Halls
these bills are all fundamentally about
the same reactionary principles and
therefore can be addressed as one
massive hateful gibberish
firstly one of the strategies used by
the far right is to highlight those who
regret transition and exceedingly low
number compared to the usual statistics
on operational regret and yet whereas
the outrage over their regret rate for
hip replacement surgeries
where's the New York Times articles and
the alarmist testimonials on the dangers
who here is aware of the fact that 97
97 of transgender people are happy with
their decision to transition
now who here is aware that 65 percent of
the general population polls regretted
their own cosmetic plastic surgery
where is the outrage
we sit here in light of these facts but
some of you want us to highlight a
statistical anomaly they would have us
look at the sky and declare it made of
steel because they've seen a jet go by
it
secondly components of this anti-trans
bill claim to be fighting for parents
rights and indeed what a wonderful
Legacy to claim
parents race was first used to defend
child labor factories
and sense has been tied to every
reactionary principle Under the Sun
let's not forget when parental rights
were appealed to to combat School
integration parental rights has always
been a dog whistle for the worst kind of
politics and has never been a vehicle
for protecting children which we are
apparently all here to discuss
we're holding all right so we are told
that this is also about protecting
children from grooming and this is
rather curious because I do not recall
the moral outrage and calls to action
from far-right demagogues when child
beauty pageants were enjoying a popular
Spotlight on reality TV shows when it
came to the actual sexualization of
children by their own parents for a cash
prize via giant Monopoly paycheck uh
what do we get from these alarmists
silence
perhaps it's worth mentioning mentioning
that nearly a thousand people are soon
suing the sununu Youth Services Center
for childhood abuse
and now they launch an attack against
children who are trying their best to
survive in a system that wants to
eliminate them
what other hypocrisy what a transparent
farce and first it is because at its
root this is not actually about trans
Identity or protecting children this
mockery of legislation is about one
thing it's about mobilizing cisgender
white workers against Escapo this is
about keeping the people who are people
separated by encouraging those without
power to attack those with even flesh
this is the causes belly of modern
American fascism trans people have been
identified as the easiest Target to keep
us all from recognizing that our enemies
are that our enemies are not amongst the
have-nots but in fact they are the
people making Wars for profit they are
the people withholding housing and
health care they're the people hoarding
the billions and wealth that their
workers create and the politicians
judges and police employed to make sure
they can continue to do so our enemies
are not trans people the state is
already bleeding teachers medical
providers and young people in the state
what it needs most is compassion
community and new generations these
bills are documents of a creeping
fascism and they must be thoroughly
rebuked and rejected for what they are
okay next step to speak is um James
Marshall to be followed by Court Reed
hi
thank you chairwoman McDonald and
members of the committee my name is Jim
Marshall from Derry New Hampshire and
I'm here to testify against HB 619 I
specifically just
mentioned chairwoman as he had
incorrectly gendered a previous speaker
almost 20 years ago my wife and I were
anxiously awaiting the birth of our
second child I was in the delivery room
holding the scissors to cut the
umbilical cord as the baby was born
there were no cries I looked over as the
doctor and nurse ran away with the baby
in their hands and a dark purple color
I can only assume I looked at my wife
with a horrified look on my face
after a torturous few seconds went by
the baby began to cry I don't think I
heard the doctors tell me what the sex
of the baby was didn't it didn't matter
I was relieved that I was alive
fast forward 13 or 14 years my youngest
was in eighth or ninth grade they hated
going out in school going out to school
joining groups being in public they felt
out of place different
it was very clear to us that this was a
after a few weeks we went to a therapist
that specialized in depression and
transgender issues not once did our
after several months of this therapy we
just we
proceeded two trans a transgender care
service provider getting hormone
treatments we noticed a marked
improvement in my in my son's care and
his mood his willingness to come out of
his room his willingness to go to school
he actually joined groups in school
where he belonged because they were
accepted
I've taken him shooting I've helped him
learn how to drive I've helped him with
homework and other things parents do
with their kids
I sit here in front of you today without
a single doubt in my mind
that he would not be here today if I and
my wife did not support him and get him
the care that he needed
hb619 will prevent parents from doing
what I had the ability to do
set my trial to get the appropriate care
that they needed to continue living and
to be happy
HB 619 intentionally or not will cause
kids to retreat Into Darkness
or even for
if my son went to school and they had no
clubs or groups or other gender
affirming rules or policies it would
have made this process so much more
difficult
schools are here to teach kids not only
the three honors but to help them become
socially aware and productive members of
society
we should not force someone to be an
outcast simply because some people fear
them or of their lives
in regards to the so-called conversion
therapy just like an abused spouse or
child believes it is their fault that
they are getting abused or that they did
something to deserve it a child
approached by a parent or a religious
leader will be forced to realize their
parents think they are defective you
have 15 seconds so please and they will
need to be fixed
I think we can all agree that the vast
majority of children want their parents
to love them and understand them and
their approval as such they have no way
to truly oppose a push by their parents
to participate in this type of thing
department of justice justice statistics
show that hate crimes against the lgbtq
community is second only to those for
race and ethnicity intentional or not
this bill will exacerbate that thank you
for your time I urge you to vote against
this bill if you have any questions I'll
be happy to answer them questions from
committee members
next up to speak is Court read to be
thank you for your time my name is
Courtney Reed and I'm here to testify in
opposition to H.B 619 on behalf of the
American civil liberties Union in New
Hampshire
primarily because and as I'm sure we've
heard already the bill would ban gender
affirming health care for minors would
ban any affirmation related to being
transgender or non-binary in public
schools and the bill would functionally
repeal the current ban on conversion
therapy by changing the definition in a
way that fails to recognize the
coerciveness frequently inherent to this
dangerous practice
I want to point out that hb619 has been
demonstrated
in legislation similar to it in other
states that have negative health effects
on transgender youth
we are aware that gender affirming care
is widely recognized as the only
evidence-based approach to addressing
the health care needs of transgender
youth and research has found that lack
of access to gender affirming care has
yielded poor mental health outcomes for
transgender youth such as heightened
suicide societal ideation
moreover
hb619 would make schools hostile to
transgender youth
transgender youth Thrive when they're
affirmed in their agenda identity and we
know that a lot of gender affirming care
for youth is specifically related to the
ability to socially transition
the inability to use one's affirming
pronouns or participate in school sports
or use the correct bathroom or locker
room
prompts what would be
in a business aggressive policing of
one's gender identity to be able to
access bases that they should be
entitled to
uh and evidence shows that when schools
have inclusive policies where
transgender youth feel safe to play
sports or access various spaces they
report higher levels of belongingness
hb619 also as I've said would
functionally repeal New Hampshire's ban
on conversion therapy which would
inevitably put lgbtq plus granted
Staters at risk of abuse and coercion
the bill would change the definition so
that those enrolled would only be
considered enrolled in conversion
therapy if it's against their clearly
expressed will which makes it extremely
difficult to classify this harmful
practice as such especially with with
minors these just requirements are
impossible for minors to meet
and the bill also undermines
through its attempts state and federal
protections that are afforded to Granite
Staters we have constitutional and
statutory protections
for transgender individuals and those of
the lgbtq community to be free from
discrimination on the basis of sex and
gender identity and there are federal
protections that prevent from that
discrimination as well and we've seen
these protections enacted in States like
Arkansas in Alabama where gender
affirming care has been blocked by the
courts so hb619 unjustly targets
transgender and lgbtq and has no place
in the granite state and I would urge
you to oppose this Bill thank you thank
you any questions from committee members
next up is a gray Dunlap to be followed
from Concord
today I am not just standing here for
myself but I'm also here to show younger
trans people out there that there are
people who care for you and will help
fight for you
gender affirming Health Care is
life-saving health care I came out as
Trans in the ninth grade to everyone in
my life I've legally changed my name in
July of 2020 this was the start of
people knowing that I was trans but I
have been dealing with that knowledge
that I was different and not a girl
since fifth grade
this was never a quickly made decision
people never talk to me about about
trans people I didn't know the terms I
had no one to make this decision for me
except me
coming out was the best decision I've
made so far I'm happier and I made great
friends along the way this bill isn't
going to save children this bill will
harm children greatly
I've talked to some of my trans friends
and it saddens me to see how scared we
all are because of this bill
taking away gender affirming Health Care
is going to make trans kids feel like
they have no purpose in this world
because the adults that we are told are
supposed to help us and the adults we
have been told to trust all of our Lives
don't care about us because we are trans
how is this protecting children when
they feel that they are better off dead
than to stay in a state that has to
discuss whether or not they are
respected as a human being
I stand here today devastated that this
is a conversation that I need to have
with you all
thank you for your consideration and
please vote to oppose this bill I'm
willing to answer any questions that you
may have
thank you any questions from committee
members
seeing none thank you
please
next up is Melanie renfreo Hebert to be
hi good afternoon
committee for allowing this space for
all of this testimony today I did have a
rather generic testimony of my own not
based on personal experience but rather
based as my own personal experience as a
community Economic Development
specialist
um House Bill 619 prohibits gender
transition transition for youth as well
as sex and gender education in our
public schools and criminalizes
necessary Medical Care the bill is
clearly limiting the rights of a
specific population along with several
similar bills with prohibitions on
bathrooms pronouns and sports it's
seeking to codify discrimination and so
it's a little triggering transphobia in
our New Hampshire law
um and I while I did have more to share
about our school system I'm going to
leave more time and space in this
process for individuals with personal
experiences that have so informed the
committee throughout today and just to
say that I am proud to live in a
community where all voices can be heard
and in this room which I haven't been in
since the fourth grade
for the field trip we all had it you
know that
um and then I'm glad to be here today
and to see so much attention effort and
willingness to learn in this committee
and I am dismayed to find that our room
Goffstown representative who's a member
of your committee is not available today
to see the faces of these individuals as
they stand up here and tell personal and
in some cases heartbreaking stories that
need to be heard to understand
the important of opposing House Bill 619
and please Market inexperiod to
legislate and not bring it up through
this session
uh next uh signed up to speak his
journey La Ford to be followed by Anne
Blanchette
good morning my name is Journey Lafond I
am a cons conquered resident taxpayer
and therapist I'm also a wife and mother
I am also a trans non-binary individual
so I appreciate you listening to my
testimony today
I have lived in New Hampshire since 2018
and have been honored to provide Mental
Health Services to youth adults and to
families across inpatient and outpatient
environments
this couple with my post-secondary
Education and Training have given me an
intimate look at how affirming care in a
timely fashion can save lives
how seeing oneself reflected in reading
material or hearing the correct name and
pronouns used to address you without
fear of Retribution can be the deciding
factor in whether a person wants to live
to see another day
I have personally worked with so many
young people who have found themselves
questioning their Identity or
orientation and while the outcome ranges
that some people some young people
realize that they are indeed gay or
trans or asexual or even straight
there are two main paths
to these realizations and on One path a
youth experience is validated by the
people closest to them
pronoun changes uh a haircut these are
the Hallmarks of gender affirming care
at this point
usually such care could evolve into
hormone therapy rarely is the surgery
ever performed before the age of 18.
often hormones a haircut or pronoun
change is enough to see a young person
with a dire Outlook become a confident
self-assured human being
my knowledge of how gender affirming
care and education impacts the lives of
young people is also personal
when my child came to me at the age of
12 to inform me that they were
questioning their gender my fears were
not about what book influenced them to
feel this way
I wasn't afraid that they would obtain
some surgery that they couldn't reverse
my concerns were around the difficulty
of living a life where people would go
out of their way to negate my child's
existence
when my son approached me at the age of
14 to let me know that he was not my
daughter but was in fact my son
I felt proud that our family had created
an environment where he could feel safe
to ponder these things and be his
authentic self
and I was thankful for every teacher
nurse therapist who treated my son with
dignity instead of disdain
HB 619 does not seek to protect Children
and Youth it instead seeks to force
lgbtq plus young people back into the
closet back into silence back into
Danger
this bill not only proposes bans on
affirming care and education but a
re-legalization of conversion therapy a
Despicable practice that has traumatized
youth across generations and across this
country
I beg you if you care about children and
youth that care about all of them do not
pass hb619 thank you and I will take
questions if there are any thank you
and I'll pause no pause please uh any
questions from committee members
also signed up to speak as Ann
hi my name is Ian Blanchette I'm from
Lowell Massachusetts and I'm here to
voice my support for Bill H
b619 my support for this bill stems from
my personal experience my grandson a New
Hampshire resident who happens to turn
14 today
uh
has been transitioning since he was
seven years old
first socially then
as soon as was possible medically
the string this has put on our family is
immeasurable
my daughter has succeeded in blocking
contact of any kind with anyone in the
family except a brother
alienating the child from his entire
extended family that loves him cannot be
the best interest for him
I have not physically seen my grandson
or have had any contact with him in
the next time I see him I do not have
any idea what to expect
his future of is one of a lifetime of
drugs and surgeries
all part of a large social experiment
that he's used in the most vulnerable
among us our children
as test subjects
please do not allow this to continue
Lupron the most commonly used drugs to
block puberty is an extremely powerful
drug originally used to treat prostate
cancer and sex offenders
the side effects are too numerous to
mention but when ultimately combined
with cross-sex hormones primarily result
in stability
by the time this bill has passed it will
likely be too late for my grandson
not
but not for the countless other children
in their families in New Hampshire thank
you for your time
any questions thank you any questions
from committee members
also signed up to speak is Susie Colt to
be followed by jamer Wilder
good morning my name is Susie Colt and I
am from Whitefield thank you for the
opportunity to testify in this matter
the reason why I traveled all the way
from the North country is because
hb619 is Rife with so much dis
information and has the potential of
violating so many constitutional rights
that it felt it was my duty to come down
here and personally ask you to quickly
find it inexpedient to legislate my
professional background includes 15
years as an attorney
defending and promoting the civil rights
of the lgbtq community in New Hampshire
in the 90s I testified in the same
Chambers to have sexual orientation
added to the law against discrimination
which we succeeded in doing in 1997. I
helped repeal the discriminatory law
that prohibited lesbians and gays from
being adoptive and foster parents
and that happened in 1999 since that
time silver unions became law marriage
and finally gender identity was added to
the law against discrimination in 2018.
which should have been the final nail in
the coffin that gave notice to everyone
in New Hampshire that discrimination and
hate against people because of their
sexual orientation and gender identity
is illegal
sadly as evidenced by hb619 and other
such attempts to discriminate against
the lgbtq community we are still having
to fight for our basic civil rights and
it is exhausting
I agree with section 2 Roman numeral 1
of hb619 that New Hampshire has a
compelling governmental interest in
protecting the health and safety of its
citizens especially children
however this bill does not do that
instead it will cause irreparable harm
to our children
to the parents fundamental rights to
autonomy by providing parents
prohibiting from parents from obtaining
obtaining medical treatment for their
children it'll harm the medical and
mental health profession by interfering
in their Hippocratic oath to do no harm
and finally to the educational system by
muslin and censoring teachers the only
thing this bill will do is put New
Hampshire in the National Limelight
along with those States like Alabama
Texas Tennessee and Arkansas who have
passed similar bills all of which are
being challenged in the courts
you will be guaranteeing future
litigation which will be a burden on the
Attorney General's office and raise
their budgets unnecessarily having to
defend cases like this
please just remember that you are hired
and elected to make laws not break laws
you took an oath to uphold the
Constitution of the United States and
New Hampshire please wrap up if nothing
else please remember the long-held
tradition of our state's motto Live Free
or Die which guarantees New Hampshire
citizens freedom from overbearing
governmental control over our lives
thank you
a representative palazzov
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
would you agree that there are some
activities that are appropriate for
adults but not appropriate for miners
like you mentioned mileages would you
agree that
for example metal just it's more adult
activities and not for minus
thank you
uh adults can drive they can drink
miners cannot
um
I'm not sure I understand
your question fully as it relates to
this kind of Bill
follow up think of uh
so I I mean uh
things that lgbts need affirmation but
also the decision
for surgery for example or for being put
on some treatment that will be a
lifelong
is a serious decision similar to metal
can you comment on that
I'm sorry sir I I don't understand I
don't understand your question I can't
answer it sorry
thank you other questions
seeing none thank you oh I
would you agree
with me that there is a significant
difference between the prohibition
against
alcohol
at a certain age which is based on our
current understanding of brain
development which changed over time
but that there is a fundamental
difference between that even though that
is an evidence-based decision that we've
made as a society and the decision not
to follow evidence-based medical
treatment for one segment of our
population who would then be denied
the same benefits of evidence-based
understanding
thank you for your question and I do
agree with you yes
other questions
also signed up to speak is Jama Wilder
good afternoon
um first I would like to just comment
and say that one of the things stated
earlier about the eunuch in the Bible
there's no evidence that says that that
was something that he chose normally
during those times those castration
happened by force so I just wanted to
note that
I live in Hollis New Hampshire and I
have five children between the ages of 4
and 18. and I am in support of this bill
it has been widely accepted that a
child's brain does not develop until the
age of 25. until then their mental
faculties are underdeveloped their
inability to exercise careful judgment
and weigh long-term consequences for
their decisions is well documented
to allow a child under the age of 18 to
make life-alterating decisions based on
gender dysphoria cannot be reversed is
not only wrong it is child abuse from
the parents and the doctors
I had the opportunities to sit with a
man who had attempted to transition to a
woman
he lived like that for decades and when
he decided it was not what he wanted he
was left with no options of changing
back the fillers in his body could not
be removed without Distortion and the
hormones he took left his skin in
appearance permanently changed he
described a feeling of being maimed and
broken he shared with me that every man
that he knew that had received
castration surgery struggled with
suicide Suicidal Thoughts daily
I requested that our school allow him to
share his story to give the children a
chance to reconsider what they might be
doing to themselves and the school
refused
I cried many tears that day coming to
the realization that this was going to
be true for many of the children in our
country
when I was in school many girls
struggled with body dysphoria instead of
teaching them how to starve themselves
if they had anorexia or teach them how
to make themselves binge for bulimia
they were given counseling to help them
overcome their illness
I wonder if anyone in this room over the
age of 30 knew someone they grew up with
that expressed a desire to surgically
change their gender
we at need to ask ourselves why this has
become so prevalent in our culture I
would suggest that they are teaching
children to question it by teaching what
gender is in schools as young as
kindergarten
in the high school they have things on
display like the gender bread person
which explains gender to the students
these are not conversations the guidance
counselors or anyone else should be
having with Someone's Child
after summer break in 2021 my children
returned to the public school to
discover we had at least half please
stop wrapping up you have 15 seconds
we had half a dozen students change
their gender in our district
many are taking hormone alterating jobs
and at least two were planning surgeries
I would argue that changing gender does
not exist because it does not matter
what you do to the outward appearance of
a person a man is still a man and a
woman is still a Woman based on their
DNA thank you thank you God do not make
mistakes when he created classifications
[Applause]
y thank you are you taking questions
ma'am
I'm sorry are there any questions are
there any questions from committee
members
staying on thank you very much have a
also signed up to speak is Paige wood to
my name is Paige wood and I live in
Greenfield New Hampshire I'm the 29 year
old transgender woman and I strongly
oppose HB 619
this bill is a debt sentence for Trans
and genderqueer youth as it would ban
access to act information in healthcare
vital to their well-being rates of
depression and suicide among trans youth
dropped dramatically when given access
to gender affirming health care and when
they are supported by their families
schools and communities
when I was younger I had no
understanding of what being transgender
was nor did I have the access to the
necessary information to learn what
being transgender was
from the time I started puberty I was
severely depressed
I had intrusive thoughts of suicide
every day for years every single day
every single day I had suicidal
ideations and I had no idea why
I struggled with this existence for
close to 15 years attempting suicide on
more than one occasion it wasn't until
as an adult I stumbled across any
information that would save my life I
still struggled after I started posting
my gender when the day I decided to
start my transition and accept myself
was the day that the Suicidal Thoughts
stopped and they stopped entirely I've
had a zoo dog style ideation for more
than eight months and I don't expect
them to come back because I finally know
who I am and I'm proud of that person
but I was lucky
it was pure dumb luck that I did not
succeed in killing myself before
discovering who I was not everyone is so
lucky no one should have to go through
the experiences that I did but this bill
would ensure that every single trans
youth in the state of New Hampshire
would
and not all of them will survive that
experience
in May of 1933 Nazis burned 20 000 books
and journals belonging to Magnus
Hirshfield hirschfield was a Pioneer in
Charleston to research and much of that
research was destroyed in the fire today
90 years later those who know America's
right are calling for our genocide
media figure Michael Knowles recently
gave his speech at CPAC where he called
for the eradication of transgender
people to thunderous Applause
architects of this bill Representatives
Terry Roy
Janine Nader
James Bellini
Sheila Seidel Nikki McCarter Alicia
Lucas Kevin vivel and David Lowe to
consider how history will view them it
will not be kindly
if this bill passes the blood will be on
their hands I'm here today to ask the
community to in a world that stands
against us stand with us thank you
next sign up to speak is Kim Paisley to
be followed by Betsy Harrington
good morning my name is Kim Peasley I'm
a resident of Concord and I'm a parent
of a transgender son I'm here testifying
in opposition of hb619 this bill's own
summary states that it prohibits gender
transition care for minors under 18
prohibits teaching about gender identity
in public schools and changes the
definition of conversion therapy this
spot Bill flies in the face of every
Major Medical Association in the United
States it's an embarrassment it's a very
dark day in New Hampshire
as a legislator in New Hampshire you
swore to faithfully and impartially
discharge and perform all your duties
incumbent upon you as a state
representative one would assume that
this means that prior to proposing any
law to a British citizen's right at
least a modicum of research would be
conducted clearly this hasn't been done
as over 1.3 million doctors recognize
the medical necessity of transition
related care for improving the physical
and mental health of transgender people
as a parent of a transgender son it's
bills like hb619 that encourage the
daily systematic attacks on my son's
very existence and they put him in
danger
as a legislator voting in favor of these
bills you're culpable
I wouldn't wish the amount of stress
I've endured at the hands of bills like
this and willfully uninformed and
hate-filled people on anybody
despite multiple Doctorate Degrees being
a woman my biggest accomplishment is
keeping my son alive to the age of 18. I
want you all to let that sink in
on his face hb619 has hate masquerading
as fear and it is control masquerading
as protection it's born out of a willful
ignorance of the facts and it's a
blatant attempt to dehumanize a group of
people that have been deemed different
or less than by the Bill's sponsors not
only does it encourage transphobic
Behavior it requires it
trans men and women are citizens of our
country and in our state just like you
and I
we all deserve protection under the
Constitution this continued to tackle my
son and other transgender persons
discuss me and makes me angry as a
mother and as a citizen
I oppose hb619 as repugnant to their
rights and Liberties contained in the
Constitution and it must be deemed in
expedient to legislate thank you all for
your time has to answer any questions
thank you questions from committee
members
that's up to speak uh is Betsy
hi I'm Betsy Harrington from Deering I
really appreciate the opportunity to
speak today I am in support of this bill
I believe that growing up means
something when I was a kid I used to say
all the time when I grow up
when I was a kid I really wanted to be a
boy I played hockey I was the only girl
playing hockey through high school the
only girl in the team I tried out
through the Olympics when I was 26.
and I felt really alone being the only
girl
but I was told by my father when I told
him I wanted to be a boy around the age
of four when I was playing beginners
hockey because everything I liked was
boy I didn't like anything about girls
at all I just wanted to be a boy
everything about being a boy was way
cooler
but he said when you grow up when you
grow up you get to decide what you want
to be right
so I feel like we still need to do that
when you grow up you get decide I love
every one of you I'm a therapist I was a
sex offender therapist at the prison I
have worked with transgender people
gender dysphoric people I think it's
okay to say we wait until you're 18. I
think we can support those kids in other
ways but
I don't think that having surgery or
giving them medications that could
ultimately castrate them people here
lied to you and said that those things
are pausing they are not pausing a lot
of those drugs castrate our children
they can never have children so like me
if they change their mind and realize
that they want to be a girl now they can
never have kids
so when they grow up is something
important and I urge you to wait until
they grow up
thank you
you want questions or any questions with
representative McLean
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um so my question is
um with regards to your capacity as a
therapist we heard a testimony earlier
on from the medical community and the
ACLU that gender affirming therapy is
the only evidence-based approach to
addressing uh the issue with gender
dysphoria so Mental Health Care is not
an evidence-based approach to handle
this well so that's my question so are
you aware of other evidence-based
approaches aside from we would do
medical mental health care until they
were 18 and I believe that that would be
very effective we can affirm them we
other questions
I'm seeing none thank you
next up to speak is Kurt donated to be
is he here
not seeing okay
all right moving on uh next up to speak
is Nina scrakuzi to be followed by Eva
Ford
hi well
my name is Dr Nina strakuzi I live in
Dover New Hampshire and I teach
sociology at the University of New
Hampshire and I'm here to express my
strong opposition to HB 619
I've been teaching for 25 years
I teach sexual behavior
sociology of the family gender medical
sociology and I would be remiss if I
were not to include the lgbtq plus
community and talk about the challenges
they confront in my classes
I've had dozens of trans students over
the years many with whom I've developed
close relationships and I've been
following changing policies that impact
the lgbtq plus Community for a very long
time
until recently I believe that as a
society we were moving in the right
direction albeit slowly and at least on
a college campus I could see the
progress
whereas trans students used to be
reticent about openly navigating the
world as trans 15 or 20 years ago they
now seem more comfortable and for the
most part they feel safer accepted and
cared about at least in my Camp my
classroom and other Havens around campus
how do I know that years of personal
conversations with students observations
and my experience as an ally
HP 619 would not only derail the
progress I've seen in one Fell Swoop it
would be denying basic human rights
not misgendering my students is the bare
minimum I can do to create a hospitable
learning environment and treat them with
respect
HB 619 would require teachers to
misgender and dead name students or risk
losing their jobs
forcing people to enact harm on the
students they're meant to support makes
creating an equitable and safe learning
environment impossible
the fact that HB 619 is even on the
docket has already resulted in my
students feeling threatened as it sends
a clear anti-trans message they are
especially concerned for friends they
have still in high school
things stand despite some positive
change not everyone feels accepted in
all aspects of their lives and that is
one reason why it is so important to
provide a supportive environment for
Trans students without feeling
threatened every time they turn around
they can focus on their education which
is the reason they're at UNH it's very
difficult to learn when your identity is
under siege
you've already heard the data on
violence against trans people poor
mental health outcomes and increased
risk for suicide
all young people in America are
experiencing a mental health crisis and
trans youth are certainly faring far
worse there are multiple reasons to
imagine HB 619 will exacerbate these
issues and if those data aren't enough
to sway anyone let's not forget the
economic cost of a decline in the mental
health and well-being of a population
I'm not sure HB 619 has a plan to
account for the large economic costs to
those Afflicted with mental health
disorders their families in society as a
whole
good physical and mental health are
essential to a productive economy poor
mental health
or mental health leads to worse
educational outcomes and lesser
likelihood of being in the labor force
as a professor of more than two decades
I love all my students trans students
included and I cannot bear to look into
any of their faces should these bills
come to pass I can't even believe I live
in a state that would even consider such
blatant discrimination against a group
of students I urge you to vote itl and
hb619 thank you thank you questions from
committee members
I've signed up to speak as he before to
be followed by representative Emily
Phillips
hello my name is Ava Ford and I'm from
Dover New Hampshire I'm here
representing New Hampshire youth
movement to speak in opposition to HB
I believe in public education that
provides a sanctuary for all students
regardless of their gender identity the
color of their skin or the money in
their pockets
hb619 does nothing to address the real
problems facing kids and teenagers today
like bullying housing insecurity gun
violence and a mental health crisis
that's been skyrocketing to the point
where our local high schoolers had to
propose their own bill this session in
an effort to get their needs addressed
this bill actively causes harm and
violence to any student who does not
align with the rigid gender binary and
anyone who supports them it 'd be the
goal of teachers and administrators to
Foster an environment in which all
children can participate in their
learning but hb619 would make that
impossible by forcing teachers to
misgender and dead name their students
every day if teachers choose to ignore
this bill and continue to respect their
students gender identities they risk
being fired this bill is rooted in
Conservative Christian beliefs that
seeks divorce students and staff to
operate within the gender binary and
adds extreme consequences for anyone who
speaks of an alternative
school is supposed to be a place where
we learn to interact with people who are
different from us not create more
division among cisgender people and
anyone outside the gender binary
that bill is a pipeline to increase
rates of bullying and violence for Trans
kids while I don't agree with HB 619 and
some of you may not agree with me we
don't need to agree today because we
have a separation of church and state
the purpose of public education is not
to exercise one opinion onto everyone
else the purpose is to provide children
with many perspectives and give them the
tools to navigate this complicated World
once they become adults that's why we
have teachers and administrators with
Advanced degrees to invest in the
education of our children if parents are
upset with the curriculum they might
want to consider homeschooling some of
the arguments in favor of HB 619 are
resting on some of the same logic used
in 1954 when white parents fought to
keep schools segregated in fear of their
white children interacting with black
children requiring trans students to
conform to the gender binary that
actively harms them won't stop trans
kids from being trans and I can't
imagine any ulterior motive other than
trying to make cisgender students more
comfortable
is this the direction we want to go in
we all know the quote those who fail to
learn from history are bound to repeat
it creating learning environments that
exclude trans children won't just harm
the trans children it will also harm
their families their peers and their
Educators why is it so wrong for our
students to learn to be empathetic and
treat everyone with dignity and respect
our society is becoming increasingly
diverse and we should be learning to
work with those who are different from
us not draw deeper lines in the sand
telling those who are different they
need to stop being themselves so that
other people can be more comfortable
I'm here because I do not believe this
bill serves any purpose aligned with
quality education or protecting children
requiring some students to hide who they
are for the comfort of others protects
no one it just creates more pain I love
the trans people in my life and I'm
grateful they didn't have to endure an
educational experience as discriminatory
and dehumanizing as hb619 anyone who
believes in protecting children and and
please stop wrapping up you have 15
seconds this bill please vote itl on HP
619 thank you I will not be taking
questions thank you
Nick signed up to speak as
representative Emily Phillips to be
okay
okay proceeding on then uh next up
okay okay all right uh so next up is it
Scott and then I'll be representative
Phillips
okay
all right
I apologize I'm Emily Phillips I
represent Fremont New Hampshire
Rockingham District Seven I was waiting
in the ante room because I have a noise
maker with me I support this bill I want
to just make a statement and I hope I'm
not repeating it but the state of New
Hampshire does not allow children to get
tattoos because children cannot consent
to permanently altering their body we do
not know the long-term effects of
Decades of cross-sex hormones I know
that there's a link to cancer
will it cause for infertility we're just
not sure I think we should protect New
Hampshire's children thank you thank you
are you taking questions or you're all
set
and I'm not sure there's any questions
anyway so thank you
okay again next signed up to speak is
actually Scott to be followed by Paul uh
sontak
good morning
um I am Archer Scott and I grew up in
New Hampshire and chose to come back to
attend to Plymouth State University
as a current resident and a Trends
non-binary person I urge a committee to
oppose H.E 6119
I grew up knowing that I was different
from the girls around me I never wanted
to wear dresses or skirts didn't enjoy
playing dress-up or with dolls and it
wasn't exciting for me when puberty hit
but rather a large Catalyst for my
struggles with mental health
I started to realize what exactly being
different could mean in high school
during an assembly where I was first
exposed to the lgbtq community in the
following years I continued to learn
about different sexual and gender
experiences through my own research and
students and teachers who spoke on their
experiences
part of this bill aims to prohibit
gender transition procedures to minors
that would be catastrophic to the trans
youth of our state
for me it was around the time that
puberty hit that my mental health
started rapidly declining gender
dysphoria is brutal my body didn't fit
like I had to put on a shirt that was
too tight and could never take it off
I was suicidal for a large part of my
teen years because death seemed a better
option than living in an identity that
wasn't mine
what was the point in living when I went
through everyday hating myself
I grew up in a period of time where
trans identities weren't well known and
there was no media attention on the
topic there is a lot of hate and
violence directed towards the trends
used now through the media and I can't
imagine trying to keep fighting while my
community was being openly attacked
I'm an adult now I've realized my
identity and started my own process of
gender transition when the hormones
started taking effect on my body and I
finally learned what it was like to love
myself looking in the mirror it was
life-changing
but I missed out on a large part of my
teenage years and it was preventable I
think it's appropriate that the world
professional association for transgender
Health recommends it after a
multi-disciplinary assessment youth be
allowed to start hormone replacement
therapy as young as 14 so they
experience puberty with their peers if
I've had the opportunity to go on
puberty blockers if I'd been taught
about the lgbtq community in school if
I'd been able to start hormone therapy
as a young teen my life would look very
different right now
trying to see if they're being attacked
across the country right now and it
sends a very clear message that they are
not important that their lives and
identities don't matter
this bill would have extremely harmful
impacts for Trans youth so I urge a
committee to vote
itl on hb6 and 18. thank you for your
time I will not be accepting questions
signed up to speak is Paul sanchak to be
thank you very much
um it'll be a feeling of privilege to be
able to
to talk today and give a perspective I
hope
um I do want to thank representative Roy
when he started off and introduced the
bill that he said that his main purpose
was to um to look you know and try to
increase conversation around this
particular topic which we really all are
struggling with
I personally have been a a teacher in
I've been a teacher for 30 years
I have participated in I was a pastor
for 11 years
I'm now working in a Recovery Center
than in Milford New Hampshire I I kind
of referenced Milford because most
likely you have seen Milford in the news
these days and I would
one of my main points the reason I came
here was here is that I saw the bill as
something that was um would possibly
help us understand the jurisdictions
between you know who has responsibility
for children and I'm real concerned
about 18 and under like everybody else's
and I would really would like to affirm
the LGBT community is that as a recovery
coach which I am right now and working
in the in the trenches with everybody
else that compassion is the number one
love and number one is the compassion
for all of you that are involved in that
particular situation and for someone who
is somewhat out of the loop or was under
the out of the loop I've learned a lot
from listening even here today
so my real concern here is that and if I
was going to as a medical health worker
as well as a recovery coach
you know with addiction and those types
of things what I've heard from them is
that as a mental health worker 80
percent of the problems would be solved
in our schools and and with the youth
and especially those that are habitated
dysphoria is if they had a safe place
and a safe person affirming laws can't
really do this okay and if we did pass
these laws they wouldn't really have a
lot of effect but they do resist evil
and they do provoke the things that are
good so my suggestion today is that um
is that came from the beginning is this
if we could have emotionally healthy
conversations with one another and even
here today I can if I say I support this
bill I'm not sure if I can go back to my
seat or someone just say is hate speak
that I would actually support it in
reality I I think it's inexperedient to
to legislate but it is bringing up a lot
of questions
and that is that we have to have those
open conversations with one another and
both sides need to come together and I
would love to be part of that situation
if anybody would like to have that
conversation thank you very much thank
you
before I go to the next speaker uh it is
noon we are going to continue if there's
no objection from committee committee
members we're going to continue we
appreciate all of you coming and we know
you have a schedule to keep also so
we're going to continue this hearing uh
committee members can go to lunch as
they as they feel is appropriate and as
their as their biological clock or their
stomach tells them to so we're going to
continue uh going
um if there's no objections from
committee members next step to speak is
Bridget KIVI to be followed by Kathy
schlotman
hello my name is Bridget kievy uh born
and raised Nashua New Hampshire
I've been going by the name brick for
three years now and I wanted to come up
by my legal name
to show you that there are already so
many hurdles in the way of transitioning
you have to change your documents or
your legal name
in order to change physically you have
to get notices from doctors and
therapists and it's a long and arduous
Journey
I have worked with the Trans youth from
this state and from all over this
country for a couple years now
and they are very well educated on how
they feel on who they are and what
hormone replacement therapy means for
them currently and in the long run and
as are their parents this is a decision
that is made by the family unit by the
doctors by the therapists this is not a
decision to be made legally
in the courts in this room
this is for individuals to decide
I hope you keep that in mind and I hope
also signed up to speak is Kathy
schlachman to be followed by Nancy
Brennan
good afternoon my name is Kathy
first of all I'd like to thank you so
much for all of you do
I really appreciate all the hard work
you do for the citizens of New Hampshire
so thank you
second
I would like to share three sections
from the Bible
to you there is much I could share
personally on my thoughts and opinions
in regards as HB 619 however the most
important words that we can all learn
and glean and learn from God's word is
the Bible
you're all sworn into office with your
hands placed on the Bible your hand was
on the outside however what's inside is
the most important
it's what's inside that matters
I believe in the word of God this is his
word and I believe it
here are the three sections from the
Bible that I'm going to read the first
one is from Genesis 1 26 to 28 and verse
31.
then God said let us make Mankind in our
image in our likeness so that they may
rule over the fish and the Sea and the
birds in the sky over all the livestock
and all the wild animals and over all
the creatures that move along the ground
so God created Mankind in his own image
in the image of God he created them male
and female he created them
finally in verse 31 God said all he had
God saw all he had made
and it was very good
and there was evening and there was
these are the words and I pray you
receive them
second verses from Psalms
Psalms 139 13-14 for you created my
inmost being you met me together in my
mother's womb I praise you because I'm
fearfully and wonderfully made your
works are wonderful I know that full
well
I pray you hear these words and receive
them
finally this is from Philippians 4 6
finally brothers and sisters whatever is
true whatever is Noble whatever is right
whatever is pure whatever is lovely
whatever is admirable if anything is
excellent worth it think about those
things so I pray that you
will vote according to them I pray they
will do is what is right in honorable
and Noble and I want you to know that I
pray for each and every one of you I
thank God for you and I ask God's
blessings to come upon you thank you no
next up to speak is Nancy brenned to be
thank you
Brennan I'm from where she her
I oppose 619 for two reasons one it is
based on inaccurate and misleading
information and two it does major harm
to our transgender and non-binary
population I have done some research too
much to share with you in three minutes
so I will be sending it to you via email
here's one example of something I found
the bill States studies consistently
demonstrate the majority of kids come to
identify with their biological sex in
adolescence and adulthood this is a lie
it is based on inaccurate outdated
studies and faulty methodology
recent accurate studies such as one in
the journal Pediatrics found 94 of
transgender youth maintain their gender
identity
this bill on page three calls for the
prohibition of gender transition care
for children and young adults they're
mainly talking about puberty blockers
and cross-sex hormones the bill States
risks outweigh benefits this is not true
yes there are some risks as there are in
every medication we take you know what
has risks
ibuprofen in severe cases it can cause
heart attack stroke kidney and liver
failure and ulcers ibuprofen as for
hormone and puberty blockers doctors who
actually work with trans youth
acknowledge the risks and are working to
mitigate them they feel the benefits far
outweigh the harm our transgender and
non-binary youth are real and their
right to exist should not be dismissed a
hateful speaker at CPAC this weekend
said transness needs to be eradicated no
it needs to be understood the bill says
there is no credible scientific evidence
that a person is anything other than the
gender and biological sex they are born
with I have included in what I will be
sending you a piece from Scientific
American that totally refutes that
please please do not pass this bill that
renders these kids invisible that forces
teachers to dead name them and deny
their very existence I have transgender
and non-binary people in my life in my
family they are real any confusion
children may have about their gender is
only exacerbated by confusion about why
they are being treated in such a hateful
manner why they have to show up day
after day to say we exist look at them
listen to them believe them please stop
wrapping up 15 seconds
support them
their way of being
[Music]
this bill does
please no applause
next signed up to speak is a hell of
Mullins to be followed by representative
Jerry Cannon
all right cool thank you guys for having
me I'm Heather Mullins and um I'm
speaking in support of banding gender
affirming care for minors
um not that I don't agree that there are
people that genuinely suffer from gender
dysphoria or chromosomal abnormalities
that actually cause them to be born with
multiple reproductive organs and the
parents have to make a decision at Birth
um there's a social contagion going on
right now where an assumption that every
child every minor that thinks they have
gender dysphoria actually does and
there's two organizations I implore you
to look into one of them is called gays
against rumors and it's actually members
of the lgbtq community that strongly
speak out against pushing these these
kinds of drastic measures on minors
because there are portions of the
population that do outgrow them another
organization called the changed movement
our former lgbtq members that now live
heterosexual lives and outgrew that
um so for the young children that are
actually struggling legitimately with
these issues all we are asking is that
you give it a few years and allow them
to see if they're one that outgrow it or
if they're actually somebody who is just
struggling with finding an identity
during some of the most controversial
hormonal periods of a child's life I can
personally say going through high school
I went through my own series of phases
and now here I am today so I have
tattoos that I got when I was 17 that
when people ask me about them I say it's
a bad decision for my youth I'm thankful
that that wasn't a decision that
permanently prevented me from having
children as I have a 13 year old
daughter who I care about dearly at the
end of the day anybody suffering from
any sort of anxiety depression or gender
dysphoria we want to affirm those kids
but we want to affirm them that they are
perfect just the way they are and that
if they decide later in life to make
changes we will support them but to go
into a child's mind and tell them that
they need to make these drastic
decisions in order to be whole to me is
criminal in this child abuse we need to
love our children and we need to affirm
them that they're perfect just the way
they are and not childhood not do this
stuff that's going to give them
irreparable damage later in life and
there are members of the lgbtq community
that have done this and regret the
decision but they're not given a seat at
the table like we heard another woman
say she tried to have someone that
regretted that decision going to a
school to speak and I think it's really
important that everybody gets a seat at
the table and we don't write off the
people that are actually suffering
you're a suicidal ideation because they
chose to do it thank you thank you
I would point out that we have a great
sound system here in the house chamber
these microphones are really sensitive
and I if you're not used to used to them
I can understand why you may think you
need to be closer or speak louder than
you do but um but please keep that in
mind but thank you
next step to speak is a representative
Jerry cannon from our committee and to
thank you Mr chair and my fellow members
on the committee
we live in the land of the free and the
home of the brave
some of the bravest people I know are
transgender people
they face a lot as you've heard today
there's a lot of challenges we face
so what parent
wouldn't want to take care of their
children what parent wouldn't do
everything possible to help their child
when they've been diagnosed with a
School
is where children learn many subjects as
well as how to socially interact with
others
or transgender child this is a critical
step in their transition and for many
it's a continuation of the social
experience they may have started in
kindergarten
parents of transgender children want to
see their child grow and become a
successful member of society
attending school
as the gender they identify is a
critical part of their growth
I struggled as a transgender child
who couldn't attend school as the gender
I identify as
I was a depressed child and a poor
performer in school I was also a target
for school bullies
as I was a feminine boy
without the ability to come out as a
transgender woman or girl at the time
or suppress hormones during my puberty
years I became depressed and gender
confused as an adult
hormone blockers weren't available back
then and I'm not sure if I would have
during the three years following High
School I misused alcohol
and totaled two cars
while driving in Paris I'm grateful to
be here today
in this very competitive World a child
needs every Advantage they can get to
get the best job available a transgender
child and their parents have a lot more
information available
to them as they grow
especially
when I was 50 years ago in school
if you think keeping teachers from
talking about transgender people or
limiting access to library books will
stop children from learning about their
condition think again
the internet is here it has a wealth of
knowledge available to transgender
children and their parents
I know
Lynn Conway and you probably know her as
well when you use your phone or use your
PC she was one of the people who
patented the process of creating vlsi
chips that are in any of our devices
that we use these days
yeah
she was a transgender woman
in the past 10 years
the number of medical professionals with
transgender expertise in the Northeast
has grown dramatically
these professionals our work are aware
of the DSM the diagnostic and
statistical manual on mental disorders
the fifth edition which identifies the
standards of care for transgender
children and adults
children should be children and families
should be working with gender
knowledgeable therapists and involve
endocrinologists oh as only if puberty
blockers are a part of a child's
transition plan
hormone replacement therapy and surgical
transition procedures are rarely
performed until a child turns 18 years
old and can make their own decision
HP 16
8619 presents a lot of information about
all aspects of transgender adult care
the section concerning transgender youth
Health Care is substantially inaccurate
as it includes surgical procedures and
hormone treatments typically initiated
when a child turns 18 and the child then
adult can make the decisions about their
health care
my biggest problem with this bill is
that it discriminates against a very
small minority of students in New
Hampshire the total population of
transgender people is somewhere around 4
500 people or
0.43 of our population
why is this bill just focused on
transgender students
why wasn't focused on any child that's
getting therapy and medication in
elementary school
this transgender students
have the same same challenges
sorry
this bill will force the state to break
our own statutes our own laws that are
in place to protect transgender people
and students in the packets I've given
the committee it identifies those
[Music]
section 193 colon 38
193 Dash F colon 2.
4-81 colon 1 and 35
even today there is legislation being
proposed in this house to vilify parents
who care about their transgender
children
we have legislation being heard to make
sure parental rights are honored by
schools when they should know what is
happening in schools
this bill is about taking parental
rights away when they want to take care
of their children this is crazy
this bill mentions faith in the bill it
implies that faith is an important part
of educating transgender children and
maybe parents of transgender children
aren't teaching Faith to their children
what faith is this bill talking about I
am a Christian
in my UCC Church welcomes transgender
children and their families so does the
Episcopal Church some Methodist churches
synagogues and many others
the last time I checked We Are All God's
Children
we are taught to love one another and
our neighbors
this bill shows no love for transgender
finally this bill is government
intrusion into the lives of transgender
children and their families
the last time I checked we don't live in
a state-controlled society
the care of our children is best left in
the hands of their parents and Health
Care Professionals not the State House
that's essentially the decision we're
giving our transgender kids
they really ought to be living free
thank you representative Cannon thank
you are you taking questions Matt yes I
will please are you taking questions
from committee members
also signed up to speak is Elliot
uh all right hello good morning New
Hampshire boarding committee alike my
name is Elliot beninotti I am previous
vice president of Nashville community
college's gender and sexuality Alliance
and lifelong resident of New Hampshire I
am transgender and non-binary my
pronouns are they them and I am here to
strongly testify opposition to
um
I remember being a child in the older
than 11 crying and sobbing in the mirror
and lamenting over the fact that
something has happened to my body that
was not right
I wasn't supposed to look like this and
I held my mother tight and I begged her
to make it stop that I did not want to
live this way did I said I did not want
to grow up it would take me another five
years to learn that it wasn't that I was
scared to grow up I was scared to be in
a body that didn't reflect my truest
self and I was scared to be trapped for
the rest of my life
I was never given the tools and language
to describe that feeling that didn't
stop me from being trans a trans kid it
didn't stop me from feeling loss and
displacement it only kept me confused
and unaware that my experiences are
shared by hundreds of thousands I
grieved the confused and unaware or
sorry I agree with the possibilities
that could have been now my only option
to find Solace is behind over a hundred
thousand dollars in medical costs
years-long referral process and time
away from my education and job there are
met those in favor of this bill seem to
only care about the pain if the
individual in question isn't trans
though
when I first came out I quickly heard
Notch mention it around children my
existence was rated X belong behind a
black sensor bar last night in danger
the children around me what about the
children who were like me what about
that kid crying in the mirror and
clutching their mother in a way that
they had never before how much of that
anger and confusion could have been
prevented if I had somebody like me then
what if I saw trans princesses in my
fairy tales non-binary teachers in my
classes any sort of insinuation that our
lives were more than a joke what if we
have spent not spent so long wanting to
die
I think a lot of anti-trans ideology
comes from a fear of the unknown that
people don't want their children to be
too different from them or don't want to
have struggles that they are unfamiliar
with a raising trans people from every
place you can from the medical system to
our school system will not prevent your
children from being trans it will only
prevent them from knowing who they are
and finding their Joy these bills will
result in the death of New Hampshire
citizens children and adults alike
love your children embrace them as their
truest self and you'll find they will
embrace you in return we've heard
stories of parents saying that their
child being trans ruined their
relationship and that's why it's a
problem
[Music]
that's beyond the child being trans
we've heard people claim that we need to
protect a gene pool we're talking about
Eugenics which is incredibly weird and
hypocritical
just gotta say it um
yeah we need to embrace trans children
as their truest self and they will
embrace you in return
my mom is here with me today and I
couldn't be happy because if you could
please start wrapping up you've got 15
seconds got it
um anybody of live trans experience will
tell you that the misinformation in this
bill is extensive both about our health
care and the people who we are to begin
with this bill claims the statements
made in our scientifically backed
despite citing no sources five minutes
and Google will show you dozens of
peer-reviewed studies that debunk the
many claims transition education saves
lives we are your neighbors your
employees your teachers and your mailmen
we hold the door for you at Starbucks
and we let you cross the street even
though you don't have the right away we
are all around you every single day
everywhere you go whether you realize it
or not we have always been here and we
always will be trans Joy will prevail
despite it all
thank you very much no applause please
thank you
next signed up to speak is Bill Bloom to
be followed by Don Johnson
good afternoon everyone my name is Bill
Blum and I strongly oppose this bill
today's more so than ever the trans
Community is facing continued attacks
based on fear
and not facts
more specifically our young marginalized
community members who do not have the
right to vote yet
and I'm here to also give a voice to the
silent
these are our kids who are our neighbors
our community members
and our future leaders
some will say that changing one's gender
is something that should be reserved to
only someone who is over 18.
I'm not sure how someone who is 17 is
unable to make these decisions and
someone who is over 18 is
so I will rely on the experts to make
that choice
if I'm to speak on numbers there are
approximately 1.4 million people who
live in the state of New Hampshire and
18 of that are under 18 years of age or
approximately 259 000 give or take
if I'm to take National numbers and
apply them to the state
the trans population nationally is
around one percent
so therefore in state of New Hampshire
it's about 25 2600 people that
identified as trans individuals
although the number may seem small
I will say that when one suffers we all
suffer
Additionally the American Medical
Association members are 1.4 million
people which is very close to the total
population of the state
agree that providing gender affirming
care is what is in the best interest of
the children I'll say that again in case
you're on your phones
the entire state population of New
Hampshire is also
equivalent to the American Medical
Association community that says that
gender affirmative care is the right
thing to do
but I will not leave space for is a tax
on our children's basic human rights
during my time here I've learned that if
you're to find a successful Society one
key indicator is to look at the children
if the kids are educated healthy and
thriving then the society is inherently
good if there's conflict of War then the
kids are malnourished deprived of a good
education and clean water we're living
in
who are living in fear of their lives so
I ask you why are we choosing to harm
the children and incur harm to their
civil rights in existence that
discriminates based on gender identity
and at the same time not allow one to
it's like saying guns are legal to own
and use however you can never buy one or
even make one
please stop with this outrageous and
hurtful legislation that goes against
The Proven experts and let's start
focusing on things that really can make
a difference
thank you thank you you're welcome
you're taking questions absolutely any
questions from committee members
I'm saying thank you
next up to speak is Don Johnson to be
followed by and I am probably not going
to do this name correctly Ethan Jacob
jacobovitz
um Tatum
a few members
my name is Don Johnson and I'm from
I have a couple of statements and then I
have a brief statement um
in regards to
um a comment that was made based off of
off of the Bible
today we've heard testimony that
from doctors
well we all know that the doctors
maybe not all of them but many of them
have created the opioid crisis that we
have today throughout the country
medical error is the is the third
leading debt cause of death according to
John Hopkins 2016.
study
they also told us that mass work we all
this is not to attack our doctors
this is to remind us that they are human
and there is error
these medical procedures called health
problems from heart disease to bone
created man and God created women
no human is perfect we all make mistakes
we all are to love one another pray for
one another and help them when they need
it
his words and his Commandments are what
we should be following that is based on
the Bible that is based on the laws that
this country and this world was founded
on
and if we cannot follow the Commandments
then we must pray for those who cannot
and hopefully they see the light God
thank you
next sign up to speak and again I'll
I'll try atham jacobowitz uh Tatum
uh I am to be followed by Ellen and Joe
Galla I am so sorry about that hi uh
it's Athena actually uh my name is
jacobowitz I'm a transgender woman from
uh Massachusetts I've been doing
um and honestly you've all heard a bunch
of people already today like you've
heard every doctor and every trans
person be pretty aligned with how we
feel we should be treated by the law
so I want to talk to you about something
real personal
uh about why it's important for kids to
be able to talk about their gender
I came out and I figured out my vendor
about 15 years ago and the world was not
nearly as
uh as accepting of trans people then
uh
forgive me this is
a little hard and I didn't have anybody
to talk to
at all
and I was the first generation of
Internet kids you know I had dial up I
played Neopets uh
and so when I had nobody in my life to
support me and I didn't know if I could
tell my parents or not because I knew
that sometimes you get disowned if you
tell your parents that you're trans
so so often they're not the first people
that you go to if you're not sure if
they're safe sometimes you want to go to
like a trusted teacher or something
I didn't have any of those
instead I went on the internet
[Music]
and I was about 17
I can't Maybe 15.
I have a lot of missing memories from
this period of time that I'm still
sorting through
I knew that I was different
I went online I found somebody who
understood that I was different
unfortunately this person was not a good
person
and they figured out
that I would what I was before I did and
they figured out that that gave them
power over me because if they were the
only person in my life who uh who
recognized me as a woman and they could
convince me to keep myself closeted and
isolate myself that uh then because they
were the only person who was giving me
something I needed they could manipulate
me for sexual favors
and they absolutely did from uh again
this person was 42 I know I was 17 when
things started uh
turning sexual I know that it really
badly damaged me
if you pass this bill
stuff like that is going to happen more
because
you're you'll be taking away so many
people that uh
in their actual lives that kids can go
and talk to about what's going on with
them
and you'll be forcing them to go look
for answers elsewhere because I I was
never going to stop being trans and I
was never going to stop having the
questions about myself that I had
and eventually I found people who are
able to help me and give me the answers
that I needed without trying to take
advantage of me I'm not trans because
this uh shitty man on the internet took
advantage of me
but I am a sexual assault Survivor
because of that
and I don't think we want that happening
to kids
so that's why I'm asking you
don't let this bill through
this will create more victims of sexual
violence if you vote vote Yes on this
bill you have 15 seconds please that's
it trans rights are human rights uh
thank you very much for listening and
I've opened anybody has any questions
this is what a trans woman looks like
after we get all the treatment and care
that we need
any questions from committee members
okay saying none thank you very much
thank you for your time I hope you have
a great day and I hope that you vote
this bill down before we proceed to the
next speaker I'd like to invite the vice
chairman up Erica Leon to take the chair
I'm going to go to lunch and remind
committee members accept that discretion
as to when they want to do so we're
thank you very much Mr chairman and uh
since I have the microphone thank you
for sharing that vulnerable story we
really appreciated that and for you
opening up next we call Ellen and Joe
hello everyone we are Ellen and Joe
Gallo we're from Derry
we oppose HB 619 before I get into the
prepared testimony I did want to let all
of you know just in case you hadn't you
didn't already know this earlier in
someone's testimony they talked about a
group called gays against groomers to uh
to in support of this bill and I just
wanted to let you know that gays against
groomers is considered a hate Group by
the lgbtq nation the center of extremism
and the Anti-Defamation League so I just
wanted you to know that
this is our first time coming to the
state house to testify and we are here
to tell you about our transgender
daughter Joyce
we are and always have been a tight-knit
communicative loving and supporting
family we spend as much time together as
we can we rely on one another and we
truly enjoy each other's company
Joyce is our third and youngest child
she was the missing puzzle piece in our
family and brought all of us together
with her abundance of love
from the time any personality showed and
until she turned 15 she'd always have
been best described as happy-go-lucky
Carefree friendly and really funny
her whole life she was always to
everyone totally irresistible
seemingly overnight our Smiley sunshiny
wickedly funny 15 year old went
completely dark
I don't want to share too many personal
details of her journey or of our
family's experience publicly and will
not answer questions today but if you
are inclined I will provide my email
address and we'll answer questions if
you have them
I will tell you though that this journey
has been all the things
but those particular years were all the
really hard things
coming to coming out
honoring and embracing your truth is a
different experience for everyone
Joyce's was particularly painful we had
to take her out of school and at one low
point we spent almost a week in the
hospital's emergency room held without
care or treatment
I say we because I slept in that bed
with her every night
as parents we did all the things we
questioned we researched we Enlisted the
help of therapists and Specialists we
doubted we cried we learned we
deliberated with caution care and
diligence
while she slowly at her own pace
transitioned socially and over time we
came to know and embrace this truth of
who our child was we found a school that
honored and supported her and once she
had socially transitioned for
predetermined time and under the care of
medical professionals we agreed that it
was time to introduce gender affirming
medicine
and that was when her light began to
shine again
and a high school senior
she is a valued member of her school
Community respected by her peers and
teachers alike
she is a servant leader wise gentle and
compassionate most of the time she's
happy-go-lucky carefree and really funny
again too
although the road ahead mostly due to
outside forces such as bills like this
one will be challenging we are so
grateful to watch her future unfold just
as any parent does at this milestone
gender affirming care in both medicine
and in the classroom very likely saved
our daughter's life
we are good present and dedicated
parents and it is our opinion that if
this Bill had passed five years ago we
would have held a funeral
rather than her graduation party this
summer
we ask you please don't interfere with
the medical decisions between a doctor a
patient and their parents
and please don't put up more barriers to
them in their important social and
school Community by prohibiting or
restricting teachers from supporting
these kids
please vote in expedient to legislate on
House Bill 619 thank you
thank you very much
next we have Sharon Boyd followed by
happy Tuesday everyone
my name is Sharon Boyd I'm from Chester
New Hampshire I'm opposed to this
legislation please excuse my appearance
I was expecting to show support today
but not actually speak to you all
and thank you for working through lunch
and yes I am a transgender woman my
pronouns are she her
at 10 I knew something was wrong
I didn't have the words for it my brain
didn't have to be fully developed for me
to know that something was wrong
I graduated from the United States Naval
Academy at 21. I served as a naval
officer for eight years the entire time
if I had come out I would have had a
dishonorable discharge overnight and I
probably would have gotten beaten to it
in an inch of my life
I started transitioning last year
my grandson lives in Arkansas he's 15.
he's trans
he came out just before I did I didn't
know he was going to come out and he
didn't know I was going to come out
he attempted suicide three weeks ago
he's okay
he was bullied in school
mostly about
the prospect of detransitioning as it
looks like Arkansas is about to mandate
if he was in New Hampshire
a New Hampshire without this legislation
going through I think he would never
have attempted suicide I think you'd be
I can't make you all
truly understand
how it feels to have your body not match
your identity
I just don't have the words for it and
Lord knows I've tried
goodness knows the kids don't have those
words for it they can't communicate
other than something is wrong and that's
even with the internet showing them
please don't deny
these children
what they need while you seek an
understanding of what it means to be
transgender when you are never going to
be able to have that visceral
and a few people have said well
kids can wait till they're 18 to make
you will never understand also
how painful it is
to children
that are experiencing a puberty that
forcing them to delay the decision until
their brain is fully formed is
tantamount to making an extremely
painful decision for them because they
are going to endure a puberty that is
itself irreversible that they don't want
and I'm open to questions
thank you any questions
seeing none thank you very much
next now we have Brady Berry and up up
after that is Mr rosivi
thank you
um and good afternoon my name is Brady
Berry I'm a senior social work student
at the University of New Hampshire in
Durham
um and I'm here to testify in opposition
to HB 619
as a transgender person who has spent a
significant amount of time working with
transgender and non-binary kids it is
important to me that we ensure the
rights of this population
aspect of this bill threatens trans kids
in its own unique way but today I'm
going to focus on education and the
importance of affirming lgbtq plus
identities in schools
three years ago when I came out as
transgender and changed my name and
pronouns many people including close
friends family and strangers told me
there was something wrong with me
these people would not use my chosen
name and pronouns and actively ignored
my identity as a transgender person
the months of people refusing to affirm
my identity nearly cost me my life in
the span of six months I attempted to
end my life twice and I'm very lucky to
be standing before you today
my life turned around because I had
access to gender affirming care to start
my transition
it turned around because I started to
see representation both in real life and
in the media of transgender people
living their lives happily
it turned around because I found people
who affirmed my identity
one of those people was a teacher of
mine and I can't overstate the value of
having a trusted adult in your life when
you're young and vulnerable
this teacher was so quick to accept
accept me and stand up for me at a time
when I couldn't do so for myself
she advocated on my behalf to other
teachers and she showed me that I am
lovable and that what part part of what
makes me lovable is my transgender
identity
by mandating that Educators only use a
student's birth name and the pronouns
that matched their assigned sex at Birth
we are removing that resource that
changed my life by only teaching that
there are two genders and that anything
else is wrong where directly telling
kids who might be questioning their
gender that there's something wrong with
them
even at 19 these messages harmed me
deeply so I urge you to imagine the harm
that could be done to kids as they're
growing up and taking in the world
around them for these reasons I urge you
all to oppose 619 thank you for your
time
see and on Deck we have Jay leper
liberak
hello and thank you for holding the
hearing
um I have a short story and then
a little bit of an explanation when our
son was only 11 or 12 he started to
believe that he was a girl
we talked to him about it asked him
questions were very considerate I think
we took him to an endocrinologist and a
social worker
who were ready to rush him into a
transition with very very few questions
almost none I was shocked that something
that traumatic or drastic
would have so few queries so a few
questions they started to rubber stamp
the process
I think very luckily for us he decided
to rethink his his decision and decided
to stay a boy and I think that he's much
much much better off having done this
thinking on his own rather than being
thrown onto a conveyor belt and
undergone something that he would come
to regret
people of his age and this is the point
that I wanted to make in support of this
bill
are extremely vulnerable they're going
to schools where they're social workers
a whole network of psychologists Etc who
are almost plucking them almost cherry
picking them for this process about
which they have very very little
understanding as far as the consequences
of It Go and I don't think and I agree
with many of the people who've spoken
earlier who have just pointed out let
them make do the thinking do the hard
work question themselves on their own
for a while in conjunction with their
parents it's I think it's critical and
essential to have respect for them at
that level
rather than just steering them and
guiding them and insisting that we know
better medical profession knows better
what kind of people they want to be and
I would just end with a quote from
excuse me from King Lear where he asks
uh who is it who can tell me who I am
so if a person of that caliber
unsurpassed in Insight Shakespeare has
questions about lear's identity
then I would ask you what a 14 or 15
year old be able to answer that question
I cannot answer it myself
so I would say
very strong support of this Bill thank
you thank you are you taking questions
any from the committee I'm sorry I
forgot the format yeah sure that's all
right actually I don't see any questions
thank you very much okay thank you
sorry we have Jay lebrack followed by
the morning committee members I'm aware
that some of you may know a few people
who use they them pronouns so I'll give
you a chance to meet me my name is Jay
lebreck I was born down the street in
Concord and I've lived in New Hampshire
my whole life
I'm 20 years old and I'm currently
triple majoring in Social Work Justice
studies and women's and gender studies
at unh
I work a part-time job I'm the assistant
music director of an acapella group and
I even snowmobile
I'm a person with passion goals and
dreams just like everyone else but I'm
also transgender
I'm standing here today able to achieve
these Feats because I was allowed to be
who I am now and always have been I
speak in dire opposition of House Bill
I grew up in Ware New Hampshire and
attended Public School from grades 1
through 12. I know very well the
disastrous effects that would come from
the passing of this bill because I lived
through them
when I was in Middle School I didn't
know what being trans was or meant as a
gender non-conforming kid I didn't know
what to think of myself when I was in
fifth grade I started wearing masculine
clothes finally I felt like who I really
was but at the same time I felt isolated
I didn't know anyone like me and no one
talked about transgender identities at
all I was certain that there was
something wrong with me
though I tried to faint confidence on
the outside I felt lonely and depressed
I thought I was such a bad person for
being this way so when I was nearing
eighth grade I reluctantly started
wearing feminine clothes again after
that I wasn't outwardly seen as
different but I felt even more alone
those around me were relieved that I was
out of my face and turning into the
woman they all expected me to be
but that didn't work out I needed to
live authentically but society's lack of
acceptance and understanding surrounding
trans identities made that feel
impossible
I developed an anxiety disorder because
I thought I was such a bad person for
being who I was
I became very religious I prayed that
God could save me from who I was and I
had to found out the hard way that I
couldn't that I couldn't be cured no
amount of prayer or religious
intervention could save me could fix me
and that's because there was nothing
wrong with me in the first place
it was my senior year of high school
before I began to entertain the idea of
allowing myself to exist I graduated in
2020 and I have since been more
successful and happier than I've ever
had the chance to be I've had the
genuine confidence to make astounding
achievements academically and otherwise
I've long thought about what I could
have achieved in public schools if my
peers and I had received some level of
education and affirmations surrounding
trans identities instead I was left
picking up the pieces of myself that
were Shattered by society's expectations
because I couldn't meet them
I am one of the lucky ones statistically
according to the Trevor Project four
trans kids have attempted suicide since
I began sharing this testimony because
of experiences like mine were not scary
we're not evil we're just people and
they're just kids please leave them
alone
I will be taking questions
thank you any questions from the
committee
I have a written as well thank you very
much if you hand those up we can put
those on the record we have a Lane Plant
sorry is the lane here
I'll set this to the side for a moment
Cameron Munns do we have Cameron munz in
and if I say somebody's name and you're
in the process just wave your hands so I
good afternoon thank you
as you said my name's Ed Butler and I
was a state rep for six terms leaving in
2020.
at the end of my second term I became
the chair of the Commerce Committee
it's good to see some of the colleagues
that I worked with and good to meet the
others that I haven't yet met
I'm a gay man and have worked on a
number of lgbtq bills that have come
before this house working to support
those that acknowledge us as whole human
beings deserving of equal treatment
under the law
and I have worked to push back on those
bills that have come before this body
when efforts have been made to undo the
recognition and acceptance that we have
achieved
I was the Prime sponsor of the
transgender non-discrimination bill that
passed the house in 2009. and again when
we finally passed that bill in 2018 in
both bodies and Governor sununu signed
it
I was a co-sponsor of the bill to ban
conversion therapy the prime sponsor
being a Republican
which passed and was signed by governor
sununo
we are all aware that we understand
issues through the lenses with which we
learn about and explore our world
the authors of this bill note all sorts
of frightening and disastrous
consequences of the treatment of gender
dysphoria in children by Health Care
Professionals
they are bent on proving that such
treatments will have horrible
consequences and the language of the
bill certainly screams that perspective
but if you look at this issue Through My
Lens I too can come up with expert
reports that report the exact opposite
of what the bill asserts
as reported in the Washington Post in
February of 2022
the Gallup poll found that 0.6 percent
of U.S adults identify as transgender
but among gen Z adults about 2 percent
identify as transgender and researchers
expect that number to grow
does this mean that there are more
transgender people than before
Advocates say that it's merely a sign
that more transgender people have the
information and language available to
understand and describe their identities
transgender people have existed
throughout history including transgender
children
but many clinics
excuse me many clinics have been
treating transgender children only in
recent decades
the medical director of the center for
Trans youth health and development in
Children's Hospital Los Angeles one of
the largest transgender clinics in the
country said her Clinic has been taking
care of trans young people only since
the 1990s
what's happening now is not a massive
surge in transgender people
it's an understanding that gender much
like sexuality exists on a spectrum and
is more fluid Than People allow
but the authors of this bill want to
make it impossible for children
experiencing questions about their
agenda to express those feelings to some
of the most important authority figures
in their young lives 15 seconds if you
could wrap it up for us
and if those feelings are expressed the
bill sponsors withhold supportive care
135-g colon 2 is headed prohibition of
gender transition care for children and
young adults
I urge you to see this bill for what it
is a fearful response to a new and
challenging understanding of who we are
as fully expressive human beings
when representative Cannon and I first
introduced the trans non-discrimination
Bill we held a variety of gatherings to
help lawmakers understand what it is to
be transgender
in 2018 we made that Journey throughout
our state and the support for the
transgender Community was ultimately
Broad and bipartisan could you please
wrap up please don't believe all that's
written in this bill broaden your lens
learn its important treatment when
warranted can help a transgender child
grow into a strong and happy adult
please make HB 619 expedient to
legislative
thank you any questions from the
committee
um thank you next we will have Elaine
plant up with Cameron munz after that
um just so you know we're coming up to
one o'clock which is when we were
scheduled to begin our next bill we had
this many paint cards left so we want to
hear everybody and what you have to say
but if your statements have already been
made if you can let us know what what
statement it is that you believe in and
if you want to go along with that
support so that we can also have time
for the other Bill that'd be much
appreciated but we're not trying to
I think I'll do a Last Call on the lane
do we have Stephanie Cauley in the room
fantastic and then on Deck we'll have
[Music]
um hi thank you I'll try to be brief
because everybody's hungry and I don't
know about anybody else but I gotta use
the bathroom very soon so I'm 67 years
old I live in Santa Conway it's been my
representative I haven't been here since
2018 when I testified at the original
trans Rights bill so it's been a few
years but I am here in opposition to
this bill I strongly oppose it I grew up
at a time much like Jerry
um when being trans was hidden away and
we had to make you the best we could
um and this bill attempts to push trans
kids back into the closet so I adamantly
oppose it I went through so much pain
um
awful experiences trying to live a life
as a transgender woman when I was
younger
and a lot of self-harm
that occurred as a result of that I've
seen progress in our society but I see
this awful pushback coming trying to
push us back into the closet and
exterminate us essentially
so I again I oppose I don't want to get
too lengthy because everybody's tired I
just would say that this seems to be an
unwarranted intrusion into the private
decision-making of patients families in
the medical doctors gender affirming
care is supported by all the major
medical groups iron retired nurse I'm
very well aware of standards of care
evidence-based practices and gender
farming care meets those and gender from
kid is literally life-saving I am open
to any questions if anybody has any
thank you any questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much we have Chris sacral from glad
followed by Luke sahugian I believe from
Durham
thank you three minutes
thank you
um Vice chair thank you committee
members thank you for putting up with a
very long day um and being here to hear
important testimony about this
legislation my name is Chris sergell I'm
an attorney with glbtq legal Advocates
and Defenders better known as glad and I
am going to focus in on just a couple of
issues that people haven't really
covered in much depth number one I want
to talk about the constitutional rights
that are impacted by denying a parent
and a child the right to obtain Medical
Care medical care that is
um widely accepted by every single Major
Medical Association in the country and
medical care that is governed by widely
accepted standards of care when you deny
a parent the right to obtain medical
care for their child you are infringing
upon that parent's fundamental right to
direct the upbringing of their children
that fundamental right has been
recognized by a the Supreme Court of the
United States and by the New Hampshire
Supreme Court repeatedly there is
nothing more fundamental to the
upbringing of your child than making
Medical Care decisions
um that impact that child's health
and also the there's another
constitutional Dimension to a ban on
gender affirming Medical Care and that
is the um the constitutional right to be
treated as equals under the law
transgender people share that right just
like everyone else does this bill
singles out transgender people and
prohibits them from obtaining Medical
Care in a way that is uh that is
flagrantly in violation of the principle
of equal protection under the law
finally I just want to focus in for a
moment on the repeal of the ban on
conversion therapy which is in this bill
New Hampshire would be the first state
to repeal a ban on conversion therapy
and I just think that's really important
to note that no other state has taken
such a drastic step I'd also like to
note that the um exception in there for
young people who affirmatively provide
notice that they don't consent to
conversion therapy that is an unmutable
standard there are zero cases of a
adolescent teenager being able to say oh
I provided a memo to my doctor in
advance that said I didn't want to get
this treatment and therefore I can prove
that uh you know it was it was done
against my will so I just want to be
very clear that this is a full repeal on
the ban of conversion therapy there's no
person who could ever meet the standard
to show that their rights are violated
under the law that's all I wanted to
touch on but I'm happy to take questions
on any topic thank you any questions
from the committee
seeing none thank you very much Luke
sahokian followed by Timothy Burdick Dr
Roberta
how's it going I came here today not to
share any opinions I came here to share
facts because upon reading hb619 I found
that there were exactly zero facts to
support any of the claims that were made
in the bill other than the statistics of
prevalence of trench under youth so
without further Ado the study title of
regret after gender affirmation surgery
a systematic review and meta-analysis of
prevalence in this study meta-analysis
of 27 studies on patient regret rates
following gender affirming surgery with
a total of 7928 patients surveyed only
77 one percent or less than one percent
reported regret guiding the conversion
or guiding the conversation types of
regret and gender affirming surgery and
their Associated etologies Anonymous
surveys were sent to 154 surgeons
registered for the 2016 World
Professional Association of transgender
Health representing about 18 000 to 27
000 individuals who receive surgery
those who expressed regret were 62 or
0.2 percent
after gender affirming surgery a
multi-disciplinary approach to a
multi-faceted patient experience
a multi-disciplinary work group recorded
incidence of gender affirming surgery
and regret amongst their patients from
2016 to 2021 of the 1989 individuals who
underwent GIS only six or point three
percent requested reversal surgery they
transition furthermore there was a 2020
Stu
2022 study of 2242 D transitioners that
found only 15.9 percent of those who
de-transitioned did So based on a factor
of identity
there are other factors such as
financial and such as hate
that pulled much higher
somewhere in the bill I forget exactly
which section there was a request for a
longitudinal study on puberty blockers
and I provided one titled young adult
psychological outcome after puberty
suppression and gender reassignment the
conclusion of which reads a clinical
protocol of multi of a
multi-disciplinary team with mental
health professionals Physicians surgeons
including puberty suppression followed
by cross-sex hormones and gender
reassignment surgery provides gender
dysphoric youth who seek gender
reassignment from early puberty on the
opportunity to develop into
well-functioning adults
now I found another study titled
hormonal therapy and sex reassignment is
systematic review and meta-analysis of
quality of life of Psycho Social
outcomes on the topic of mental health I
reviewed about 56 studies 52 of which
indicated that transitioning has a
positive effect on mental health of
transgender people four of which
indicated mixed or null results meaning
that exactly zero indicated negative
results
furthermore there was a study on mental
health self-worth and socially
transition and transgender youth the
conclusion of which
essentially is that socially children
who socially transition report levels of
depression anxiety that closely match
levels reported by their cisgender
children or colleagues meaning that from
a demographic of one of the highest
suicidal ideation and suicide Tendencies
they go back down to essentially normal
the conclusion
vote
[Music]
thank you very much any questions from
we have Dr Burdick followed by Jonah
Sutton Morse
hi good afternoon thanks for having us
and thanks to all the committee members
for listening to this testimony today
those stories that we've heard have been
incredibly powerful my name is Timothy
verdick I'm a family physician I live in
Lyme New Hampshire
I'm not going to read the testimony that
I've submitted that online already for
you there's one aspect I do want to
point out that has not been discussed
much today is that in addition to the
dangers that this poses to the trans
Community this also imposes dangerous
directly to the medical community this
puts Physicians nurse practitioners and
other clinicians
in an untenable situation in which we're
asked not to practice good Medical Care
perhaps even to practice negligent Care
by harming patients
or risk having a medical license taken
away from us
at a time when Physicians and nurse
practitioners and others are already
facing an incredible stress load in
their work life
High suicide rates in the clinician
community and difficulties recruiting
providers
particularly in primary care to come
work in New Hampshire at times when it's
impossible in many communities to find a
provider to be your PCP a bill such as
this is going to make it much much more
difficult to retain and recruit
clinicians to come work in the state of
New Hampshire and that's going to have
an incredible detrimental effect on
everybody in the state of New Hampshire
so I'll stop there if there's any
questions
we have Jonas Sutton Morse followed by a
representative Potenza
good afternoon thank you my name is John
Sutton Morse I'm from Canterbury
I'm here to testify against the bill
because to put it bluntly this would
directly impair my ability as a parent
and person of Faith to instruct my
children which is the very thing that
the bill claims to support
I'm a member of the Concord monthly
meeting and New England yearly meeting
of the religious Society of Friends the
Quakers
a parent of three children my oldest let
us know last year that they are
non-binary
my kid's really great play Minecraft
they like rock climbing which is nice
because now they wear safety gear when
they go up high
my middle child is nine she is very
respectful of her older siblings
pronouns it's really great
when your nine-year-old comes in and
they're so mad at their older sibling
and they pause to get the pronouns right
Daddy
they were so mean and unfair
I'm the parent of some kids who are
great and awesome and this bill notes
that Many religious faiths teach the
therapist but two genders as best I can
tell New England yearly meeting hasn't
minted a position on this
but I do have a few centuries of Quaker
testimony on integrity and my kid let us
know that they were non-binary we
updated their records with a doctor and
the dentist and when my employer came
out for health insurance and asked me to
list all of my family members
I wrote to my HR department and I said I
need you to update things so that I'm
not writing male or female because those
aren't correct
shout out to my HR department in I.T for
getting it right
that's that's my testimony to this
committee and that's my testimony as a
person of Faith to the world this bill
says that parents are solely responsible
for teaching their children about
matters of Faith morals and matters
relating to their sexuality we told our
kids be straightforward and clear when
you have a conversation are they a boy
or a girl no they're not well should we
say he or she about them no you should
say that
and we told our kids if people get
argumentative and confrontational go
find an adult and have them help
navigate the situation
this bill says that teachers can't help
do that
this bill doesn't do what it says about
letting me instruct my kids on manners
of faith and morality
and you should vote against it
thank you very much any questions from
the committee saying none thank you we
have representative Potenza followed by
thank you chair my name is
representative Kelly Potenza I represent
Stratford District 19. I am strong
support of this bill
um based upon the science is unsettled
on this
so Dr William Malona he's an Idaho based
assistant clinical professor of
endocrinology and there's a lot of
medical stuff that's in here and there's
a lot of things that people have talked
about already but he's a member of a
society for evidence-based general
medicine he's been in this field for a
long time and it's actually an
international group of more than a
hundred clinicians and researchers
concerned about what they call the lack
of quality evidence for the use of
hormonal and surgical interventions as
first line of treatment for young people
with gender dysphoria
let me be clear
I want everyone to get whatever kind of
mental or health or support that they
need and if they get that if they're
hearing it from their school or anything
else that's not what this bill is
designed to do it's stopping in a sense
medical things that are not it's not
concrete there's sides on both of this
actually in February the Swedish board
this was in 20 2022 the Swedish board
um a national Board of Health and
Welfare updated its healthcare service
guidelines to recommend restraint when
it comes to hormone treatment noting
increasing reports of detransition and
transition related regret among youth
who transitioned in recent years the
National Academy of Medicine in France
also advised caution that same month in
2020 The Finnish health authority
issued similar guidelines deviating from
it and recommending Psychotherapy as the
first line of treatment for gender
dysphoric minors
um
the last thing I don't want to say is
there's a woman that I followed for
several years her name is Dr Miriam
Grossman she is a child in adolescent
psychiatrist she's treated young people
for nearly 40 years and written
extensively about gender ideology
um and she is in full agreement of this
that the first line of defense is
psychotherapy I think we need to support
this bill I think that we need to
support our youth that are suffering
from any anything that they have whether
it's
um
not just this so there's this bill is
the right thing to do because we don't
we don't know and the science is not
concrete on this and thank you for your
time thank you very much any questions
from the committee uh representative
McLean
yeah thank you madam chair and thank you
for taking my question so um you
mentioned in Sweden Finland and France
uh the pivot towards Psychotherapy and
advocating restraint so do they have any
data
relatively speaking as to successful
outcomes in comparison to the gender
affirming therapy therapy that we've
heard testimony today
just
I'm not sure but I will I will
definitely do that research and I will
send you what I will send you everything
that I have uh read and researched on
that to see if there is
um that kind of research that can
on the Psychotherapy side they feel as
if that is the first line of defense
that there's not enough science on the
other side in using medical
interventions in regards with Therapies
in in hormone treatments they don't know
the long-term effects of those that's
the reason why that their their first
yes it would just be interesting to be
able to look at some quantitative data
and if they had done uh work in those
countries it'd be interesting to see
thank you
thank you very much we have Reverend
Elsa worth who will be followed by Kalyn
and I'm sorry I really appreciate that
you have that with us but we're not
allowed to have any props in the state
house that is something that is a house
afternoon I'm the Reverend Elsa worth I
am the priest at St James Episcopal
Church in Keene and I'm here
representing the Episcopal Church of New
Hampshire
that portrait is of my transgender
daughter Emilia taken in the fall of
2017.
earlier that year unbeknownst to us she
experienced excruciating gender
dysphoria
it took her a while to understand and
then admit to herself what was going on
but in the fall of her senior year
about when that photo was taken
she came out to her friends and family
as a transgender girl my child was an
exceptional young person awarded a
scholarship to her prestigious boarding
school in Connecticut where she was
voted class president four years running
a high honors student a crew team member
a National Honor Society musician
courted by all the best colleges and was
deeply loved and respected by her peers
and teachers
she had a hard time putting together the
pieces in her mind about how she could
live her life as a girl life at a
boarding school is incredibly binary and
there was no support in that school and
her body was telling her she simply
could not go on as a boy
so three months after she told everyone
she was trans she died by Suicide one
winter Saturday morning away at school
my daughter was an exceptional young
person but her situation unfortunately
is not exceptional as we've heard over
and over this morning and today
around 45 percent of transgender young
people attempt suicide transgender girls
like my daughter are even at a higher
risk than that that is almost one out of
every two kids
what other demographic in all of society
is that vulnerable
what we didn't realize in time
in how fast everything went
was how much at risk every transgender
child is no matter how well-loved they
are no matter how well supported
this is because despite individual
circumstances there is a pervasive
stigma
generated by all of us corporately
creating a backdrop to everything like a
chronic underlying hum of hatred that
eats away at even the most
well-supported transgender young
person's soul
so when legislators come together as you
all did five years ago to ensure a
transgender rights it is like a gigantic
unyielding weight is lifted from these
vulnerable children's shoulders
but when legislators turn coarse and
together suddenly and intentionally
Target this particularly vulnerable
population this minority and attack the
parental rights of trans families it
only increases the vulnerability of
these transgender youths and puts them
even higher
for harm or hate crimes and I know that
pers that persecuting vulnerable
minorities is not what New Hampshire is
about
thank you in my faith tradition the
Bible asserts that God stands with
closest to those who are marginalized in
Earth and God suffers when they suffer
so I invite our legislators to stand in
that place too and work against this
cruel backward step and protect all New
Hampshire's children by defeating Bill
thank you for your testimony any
questions
um seeing none thank you very much and
we are trying to keep to that three
minutes we still have
a very large stack of of pink sheets and
we want to make sure that everybody is
heard we have Karen De Silva followed by
David Arthur
hi good afternoon my name is Caitlin
dasilva I use they them pronouns I'm a
social worker and I'm a member of the
Episcopal Church
and I am speaking here before you in
opposition of hb619
by the time I was 12 years old I felt as
though I was different from everyone
else part of this was due to the
religion that I grew up in religious
beliefs that this bill is citing as one
of the reasons why teachers should not
be allowed to mention genders other than
male or female or pronouns other than
those in common use in the English
language when referring to male or
female
my family never pushed these beliefs on
me but when growing up in the church
these were messages that everyone was
receiving when I was 13 I begged my
parents to send me to a Catholic Camp I
never told anyone why but it was because
I was hoping that this would make me so
I was not different from everyone else I
had heard stories about conversion
therapy and I wanted to send myself
I grew up with so much guilt and shame
because of the world I lived in the
world we all live in where legislation
such as proposed HP 619 is perpetuating
damaging and potentially deadly
misconceptions about the transgender and
non-binary community
on March 3rd 2014 at eight years old I
tried to end my life just as one in five
transgender and non-binary youth tried
to end theirs these suicide rates these
rates of suicide are not due to other
underlying mental health conditions as
this legislation suggests when trans and
non-binary youth are supported in home
and at school rates of suicide drop
nearly 30 and 50 percent respectively
minority stress Theory explains that the
everyday stressors that minorities
including transgender and non-binary
people face on a daily basis cause
elevated rates of mental health
conditions such as anxiety and
depression not the other way around
I conclude with asking you this will you
allow students to be called by their
nicknames in schools or are trans
students the only ones that will be
required to be called by their birth
name Will puberty blockers still be
allowed to be prescribed for youth who
need to delay the process of going
through Purity because they began going
through it at a young age or while
puberty blockers only be illegal for
Trans students who need to delay the
process of going through puberty because
of gender dysphoria is my gender and are
my pronouns and the gender and pronouns
of approximately 300 000 trans and
non-binary youth so difficult to accept
that you are willing to invalidate them
to the point of suicide and this bill is
invalidation
I am lucky to have found a supportive
Faith Community family friends and
chosen family but a lot of others have
not been
and so I please ask for you to consider
opposing hb619 thank you thank you are
there any questions from the committee
seeing none thank you so much for your
testimony we have David Arthur with Sean
you thank you hello
you know this is a very sad day
it's a emotional day
it's an emotional day because
we have to actually choose the side
and I'm hoping that there's a medium
but I am a gay man
I'm here to testify from my own personal
life knowledge and experience I'm also a
d transitioner
featured in the new documentary
affirmation generation
foreign
I identified as a trans kid
I was
the depressed suicidal Chinese kid I
OD'd at 13 on pills I sliced my wrist at
16.
I sincerely believed that I was a girl
trapped in a boy's body I was without
clarity
than nobody is ever born in the wrong
body
my story is a bit different from trans
youth today
because I grew up in a time when wrong
sex hormones or medical affirmation was
not popular not popular nor was it
profitable
it was actually deemed dangerous
I thank God that I wasn't put on puberty
blockers because I may have more health
issues than I have now just from being
on wrong sex hormones for over 20 years
I have osteoporosis commonly known as an
elderly woman's disease I am sterile
and I have been since before the age of
30.
the mental issues that came along with
the ROM sex hormones were devastating
major chronic depression severe mood
swings anxiety PTSD Suicidal Tendencies
and attempts
from my own experience as well as the
experience of hundreds and hundreds
possibly thousands of detransitioners
out there that I have spoken to
I was a suicidal trans kid
I was also a suicidal trans adult
because the affirmation and the
acceptance did not change my depression
did not take away my Suicidal Tendencies
they did Flatline for quite a period
because I recognized the Euphoria of
affirmation and acceptance but it wasn't
long before I was eventually I got to
see that I was still the same confused
nobody that knew me
nobody that knew me would have ever said
that I was depressed or angry they would
have said that I was Secure I was
content and I was being the girl I was
meant to be
none of them had a clue that I was
emotional
turmoil inside
that I lived in chaos in my head and in
my body
puberty blockers put little girls into
pre-mature menopause
puberty blockers slow
the natural development of brain body
bones
we're sterilizing we're medicalizing
experimenting on and mutilating
youth in the Name of Love and
inclusivity
they're not even able to make cognitive
decisions
we're passing laws where they can't buy
lighters if they're 18 they can't drive
if they're not 15 they can't vote they
can't go have a beer
but they can choose their gender they
can choose to be affirmed medically
which will completely totally
the life I live for over 20 years as a
transgender woman
I would never
wish
as an adult
do as you choose live free and die
but as a child we have to take
precautions
we must
I am living proof
and and regardless of Statistics that
you've heard
I'm telling you there are thousands of
detransitioners there are thousands of
people out there that have been harmed
medically physically and mentally
thank you from puberty blockers if you
can come to the conclusion thank you yes
ma'am thank you
puberty is not a disease
I'm nobody's enemy
nobody's enemy
I've been in tears sitting over the air
and sitting over there and having to go
to the bathroom because I feel
so much of the pain that I hear in the
testimonies today
thank you
we have Sean McDonough followed by Art
okay
my name is John McDonough I'm student
attorney from the Harvard Law School
lgbtq advocacy clinic and I'm here
representing Seacoast outbreak
hb619 would exclude transgender
students from bathrooms that reflect how
they live and express themselves in all
other areas of their lives when schools
have attempted similar bands courts have
repeatedly bought them as violating
transgender students civil and
constitutional rights in Granby
Gloucester County School Board the
fourth circuit enrolled in favor of a
transgender boy's right to use the boys
bathroom at school the Supreme Court
also typed with that transgender Boy by
declining to reconsider the ruling and
leaving it in place
that District paid a 1.3 million dollar
settlement
in another case Whitaker B Kenosha the
seven circuit World in favor of a
transgender boys right to use the boys
bathroom at school that District settled
for eight hundred thousand dollars
there are many more examples from past
decade and the testimony that my
colleague Chris passed out earlier we
have plenty of citations in there of
other cases in each case a school has
tried to implement a bathroom policy
excluding transgender students and
courts have struck down that policy
and ruled in favor of transgender
students rights to affirming that from
access
against this way to precedent there is
one outlier in the Adam's case the 11th
circuit ruled against the transgender
boys right to use the boys bathroom in
school
this anomalous decision only has a force
of law in three states by contrast 25
States
have binding precedent that supports
transgender students rights to use
bathrooms consistent with how they live
their lives publicly
in the past discriminatory beliefs about
gay men and bathrooms were prevalent
these beliefs were even used to keep
them out of our military
now if you tried to exclude a gay boy
from the boy's bathroom it would clearly
violate his civil and constitutional
rights it's no different for a
transgender boy under our
non-discrimination loss
in each of the cases I've mentioned
today to keep transgender students out
of bathrooms schools have spent
resources on litigation trying to
exclude them and all but one school has
lost anyway
please don't throw away money that could
help all New Hampshire students on this
doomed attempt to hurt a vulnerable
you've submitted your testimony I forgot
to ask the previous testifiers that if
you have a copy that wasn't otherwise
submitted that that's would be helpful
to have to the clerk for the record uh
thank you and now we have I'm sorry
dear members of the committee
my name is artem code if I'm testifying
in strong opposition to Bill hb619
I'm representing myself I am a gay man
and an asylum Seeker from Russia living
in Durham
it's been a year since I left Russia
I escaped Russia because it started the
war in Ukraine and it's continuously
attacking both lgbtq plus and human
rights when I was in sixth grade I moved
to a new school one day in early
November 2011 my classmates were doing a
lip sync to some famous songs of that
time on the next day I found out that my
classmates have recorded me singing and
dancing and posted a video of me on
every post possible social media
platform
later on I started receiving threats
I was pushed up against the wall I was
bullied harassed and speed on
I have been called all kinds of slurs
later in the same semester I decided to
finally talk to my class teacher who was
a school psychologist at the same time
on the same day she gathered my
classmates in the classroom and told
them about me she disclosed my sex
orientation which resulted in even more
harassment
it was in seventh grade
when the Russian government passed the
gay propaganda law among miners
this has closed all the outlets to
discussing sexual orientation and gender
identity with teachers psychologists and
even parents
for years I have been denied access to a
Psychotherapy because I was a gay minor
in 2017 I was diagnosed with the mixed
anxiety depressive disorder for years I
was taking medication only in 2020 when
I was 19 years old I could finally enter
Psychotherapy and could tell my
therapist about the experiences I have
had I escaped Russia because of the
anti-lgbtq plus legislature I was scared
for my life
and felt absolutely unprotected more and
more anti-constitutional laws have been
introduced in Russia so far the latest
one being the expanded LGBT
propaganda bill that covers any age
group instead of only minors that was
passed and signed into law in December
2022 even to this day on March 7th 2023
I'm still affected by the traumatic
experiences I have had because of such
legislature police do not let New
Hampshire become Russia thank you thank
you any questions from the committee
thank you very much
thank you we have Laura al-azram
followed by a reverend M Holland
thank you very much for listening today
my name is Laura I'm from Londonderry
um first of all I just wanted to say
that I'm in support of this bill
and I think a lot of other people that
are here
you know we're not hating transgender
people I don't hate transgender people I
don't wish that they didn't exist in a
couple of the other harsh things that
were said today
um
I think everyone deserves love you're
made with inherent dignity and people
ought to be cared for
um but also mentioned earlier were some
studies that have come up in Sweden and
those are based on long-term data and
the reason that data is important is
because they've been collecting it for
decades on every single person at every
single interaction with doctors so
there's a treasure Trove of data there
and what's more important than the
specific results of the study because we
could drown in data are the results
pediatric gender clinics that have been
operating for decades have been closed
because they've looked at the data and
decided to heed it
France Italy Australia Finland and the
UK the Tavistock Clinic most recently
which was the largest pediatric gender
clinic in the world and three gender
clinics in Sweden have closed
because
they have decided to refocus treatment
for gender dysphoria on mental health
support and exploratory psychological
care for minors
I am a huge parents right Advocate by
natural law parents have the broadest
latitude to make decisions for their
children regardless of what state law
says however they do not have the right
to kill them to abuse them to deprive
them of healthy functioning body parts
or to consent a treatment that will
disable normal healthy bodily processes
and cause serious defense deficiencies
in future bodily function
they just don't have that right
they also do not have the requisite free
choice in the matter seeing as that they
as they are under threat of self-harm or
suicide by a beloved child
certainly minors don't have the
cognitive capacity to make life-altering
decisions
I don't hate people kids who want to get
tattoos or kids who want to vote
but I recognize that they don't have the
cognitive capacity to make these
decisions it's a Perfectly Natural
developmental limitation but it's
further Complicated by a very high
Coincidence of serious psychiatric and
psychological diagnoses including autism
ADHD anxiety depression and most
concerning suicidality that's really
what we're talking about here
but no doctor should proceed with
elective life-altering treatment while
the patient's decision making is
compromised by despair
I ask that you support hb619 and please
oppose HB 368 which you'll be hearing
this afternoon please support and help
New Hampshire move toward a
compassionate whole person
developmentally developmentally
appropriate approach thank you
thank you are there any questions from
the committee seeing none thank you we
have Reverend Holland and then Reverend
Mario
good afternoon honorable members of the
House Health and Human Services
committee I've amended my comments to
shorten them my Reverend my name is
Reverend Sam Holland I'm tired like many
of you I'm an ordained Christian
minister in the United Church of Christ
I live in Center Harbor in the center of
the state and I'm here on behalf of my
local congregation in Plymouth Plymouth
Congregational United Church of Christ
I'm also speaking on behalf of the
justice and witness Ministry of the New
Hampshire Conference of our denomination
I ask you to vote in opposition of House
Bill 619 last fall our conference voted
to affirm the worth and dignity of trans
people in both society and the church I
have that resolution for you so you can
review it
um our conference has publicly professed
that we will as a large christian
community stand against
anti-trans legislation and policy so
here I am primarily as a church leader
it happens that this bill also pains me
emotionally as someone who identifies
with the non-binary and trans Community
this bill shows legislative overreach
and does not even fit the culture of New
Hampshire you know that Live Free or Die
it's not our culture
the care for Youth and adults with
regard to any physical transitioning is
slow and is careful
this bill lacks empathy and
understanding and this bill seeks to
totally erase those who are born as
intersex and that's a problem
this bill would leave space for
Guardians to coerce Youth and children
into conversion therapy which has been
shown to lead to an increased risk of
self-harm and suicidal ideation and I
just want to highlight the lawyer's
comments about this would make us the
first state to reverse that ban that's a
problem even by being proposed this bill
alienates families I know there are many
families in our state experiencing deep
emotional hurt because this bill is
being considered
I hope you will keep that in mind as it
causes people like me to consider moving
away from our state I give to Charities
I support our state's community and so I
hope that I and other families would be
appreciated as such
the effect of such legislation is
stinging and offensive not only to the
safety of people I care about but also
to my own existence and to have to stand
up here and defend that existence is
biologically impacting me I've seen
other people shaking and hearts are
pounding so I hope you keep that in mind
I want to see Youth and families
supported as a minister a person of
faith and a resident of our state I want
to see a society where all people are
empowered where all people are
metaphorically lifted up and where all
people are honored I hope that you will
reject this dangerous and unsympathetic
Bill thank you thank you any questions
from the committee saying none we have
Reverend Morin followed by Joanna Brown
thank you
thank you so much I am the Reverend
Sarah Maria associate conference
Minister serving the
132 churches of the New Hampshire
Conference of the United Church of
Christ
since 1985 the United Church of Christ
has been open to and affirming of the
lgbtq plus community
on October 15 2022 the New Hampshire
Conference of the United Church of
Christ recommitted to welcoming
transgender gender non-conforming
non-binary and intersex people and their
families into the full life and Ministry
of our places of worship and study and
encouraging all of its settings to do
the same
we made this commitment not in spite of
our faith or opposed to it but rather
because of it
in our sacred text the Holy Bible we
hear again and again the words of God
declaring that creation is good
simply put our transgender and
non-binary brothers and sisters and
siblings are part of this vast and
beautiful creation beloved in God's
sight in the fullness and sacredness of
who they are
as they are
they are not in need of converting to
anything different to be seen as good in
God's eyes
our teacher leader and Savior Jesus
Christ welcomed all to be with him
rejecting those who would Place barriers
between and amongst people
just like Jesus the New Hampshire
Conference of the United Church of
Christ believed that all human beings
are in need of supportive affirming
communities in order to live in health
and wholeness especially those who have
known rejection
and violence
are trans children deserve to be loved
and affirmed for who they are and
encouraged to see themselves as
beautiful and whole no matter their
gender expression
they deserve access to health care that
compassionately helps them to live into
the people God has called them to be
they deserve access to the places and
spaces that reflect who they are
we come to these conclusions and beliefs
because of our faith and because we have
experienced firsthand God's voice and
presence in our trans siblings
when transgender gender non-conforming
non-binary and intersex people are
welcomed into our churches accepted and
embraced for the ways they reflect the
face of God
they have become beloved members and
leaders of our churches
offering valuable Ministries both to as
laity and as clergy thank you if he
could wrap up your testimony we are
richer for their presence in our midst
therefore we ask and we pray that you
will reject this divisive and hurtful
bill and the irreparable harm that it
would cause our transgender and
non-binary youth and their families
please vote in expedient to legislate on
a house bill 619
thank you thank you any questions from
the committee seeing none we have Joanna
Brown followed by Jeremiah githu
thank you
Joanna Brown I have three lgtbq family
members who I love and adore I do not
look at any transgender person without
Compassion or love I do believe they all
do need to be affirmed however
our schools are bombarding children with
transgender push
and they're excluding parents from the
conversations
teachers are not equipped to deal with
the psychological issues that teenagers
face all teenagers go through some sort
of body dysphoria at some point very few
become transgender
but the social push to become
transgender
our children are faced with it all day
every day in every part of their life
from school to social media to
conversations with friends this is
becoming a tidal wave for all children
um more and more detransitioners are
coming out in fact there's one that I'm
in contact with who took some sex
hormones as a young child
to become a boy
she no longer wants to become a boy but
she can no longer talk because her vocal
cords were destroyed
after just six months of taking hormone
therapy
she can't talk without extreme pain
so when the doctors tell you that they
don't know that there's irreversible
damage
that right there is your clue they don't
know because either they're not looking
or they don't have enough evidence
we have enough people coming out saying
yes I've been harmed irreparable
irreparably harmed and they're not being
paid they're being chastised they're
being assaulted they're being
tell people tell them that they're lying
nobody's listening to these people that
if you pay attention to what's happening
in Milford there are kids playing games
with the transgender policies
there's a transgender girl who urinates
in the girl in the girl's bathroom with
the stall door opened exposing himself
um please no outbursts
there are true transgender people and
then there's a whole Congregation of
transgender boys boys that are playing
under that umbrella
to abuse and assault girls these are not
true transgender people they're playing
games with the school policies
and other children are being assaulted
if you can wrap up your testimony please
excuse me we need to have silence so we
can hear everybody else's testimony we
have many other people to hear today and
I would like to keep respect in the room
thank you
the UK Sweden France and Finland have
all banned youth transgender policies
they are no longer operating medically
on transgender people they're all
pulling back and looking at more
evidence before they charge forward it's
time we pay attention to what's really
happening thank you
thank you any questions from the
committee seeing none we have Jeremiah
Jeremiah and I am a 17 year old from
Northampton and I am one of those
opposed true transgender people I guess
that she was talking about
um I have been a resident of the state
for almost my entire life I've been a
part of my school's gsas I've been a
part of organizations
I have never seen anything like this in
our legislative
I for about eight months moved to
Florida and I was called all sorts of
slurs no matter what I was called no
matter what I was wearing or what I was
doing when I was working when I was
getting my gas pumped I was called
unspeakable things I will not repeat to
the committee right now but it's
seeing this in a place that is titled
live for your die is atrocious it is
devastating and I am also I would also
like to cite what representative Roy
said
when he was testifying at the beginning
where he quoted how do I get my breasts
back
I have had mine gone for the most part
for the past two years and I've never
been happier I can say that with my full
chest
the surgery when I woke up from surgery
I was crying for three hours straight
one because of the anesthetics and two
because I was just so happy to
figuratively have that off my chest and
I was a much happier person a much
better person
I could do things that I couldn't do
before like stand here and talk in front
of
whoever's watching right now
and I just
it's awful to hear what
people like representative Roy are doing
and to finish this up I would just like
to read off
um
the note of a young girl
who committed suicide when she was 17.
and I am about 20 days from 18 and I
will have outlived a number of my peers
who have committed suicide who have
attempted suicide and it's
appalling
I that's all I can say about it
here's what she wrote
there's no way out I'm sad enough
already I don't need my life to get any
worse people say it gets better but
that's not true in my case it gets worse
every day I get worse that's the gist of
it that's why I feel like killing myself
sorry that's not a good enough reason
for you but it's a good enough reason
for me ask for my will I want a hundred
percent of my things that I own to be
legally sold and the money plus the
money in the bank to be given to trans
civil rights groups and support groups I
don't give a which one
the only way I can rest in peace is if
one day transgender people aren't
treated the way I was they're treated
like humans without feelings and
emotions gender needs to be taught about
in schools the earlier the better my
death needs to mean something my death
needs to be counted in the number of
transgender people who commit suicide
this year
I want someone to look at the number and
say that's up
fix it fix Society please
thank you for your testimony any
questions from the committee seeing none
I know that that was her late poem
Manuel let's try and keep our language
respectful but we can't ask that of her
she gave a lot and also when we're
speaking to people let's just try and
make sure that we remain respectful so
we can keep this good dialogue going
thank you
we have Liz Barber followed by sorry my
contacts are acting up Stephanie slave
I don't see Liz Barber do we have
Stephanie slave Jessica Annie Carr enjoy
Jessica and Annie
hello thank you for taking the time to
hear from us today unfortunately Annie
did have to go but
the three of us argue in eight students
we were all born and raised right here
in New Hampshire attending our local
public schools across the state
the first thing we learned about New
Hampshire is our motto Live Free or Die
growing up with the rite of passage that
freedom is so precious not even life can
continue without it
the rights for yourself called what you
want and refer to by your chosen
pronouns is an individual's freedom
the three of us are not transgender or
non-binary we have all been affected by
this issue
as we have family friends and peers that
are
according to the CDC one of the top
three causes of death among teens is
suicide
I've experienced depression and suicide
personally and among my own family
I can confidently say that losing a
child because we banned health care that
could have saved them instead of
allowing them that
sorry access is a failure upon us and
our government
we have an opportunity here as the Next
Generation to be active in our community
and make a stand for what we believe is
right and wrong
to watch someone you love go through the
struggle of the world telling them not
to be who they are is what emboldens us
I'm scared of a world where the boxes we
fit in become smaller and more
restricted I'm scared of a world where
my future children don't have the right
to be themselves
we should be focusing on helping these
youth not tearing them and their mental
health down we should refer to them as
they wish allowing them access to gender
affirming health care and giving them
the respect because they are human too
protecting NH children starts here and
with opposing HP 619
we will leave you with this if it was
your child's wouldn't you want them to
be happy Above All Else
thank you for your time
thank you seeing no questions thank you
very much and if you can give the
written testimony we'd appreciate that
next we have best scare followed by
Marie Daniels
so I didn't give you a notification we
hi Beth scare from Nashua I'm reading
the testimony from Aaron Brewer
um she said I'm says I'm a former trans
kid as a child I was insistent
persistent and consistent that I was a
boy
I have no doubt that if the option to
take puberty blockers and cross-sex
hormones had been available I would have
done everything I could to obtain them
including threatening suicide especially
if I had others encouraging me to
threaten suicide as children are today
in the short term I likely would have
felt better
testosterone is a controlled substance
like other Controlled Substances it has
high risks to health and well-being and
has the potential for both addiction and
abuse testosterone makes almost anyone
who takes it initially
initially feels a sense of euphoria
if I had taken it a child it would have
allowed me to completely disassociate
for myself as a girl and create a new
persona someone who could pretend that
the horrible trauma that triggered my
gender dysphoria didn't happen to me
when I first started taking it it would
have boosted my confidence and increased
my energy and most importantly I would
have felt safer if I took testosterone
it had been so much easier to pretend I
was not that little girl who was
brutally sexually assaulted
a little girl who became convinced at
the moment of the assault that I was not
safe being a girl that the only way I
could keep it from happening again was
by becoming a boy
despite feeling better in the short term
in the long term taking testosterone
would have been profoundly damaging
potentially even more damaging than the
sexual assault I can't imagine the
impact of being told by teachers doctors
and other adults that I was born in the
wrong body that I was inherently flawed
it would have been reinforced all the
mistaken beliefs that I had had caused
me to develop gender dysphoria in the
first place
foreign
that being a girl was bad that it was my
fault that those men hurt me that my
body was a mistake that it was too
dangerous to be a girl if I had been
medically transitioned I wouldn't have
gotten the help I needed to work through
my self-hatred and shame I never would
have realized that my transgender
identity was a coping mechanism I'm so
thankful my school psychologist put me
on a healing path I'm grateful to other
therapists who helped me understand that
my transgender identity was a result of
the sexual assault not because I was
born in the wrong body I shudder to
think at what my life would be like if
I'd been encouraged to believe I was a
boy I would have lived my life hating
myself puberty blockers would have
my growth and development
cross-sex hormones would have caused my
otherwise healthy body to become
dysfunctional the combination of both
puberty and blockers and cross-sex
hormones would have left me sterile
children who say they feel better
because of puberty blockers and
cross-sex hormones are likely telling
the truth in the short term these
interventions allow children to avoid
difficulties they're facing whether that
be grappling grappling with internalized
homophobia struggling with autism or
trying to recover from a significant
trauma we should not be giving children
controlled substances in order to make
them feel better it is a horrible
disservice to encouraging them to
dissociate to run away from their
feelings or run away from themselves and
to take a drug that in the short term
will help them to feel better by numbing
their feelings in the long term if you
could summarize if you could submit the
rest as testimony if you could put it
through the portal everybody else will
be able to read it as well permanently
damage their bodies and long can prevent
them from getting the help they need to
understand the difficult feelings
they've been having in the first place
please vote OTP on HB 619 thank you
thank you very much seeing no questions
we have Marie Daniels with Anne-Marie
Banfield on Deck thank you for your
patience and this long day we don't pay
you people enough but of course you
already knew that I am Marie Daniels
from Barrington New Hampshire testifying
in opposition to this bill I want to
scream I'm a school psychologist and
high school guidance counselor and the
faculty advisor of my gay straight
Alliance at my school I I started this
club after one of our transgender
students was hospitalized a second time
for suicidality and I felt that I needed
to provide some supportive Community for
these kids these kids are suffering
they're experiencing bullying and
ridicule and constant microaggressions
and they're dying at their own hands
because of it in contrast to the Cherry
Picked data and widely debunked studies
obliquely referenced it in this Hall and
in this bill I want to leave you today
with some legitimate research from the
CDC the Journal of the American Medical
Association the Journal of adolescent
health from the Journal of interpersonal
violence we know that 80 percent of
transgender kids consider suicide in at
least 40 percent attempt it
This research confirms that the suicide
risk plummets and mental health outcomes
drastically improve when kids experience
gender affirming treatment in
communities as someone who has spent
decades working with teenagers and in
schools I can I can unequivocally tell
you that they invented hysteria about
locker rooms and bathrooms is just that
invented these kids by and large if they
don't have access to a private bathroom
say in a nurse's office they are going
to the bathroom they're not drinking all
day they're waiting to till they can get
home and go to the bathroom in uh in
peace
they don't want to go into locker rooms
either one because they're afraid
they're afraid of making anyone
uncomfortable and they're afraid for
their own safety and I can tell you
heteronormative males are not sneaking
into girls bathrooms and locker rooms to
attack kids
largely because they're so afraid of
being called Gay they wouldn't set foot
in those rooms so that's that that is an
invented information that that people
have referenced
um if you could try to wrap up your
testimony yep thank you I can tell you
that transgender kids who need to need
to satisfy PE requirements are taking
classes that don't require that they go
into to uh locker rooms and they're
taking their PE classes online as far as
school staff respecting kids chosen
names and pronouns the research I will
show you solidly shows that these tiny
kindnesses that we offer kids
significantly decrease the kids suicide
risk in closing I want to ask those of
you who believe in the conservative
values of parental rights and limited
intrusion of the government into
people's lives and local control please
say no to this bill and allow these
private medical decisions to remain in
the hands of families and their
Physicians and allow school districts to
continue to decide how to best serve
their own kids for those of you who feel
you have a moral obligation to insinuate
yourself into these very private
decisions please know that if this bill
cat passes more New Hampshire kids will
die
and it will be and you will be culpable
thank you for your testimony are there
seeing no questions from the committee
um unless I missed one uh thank you
Anne-Marie Banfield with Tom Carden on
Deck
it's Anne Murray still here
thank you everyone and uh thank you
members of the committee I thought it's
a long day for you appreciate your time
my name is Tom Carden I am a retired
High School teacher I'm a former member
of the House of Representatives and I am
the grandfather of a transgender
daughter who's the teenager
she's well adjusted she's happy she's
sweet and she's very courageous
we really didn't know what was going on
for with Ali At first
she when she was four she was in the
hospital she got Salmonella poisoning
and of course I taught Food Service
sanitation and we were worried that she
was going to die
so she's in her bed one day and all of a
sudden on the TV a Barbie doll shows up
jumped up that's where I want Mommy
so her mother went out and bought her a
Barbie doll and then things kind of
progressed she started getting these
really kind of cute hair pieces and then
we started realizing that that she's
different
and it was okay
and one of the things that my daughter
agonized about is what's going to happen
when she goes to school
she had lots of sleepless nights where
but she did what she was supposed to do
she advocated for her daughter
and the school was pretty supportive at
first and you know it's kind of hard
because you know Ally wanted to wear
girls clothes to school and of course
she she couldn't at the time and you
know again the advocacy and a very good
school system allowed her to start
wearing all right girl schools just
girls close to school
and
you know she she didn't wake up one day
and decide that you know I want to be
trans this has been a long process for
her it's been 10 years
and I think anybody is that way it's not
like it's cool you know they're they're
discriminated against they're bullied
State legislations make laws against
them
and you know she it's just who she is
and that's all she wants to to be
you know she just wants to blend in like
the rest of all of us
um you know it's a very vulnerable
population
and you know they really they need
support more than anything they don't
need laws made against them and I would
hope you would oppose this bill and in
all honesty
um and I'll go back to the legislature
you know any decisions on their health
care should be made between the patient
the doctors and the parents thank you
thank you for your test
seeing no questions we have Ray Breslin
going once going twice for Ray Breslin
we may get through this before it's
midnight fantastic next we have Aaron
pennichick
so thank you
thank you
and after Stephen will have Victoria
Gullah
you have three minutes thank you thank
you
I'm Stephen scare of Nashua and I urge
you to consider voting ought to pass on
HB 619
earlier we were talking about puberty
blockers and according to Marcy Bowers
the president of the world associate
World Professional Association of
transgender Health which sets the
standards for treatment a child who
starts puberty blockers and then goes on
to opposite sex hormones which almost
all do will never have any sexual
function never be able to experience
intimacy Marcy Bowers Compares that to
female genital mutilation
activist claims the laws that end the
practice of treating gender dysphoria
with hormones and surgery deny
life-saving care or claiming they
support with astronomical suicide
figures but just last month Dr watalia
Catalina finland's leading pediatric
gender medical experts who aren't that
and I quote it is not justified to tell
the parents of young people experiencing
transgenderism that the young person is
at risk of suicide without corrective
treatment and the danger can be
countered with gender reassignment
treatment she cited 12 studies that
demonstrate that if you allowed children
to go through natural puberty four out
of five will outgrow their dysphoria the
most recent one was and the largest one
was just two years ago which showed an
assistance rate of over 87 percent
so why the differences between U.S
policies and the health policies of
Finland England and Sweden countries
which have dropped the gender
affirmative model of puberty blockers
and opposite sex hormones
the Trevor Project statistics are from
self-report surveys
solicited on LGBT sites not from a
review of the actual suicide rates the
youth risks of ia2 those are
self-reports and according to that it's
nine percent of all all youth have
attempted suicide but the actual rate is
.014 according to the CDC
a review of the data from the world's
largest pediatric gender Clinic
indicated a suicide rate of
0.03 percent were trans identified youth
although this is higher than the average
suicide rate it's similar to suicide
rates for youth with other mental health
conditions and lower for them the
suicide rates for autism and anorexia
another study of 2 800 children
concludes that suicidal suicide
suicidality among transgender
identifying youth is only somewhat
higher than those being treated for
mental other mental health issues which
many have
whatever decisions you make I hope it
won't be for under duress or coercion as
detransitioner in one of thousands if
not tens of thousands of de-transition
or Chloe Cole said I hear emotional
blackmail at these hearings constantly
their blood will be on your hands gender
dysphoric kids are listening shoving the
idea that it's trans or suicide will
harm the youth children are not Martyrs
for your political ideology thank you
any questions thank you seeing no
questions for the committee thank you
very much we have Victoria gulla
hi thank you I want to just uh quickly
address the girls from UNH I am a mother
and I don't try to make my children
happy
my goal in life is not to raise or to
have happy children I need my children
to experience up and downs and pains so
that they can learn to cope so no I
don't give my kids candy all the time I
don't let them watch endless TV and and
everything because I'm the mother and
I'm the adult in the house
so I want to give you an education on
where why we're here we're here because
this is actually Marxist theology it's
in the literature it goes back to 1984
where they first brought in queer Theory
into the academic
um papers and I to give you an
understanding of my history and my
education I graduated from conduit High
School in 1991 I went to McGill
University in Canada and I graduated in
1995 and I studied the history and
politics of tyrannical regimes which of
course included Marxism fascism
French Revolution so for me I recognize
the language because I studied it in the
context of History what I didn't do is I
wasn't in the College of Education and
this was kind of coming into the
colleges of education at this time
really the queer Theory came into the
colleges of Education in 1993 and 1994
so I was on my way out of college by
that time and again I wasn't in the
College of Education I was in the
College of Arts or the faculty of Arts
so
um as part of queer Theory what they
want to do is they want to destabilize
you can't have a Marxist revolution in a
stable Society because people are happy
so what they found that in the western
societies the marxists realized you're
never going to be able to bring about
Marx's revolution in Europe because
those societies were happy they couldn't
do it in the United States because we
weren't happy
stable country so in order to bring
about Marxist Revolution they needed to
destabilize and part of that data
stabilization
is making people themselves the
individual unstable and that's why it's
so subversive and that's why what has
happened to these people in this room is
so cruel because marxists don't care
about the individual they only care
about the collective and they don't care
if they mentally and physically abuse
people they don't care if they murder
the people in the Ukraine during the
halamador where they starved five
million people they don't care now as
China and actually the term brainwashing
comes from the Chinese literally the
people coming out of the camps were
interviewed and they talked about
um being brainwashed and that's we also
call that re-education camps so for all
of you it's very sad but you have been
brainwashed the reason that someone my
age I just turned 50 doesn't have all
these peers and we didn't have all this
LGBT stuff in schools because it didn't
exist because it hadn't hit the pedagogy
in the colleges of education so that's
what they do they are creating all of
these kids and they're destabilizing
them and part of it also is to remove
the child's relationship from the parent
and in doing so you can also attach that
child to a teacher you can attach it to
a caring adult in a safe Space by saying
that you have safe spaces at school
you're saying that you don't have a safe
space at home so if you didn't include
your testimony we do have some questions
for you
this this is a an attempt and they again
they're they're abusing these people
physically and mentally to
to pull kids and destabilize society and
if you see the Mental Health crisis in
the state and everywhere I went to
conval the principal there says the
number one issue at conval is mental
health that wasn't so when I graduated
they've created this
thank you representative polisov
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question uh you're talking
about Marxist I haven't had anyone today
represent themselves as a Marxist we had
some people from
psil I believe something people
socialist and Liberation party we also
had some people with uh representative
could you get to the question
uh the question is would you call
anti-familitants and socialists who
testify today would you call them
marxists who are trying to impose this
ideology
would I
[Music]
specifically there were some
socialists and then Chief people today
as a the marxists you're talking about
actually I'm gonna this is not getting
us to knowing if we're going to vote for
against the bill this is very
interesting conversation but if we can
take that offline
thank you
we have Leo Gutierrez followed by
Merrick Finn and thank you for your
testimony
yes for those keeping track at home
there's 42 more cards for this bill and
15 for the other Bill since I don't see
Merrick Finn that makes it 41 we have
Mike and
Andrew Adam croskey
sorry it was a little close together for
me though see and then we have Anthony
Federer blue after that
stand back
I appreciate you guys being as attentive
as you've been all day long day
when I first heard about this
legislation I was pretty angry actually
livid would be a more at this apt
description
Rick Ladd got in here full Sheila said
Al got an earful
um
as a parent I don't want anybody else in
I'm a Libertarian I got some pretty
strong views but I don't want anybody
else in the middle
and I can tell you also as a parent of a
transgender girl
who came out
she doesn't have any bad side effects
she's healthy she graduated in the top
10 of her class she's in college she's
very happy
I'm fine with a happy child
um
she's well adjusted she's well adjusted
because of school supporter
the sports team supported her her friend
supported her when it came for Timeless
sleepovers the other parents supported
her
she was treated exactly how she came out
and that's what I would expect moving
forward in a state that says Live Free
or Die
be yourself
be good to other people
and that's the way it should be so I
hope that you guys will either vote this
down or at least table it and not push
this forward
if my daughter was still a teenager I
just jump across the river I live on the
Connecticut River I go across the
Vermont
any questions from the committee seeing
none we have Anthony federon blue
do we have Jason wells in the room
see do we have Dave to Broken Heart
oh
Jason Wells yes fantastic thank you
thank you
I'm Reverend Jason Wells and I pastor
Saint Matthew's Episcopal Church in
Goffstown
I urge you all to vote inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 619
today you're hearing many good reasons
to ICL this bill from my neighbors who
are in the healthcare mental health and
educational communities
they have told you the truth and I hope
that you listen because it is the truth
that sets us all free
you'll hear from other religious leaders
who although this bill invokes religious
Faith are witnesses to people of Faith
who love and affirm lgbtq plus neighbors
just as they are
my testimony will begin and end with
page one of this bill
as I saw this bill state that it is it
takes its compelling interest
directly from the smallness of the
numbers of the transgender population of
New Hampshire
the bill is very clear it wants to bring
the full force of law
and to bring along with it the mental
health health care and educational
sectors along with it to bring all of
this Force to a vulnerable Community it
is a Goliath of a bill
the Bill's sponsors are quite ready to
claim that mantle as an excuse to harm a
small community
now when I was growing up in Sunday
school I was always taught the story of
David and Goliath
you as always every time about bullies
and the importance of standing up to
bullies and their intended victims
and with and for their intended victims
because the bill uses religious language
I will use a religious definition of
bullying that comes from the southern
baptist convention's own ethics and
religious liberty commission that has
three characteristics
bullying is intentional and tries to
cause harm and distress to its victims
bullying exists between parties of
unequal power
and Bullying happens over a period of
time
House Bill 619 does all of these and
more
in the words of the bill children under
its power that are affected by it will
be done this will be done to them
through the age of majority
it is clear that there is a difference
of power when we bring the force of
legislature of law Education Health Care
and mental health
all to bear on children whose voices we
only hear second hand today in this room
bullying tries to cause harm and
distress to its victims and we know this
because we have listened to our
neighbors and their testimony this
morning we have heard the results of
homelessness depression clinical
depression and even suicide
bullying is intentional and there is no
more clear intention than a 15-page
written plan to document the harm that
is intended to be done over time if he
could summarized your testimony I cannot
speak for others but that at St
Matthew's Episcopal Church in Goffstown
we teach that god holds Christians to
the moral standard of speaking up
speaking out and defending the
vulnerable as David did Goliath
in front of you is a written out plan
and there is a smooth stone that like
Goliath will knock it back that stone
has the letters itl written on it please
vote in expedient to legislate on House
Bill 619 thank you seeing no questions
from the committee thank you very much
we have people from the Episcopal Church
of New Hampshire I couldn't quite read
the writing that was very very small
is there anybody who is writing very
very small there's a Rick and a cape
fantastic
sorry I apologize for not being able to
and then on Deck we'll have William
Jewell
foreign
good afternoon and thank you for the
opportunity to testify my name is Pastor
Kate Harmon siberini I am a priest of
the Episcopal Church of New Hampshire
serving congregations in Concord and
Franklin and I come before you today to
ask you to protect the vulnerable
children of our state by voting in
expedience to legislate on House Bill
I have heard today from proponents of
this bill that what they are most
interested in is protecting the children
of this state but they have let their
own agenda prevent them from seeing the
facts
the medical consensus is that children
and youth are not at risk from their
transgender classmates it is transgender
students themselves who are at
significant risk of violence and death
a U.S and Canadian study published just
last year in the Journal of
interpersonal violence showed that 56
percent of trans youth reported a
previous suicide attempt and 86 percent
reported Suicidal Thoughts
if we are truly interested if we are
truly interested in protecting our
children then this bill goes about it
all wrong
because the study showed what other
Studies have affirmed in the past
that what reduces trans student suicide
rates was having a supportive and
affirming School environment a
supportive and affirming family
supporting and affirming Medical Care
and people in their lives who affirmed
them as the people that they know
the sponsors of this bill have refused
to see the facts but they have also
refused to see the truth
because transgender children as we have
heard today are not just statistics
I have been on the phone at 1am talking
to a youth whose family has rejected
them for being trans
whose school is not a safe place for
them
their family has made having a place to
live be contingent on that child against
their will going into conversion therapy
and I have stayed on the phone with them
through the night begging them not to
end their life
promising them that the world is better
with them here that the world is
changing that things are hard so hard
right now but one day it will be safe
for them
hb619 makes it harder to keep that
promise
Matthew 7 16 says we will know the truth
of things by their fruits many of the
proponents of this bill have cited their
Christian faith but there is nothing of
God and a bill that would rather
transgender children be dead
than be themselves
trans kids are our kids they are God's
kids they are New Hampshire's kids and
they need our help
please vote itl on hb619 thank you thank
you are there any questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much
we have William Jewell followed by Iris
terrella
William here yes it's fantastic I
apologize I'm short so
sometimes people won't see me so uh I'm
uh I'm Bill Jolly I live in Groton which
is in Grafton County and usually dads
are relegated to the role of being an
ATM with a teenage daughter or uh to
giving bad jokes but I'm here for a
different reason one of couple reasons
but one is that my daughter is not trans
she's not gay
she's been taught and she Embraces the
notion of loving everybody
and I take offense at being called
hateful especially by people of the
cloth
because I feel strongly in my beliefs
and I can pull a paragraph a line out of
the Bible too but I'm not going to do
that today so I'm just going to leave
that right there that is an unfair and
ungodly way to act
so to go to the matter at hand I'm here
in support of Bill 619
and that should be OTP
I want to direct everybody's attention
we have all these statistics swimming
around in the sky right now they're
being thrown at you guys and Mark Twain
I taught defense analysis a section of
it to the Army not in an academic an
academic sense but there's lies damn
lies and statistics right that was Mark
Twain or at least he gets credit for it
so I'm not going to do that to you I
will point out the one fact that the
exponential rise in teenage suicide
happened around 2009 to 2014 depending
on which statistical
data you look at right and so my
question is and it's only a question
it's one to ponder it's rhetorical was
that a result of the hypersexualization
of things in schools all of a sudden
this is an issue for kids to deal with
uh I might even be well I think we're
all at about the same age with you folks
so when we were in high school this
wasn't really discussed much it wasn't
an issue I'm sure that there were
children youths who had uh questions
about their identity who were unsure
about where they were going in fact I
bet all of us
I I couldn't figure out how to get a
date until 11th grade so I mean we're
all trying to figure out things okay so
that's a big piece of this suicide has
gone through the roof everybody here
wants to see suicide go down I do I lost
a friend in high school to high school
I'm also a military vet that served for
32 years I've had some friends kill
themselves from that too so I don't like
suicide and I can speak about driving
people not on the phone uh ma'am
wherever she want but picking people up
and saying get in the truck and going
for a ride so they don't kill themselves
so I know that this is a real thing and
if anybody's experienced that or they
have a friend who's experienced it my
heart goes out to you I'll be real quick
this ought to pass because it's about
families taking care of the kids if you
go to the page eight of this bill I
could read it to you but you don't need
me to do that you can read and you don't
want to hear my voice anymore my
horrible Charlestown Boston accent lines
one through 16. please look at those
and then lines 22 to 30. if you would
consider those this bill has value and
maybe it's just a discussion maybe it's
just the beginning but I think it's an
important discussion because there are
kids who are not
affected in the way other kids are that
are being excluded from the conversation
and I'm talking about non-gay non
LGB kids they need to be respected as
well that's what this is about in my
mind thank you
you
thank you very much for your testimony
we have Iris termell followed by Sally
stodd
my name is Iris Carmel and I'm a seventh
grader and a trans girl from Pembroke
this is who I am and no piece of paper
either online or a written can change
that
for hb10 and sb272 when lgbtq people
come out to their parents Grand
grandparents friends and all other
people who they spend a lot of time
around it should be when they decide to
it's not okay for the school system to
tell their parents when the students
don't want them want to come out to them
yet we are our own people and we have a
right to tell them when we want to it
could be in a year a month or even a
couple years before some people feel
like they are ready to come out vote no
one hb10 and SB 272
reach me 417 I object that to gender
affirming care being called child abuse
what do you think council's child abuse
I am non-abuse child and I have been
getting gender affirming care for a
while now personally I feel like I'm
being loved and supported by all my
family members and my friends
I cannot talk today it'd be child abuse
if kids didn't have a way to be
themselves without being in the abused
child category it'd be child abuse if
group if girls had to play on the boys
team but because of having a so-called
physical advantage over real girls
it would be child abuse if girls are
forced to go into the boys bathroom and
boys locker room vote no in HP 417
for HP 619 forcing trans people to wait
until they are 18 years old to get
gender affirming care is just wrong some
people need to get the treatment if that
they feel are needed at the time they
are needed it stops people from like me
working from working with my doctors at
places like Dartmouth health and Boston
Children's Hospital from making
decisions with my parents doctors and
parents about known HB is 619
for each b368 protecting gender or
firming care and provide versus the way
to go I know I would feel a lot better
if this were the law vote Yes nhb 368. I
would like it if you all kept protecting
lgbtq rights including mine thank you
for your time
thank you thank you very much for your
time and testimony that's not allowed
but this is a very brave seventh grader
so I didn't hear that thank you thank
you very much next we have Sally stodd
do we have Sally stodd or Amy manzelli
good afternoon uh acting chair members
of the committee my name is Amy manzelli
and I'm here from Pembroke New Hampshire
in strong opposition to 619.
New Hampshire is just no home for hate
that is why we are so proud to live here
with our family including our
transgender daughter and that is why we
encourage you to itl 619
as we said New Hampshire is no home for
hate last month as you all probably know
a coward painted swastikas and other
hate symbols in Portsmouth at places
frequented or owned by Jewish black or
lgbtq plus
customers or owned by those people
and what do we do
Portsmouth PD teams up with the FBI and
the attorney general and that coward is
going to be prosecuted to the fullest
extent of the law
the Nationalist Social Club
known casually as
nac-131 this is a white supremacist
group
they they hung a banner last summer in
Portsmouth that said keep New England
white
what do we do about that
the New Hampshire Attorney General's
office filed the Civil Rights lawsuit
against that white supremacist group its
leader and a member that's what we do
about that in New Hampshire
and a few years ago when questions arise
about rights to discriminate
what do we do in New Hampshire
wise lawmakers like you
we tighten and we strengthen New
Hampshire's RSA 354 New Hampshire's law
against discrimination
finding in declaring quote
practices of discrimination against any
of New Hampshire's inhabitants because
of age sex gender identity and a whole
bunch of other important things
are a matter of State concern
such that such discrimination not only
threatens the rights and proper
privileges of its inhabitants
but menaces the institutions and
Foundation of a free
Democratic State and threatens the peace
order health safety and general welfare
of the State of New Hampshire
now those amazing words are already
state law and what does that mean for me
that means that when we as parents
finally listened to our daughter
three years after she asked Santa to be
able to make her a girl starting at age
three
that we can continue to listen to her
now seven years later it means that she
can continue to be her true teenage self
voting itl on this bill means that when
she plays Sports she can play on the
girls team just like the other girls it
means that when she goes to the bathroom
thank you she can go to the bathroom
just like the other girls it means that
when she receives her medical care from
experts at Dartmouth and Boston
Children's not none of us not her not
her health care providers and not her
parents will be treated as child abusers
she will be proud to be from New
Hampshire because New Hampshire is no
home for hate
thank you for voting itl on 619. thank
you for your testimony any questions
from the committee seeing none well next
we'll have Nancy bitterman if she's here
we still have 34 Mark more cards to go
and we have our other bill as well we're
going to see how many we can do by three
o'clock then we'll recess this in order
to hear our other bill of the day which
is House Bill 368 and then pick this up
again right at the end so that we can
continue to hear everybody but also
respect everybody's time so with that
um I hear
talk about
and people feeling like they are being
um
second-class citizens but I'm here to
talk about the medical side of things
um most looking around the room here
you're all some of you are not old
enough to realize that there was a draw
down the market thalidomide that was
given to pregnant women for morning
sickness and every doctor gave it said
hey this is the miracle drug this is
going to fix everything you're not going
to have morning sickness until hundreds
of thousands of babies were born with
defected limbs all over the world this
was not just in the United States it was
all over the world and it took
legislative action to stop the use of
this drug and to install safeguards as
to whether drugs can and cannot be
approved appropriately and how they were
done that still did not stop another
drug from being put on the market called
des and I am not going to pronounce the
name for it and again this was an
estrogen drug that was promoted to women
saying hey you're not having you're
having miscarriages you're unable to get
pregnant we are going to give you this
drug
the ramifications from this drug are
still being felt today
the women that took it most of them had
cancer of some sort later on their life
and died at an early age
their children
are now saying are seeing the effects of
it they're called Des sons and daughters
and the side effects to the women are
infertility and other other fertility
issues and um and the men along too with
having different types of cancers and it
has now been the grandchildren
so this drug that was stopped in 1970 is
still affecting people today the
grandchildren are seeing the effects of
this drug so when a doctor or a medical
profession or a group of them say oh we
think this is safe all of those drugs
were said to be safe and effective and
they were going to solve your problem
they did not
and I would also like to say that in
this state and I have and I would hope
somebody else could even do more
research than I could I could not find
it this law has been repealed or not but
in 1917 in order to get out of a mental
institution you had to be sterilized and
in New Hampshire they sterilized over
almost close to a thousand people male
and female
so just because we can do it doesn't
mean we should thank you thank you very
much for your testimony any questions
from the committee seeing none we have
the Sandra Sandra Sanchez and then after
that Pally Rojas
is Cassandra still here I did we didn't
realize that the office of the child
advocate was here we would have tried to
see her
thank you and
hello members of the chair
um
or chairperson and members of the
committee
my name is Jennifer Madsen and I'm from
Manchester New Hampshire
I'm here to testify in the opposition to
house bill 619.
this bill directly contradicts the US
Department of education's guidelines for
supporting transgender youth in school
it ties pronouns to the gender binary
based on a person's assigned sex at
Birth and disregards gender neutral
neutral options like they them all
together
[Music]
I recently received a letter from my own
School
that referred to me as he
I am not a he
my pronouns are she her
however I was not mad
I figured it was a simple typographical
error
while I wasn't mad
reading that word over and over again
made me feel deep down inside
again I'm not here my pronouns are she
her
as a cisgender person I will never truly
know what it feels like to be
intentionally misgendered
but that letter gave me just the tiniest
taste of what transgender people go
through
so now I asked you all how would it feel
if you were intentionally misgendered
every day
would you feel welcomed would you feel
light would you feel respected
if your pronouns are he him and I called
you she her on purpose
would you feel respected
if your pronouns are she her and I
called you he him as a cisgender person
would you feel respected would you feel
light
now imagine yourself back in
School especially middle school and high
school
between anxiety
and having to go into from those
Elementary School years to those older
years those are very awkward years for
many many children no matter how they
identify
don't we want them to feel welcome at
school
I have a family member who's in high
school and is transgender
they use they them pronouns
if this bill passes they would be
misgendered every single day until they
graduate or until the bill is repealed
so I asked you again how would you feel
to decide against this and vote itl on
House Bill 619 because children are
people too who deserve basic respect
just like us adults
thank you very much for your time I do
not wish to answer questions as pronouns
are not up for debate with me because
they are a matter of basic respect in my
eyes thank you for your testimony
and we also are looking for Heather
Mullins
hi good afternoon and thank you for your
thank you
my name is Matthew shirka I'm
representing the national Center for
lesbian rights which is a legal
organization working to protect the
civil and human rights of lgbtq people
I'm also the co-founder of our born
perfect campaign a national campaign
representing survivors of conversion
therapy across the country including
myself a survivor of conversion therapy
again thank you for the opportunity to
express hours our strong opposition to
this bill in its entirety however I will
focus specifically on the section of the
bill that removes all protections from
so-called conversion therapy
our team has worked to protect lgbtq
youth by supporting legislation
protecting those youth from conversion
therapy thus far 20 U.S states and over
120 cities and municipalities have
passed such legislation to protect lgbtq
minors
each of these laws have passed with
bipartisan support out of the 20 States
eight Republican Governors have signed
the passage of these laws and almost 50
50 split of
bipartisan support Nationwide including
governor sununu
New Hampshire passed a ban on conversion
therapy to codify an already understood
issue with extraordinary amounts of
evidence that any attempts of conversion
therapy is harmful fraudulent and may
cause a lifelong damage and potential
suicide
personally I am one of seven hundred
thousand people living in the United
States today that have experienced
conversion therapy that number is as
reported by the UCLA Williams Institute
my personal experience in conversion
therapy unfortunately aligns with the
many harms reported by mental by the
national mental health and medical
associations
I was in conversion therapy for five
years from ages 16 through 21. each of
my therapists was a licensed
professional
when I came out to my father my father
made it clear how much he loved me that
I had nothing to fear yet my father
began to search for a therapist to
understand what my coming out May mean
for myself and for my family
in meeting with a licensed professional
again this is how the bill currently
exists in New Hampshire my father was
told that being gay was nothing more
than a mental illness that same-sex
attraction can be cured and that all
people are innately heterosexual
the therapist that further explained
that childhood traumas were the cause of
me being LG of myself being gay but
further for the entire lgbtq community
and that if I went to therapy and healed
those childhood traumas my same-sex
attraction would disappear
for my father this was a Lifeline moment
that he felt that he could possibly give
me a different outcome instead of being
gay
luckily for me I didn't have any
significant childhood traumas which
sorry
um supposedly the therapist that I was
working with and state and so their
diagnosis stated that I was too close to
my mother and my two sisters and not
close enough to my father my first
treatment required that I did not speak
to my mother and two sisters which
lasted three years
I was told this would ensure that I
would not pick up any effeminate
behaviors I would not see women or the
girls at school as my peers and that to
learn that men are my peers while I
truly believed conversion therapy was
working I became depressed and suicidal
in year two out of five
one of my therapists believed I was
ready to engage with women sexually I
was instructed to use step by step I was
instructed step by step how to engage
with women in my environment despite if
I led to believe our attractions were
loved maybe real or not I suffered
extreme anxiety around that and I was
not able to sexually perform
in this moment my therapist prescribed
described me Viagra through my father in
order to boost my confidence as a young
man I did not suffer from erectile
dysfunction I was just I was a healthy
young 17 year old boy
during those five years my parents spent
a total of thirty five thousand dollars
on my conversion therapy I dropped out
of college due to my depression anxiety
the entire ordeal was artificial
humiliating and demeaning
every licensed therapist knows or should
know this is a dangerous and fraudulent
practice anyone who carries a license in
the state of New Hampshire New Hampshire
knows that their educational curriculum
those requirements obtain a state
license that conversion therapy has no
significant backing
thank you if you could come to the
conclusion thank you yes
this is a law that already exists in New
Hampshire by repealing the law as it is
stated you will be allowing
therapists who are licensed by the state
the state's responsibility to protect
the youth
um to protect practice
one is something that is extremely
dangerous and too fraudulently make
money off of those profits thank you for
your time thank you very much for your
testimony any questions from the
committee
seeing none so Heather millins
and we have Russ Ann Chester
thank you my name is Russian Chester I'm
from Bedford New Hampshire I have been I
was born in 1960 in the state at nine
years old I started to develop I was not
comfortable with it and I used to bind
myself because I wasn't comfortable with
developing so young
um
had I had the opportunity to participate
in hormone therapy I may have I don't
know
um but I can say that I am proud that my
name is Russian and occasionally I get
misidentified as mister
I don't have a problem with that I don't
identify by what I look like or a label
I want to say I am truly appalled and
saddened that our state has gotten to
the point that we are identified by
labels that's the one thing about New
Hampshire that never existed we didn't
used to identify as he she they or they
them their or whatever furries we didn't
identify we identified as humans
the queer theory that took place that
someone mentioned I actually grew up
during that time and I struggled
the bottom line is the queer theory is
about dehumanization
and dehumanization is exactly what is
happening to all of our lgbtq community
folks tapping to the to the CIS
Community folks it's dehumanization this
bill has absolutely nothing to do with
hate it has nothing to do with trying to
take away parentals rights or faith it
has to do with schools who are set in
place to teach our children education
not to be involved with the
socio-emotional learning aspects the
bottom line is schools have our children
outside the school system they are have
they have 165 to 128 hours a week that
is not in the school system
I was a child advocate I was an advocate
for child abuse victims
I
hold myself partially responsible
for a girl
that I helped
transition because she she really told
me that that's what she wanted I helped
her find the resources out in our
community
I was the one that got her suicide note
because she wanted to de-transition
after the fact and the lgbtq community
was not accepting
so we talk about love and hate the
bottom line is is that love and hate is
absolutely
but don't stand on your faith and say I
love you so therefore as long as you
think like I do I'll support you
that's what the LGBT community is doing
to our our gay population and our truly
transgender population and it's not okay
and I'm willing to take any questions
thank you very much for your testimony
any questions no singing on thank you do
we have Lee Hollis here fantastic
howdy uh and thank you very much for
staying you're probably starving because
uh I wanted to try and touch on a couple
of the uh a couple of the things that
have been mentioned previously by other
testimony as well as some things that
hadn't um
that I haven't really seen come up too
much my name is Lee I was born and
raised in New Hampshire I am non-binary
and my trans partner couldn't be here
because disabled people have more
difficulty getting to speak in person
at events like this because of you know
being disabled so I also appreciate the
fact that we were able to submit online
testimony that's something that I didn't
know we could do and I think that's
great so
uh one bit of the first page that I
wanted to point out is that it marks um
it says that suicide rates and mortality
rates are elevated even in uh even in
trans people who have received gender
affirming care mortality rates also
include homicide
and homicide of transgender individuals
has increased by 400 percent
in the last I think five years
uh so yeah our modern our mortality
rates are increasing actually but it's
because we're being murdered
um and as for
increased suicide rates
other populations that have Market fee
increased suicide rates especially in
adolescents are women
and gay people and disabled people and
we've already done the song and dance
about protecting gay people and women
and disabled people hopefully we can do
more for all of those groups in the
future but
I
I can't imagine a world
I don't want to imagine a New Hampshire
that is
so in everybody's business
that they
think that it's appropriate to get
between
families and their doctors and
especially like
sorry
thank you you're doing great if you can
give us a conclusion it's right in that
time so thank you yeah
the primary thing that I want to point
out is that the majority of the people
who spoke in support of this bill even
they didn't support all of it the
majority of them were saying that they
support psychological treatment to
gender affirmation in schools
and the only person that that I saw who
like was gung-ho about the whole thing
was the guy who came in and compared it
to Nazi Eugenics and I don't think we
want to listen to that guy because he
was
like if you keep it to the topic and not
to people then thank you very much we've
gone over the three minutes we still
have all of these and we want to make
sure everybody's sorry so thank you so
much for your testimony
thank you for taking my question that
homicide statistics that you mentioned
do you know if it's National statistics
and do you know if this problem exists
in New Hampshire increased
occurrence of homicide of transgender
people I'm not 100 sure about New
Hampshire but I can get that information
and and send it over
any other questions
thank you I'm not saying any other
questions thank you very much do we have
Mackenzie Maloney here
good afternoon I can see you're all
tired and um good because so are we so
my name is Mackenzie Maloney I'm from
Manchester New Hampshire and I'm a
midshipman at the United States Merchant
Marine Academy to service Academy
I was nominated by The Honorable Senator
Shaheen the only woman this year to be
nominated in New England
I am also a member of the U.S armed
services
I meet a life-altering decision at the
age of 17. this is when I started to
join the military
why was I able to make a decision that
could lead me to ending a life
when this bill would stop me and other
people from saving one
I was diagnosed with PCOS at the age of
15 and put on estrogen should my care
have been stopped due to my age or is it
only because I was born with female
anatomy that I can get proper care
I went to the New Hampshire school
district and I have never had any
teacher Healthcare person or therapist
tell me who I was
what I did see was people struggling in
my JROTC program and other programs with
identity with no guidance I saw the
depression anxiety and self-hate consume
them
I saw what happens in the absence of
Education ignorance fear and Terror
this bill would be detrimental to young
children children who are confused and
in need of Education to push aside their
identity
but those in support of this bill is
correct
this would stop transgender people
transitioning at the age of 18 because
those people would not make it to the
thank you
thank you for your testimony
it is now 301 we still have a pretty
large stack of cards to respect
everybody's time we're going to we're
going to recess this hearing until
immediately following the hearing on
House Bill 368.
and
with that I'd like to introduce the
prime sponsor of House Bill 368 our very
we all may need just a moment for that
Whiplash of changing from one to the
other we just want to make sure we're
respecting everybody's time did you have
so you can submit that to the clerk we
we acknowledge how long the day has been
for everybody it's a really difficult
Balancing Act to make sure that
we're giving everybody the right amount
of time so that they can be heard and
also not step on other people's time so
thank you for hanging with us and
are we set to go we are thank you
representative
thank you madam chair
and fellow Representatives the committee
members
my name for the record is representative
Jerry Cannon I represent Stratford
County district 12. and that's the city
of Somersworth and the town of
Rollinsford
HB 368.
it's an act relative to protections
related to receiving gender affirming
health care or gender affirming mental
the
it's just started to brew and it's uh
and it's coming this uh
20 States including our own
who are have talked about
um
make it illegal
for a parent or or child to look for
gender
affirming health care and gender
affirming mental health care
and
we've we've heard from a number of
people who are considering moving to
and these people need protections
they
the bill this bill has already been
introduced in California in the past
and it offers people who are moving
to come to our state
and if they
are providing
gender affirming health care or mental
health care to their child here in our
state
that medical information
shall remain in this state if it could
be used
to prosecute them on charge us in the
so the the additional chapters in this
cover a number of areas
and instead of going through all the
details all the legislative details
um
I'll just cover it by the the titles of
the
chapter
354 C2 is essentially
that foreign subpoenas are prohibited
and this essentially that will
um
we we won't acknowledge those
essentially if someone asks for that
information it will stay here
this is um
very much
akin to hippo rights
is that Medical Care is not released
unless somebody authorizes it
encoding this in our statutes
to let people know the same thing that
happened only only the people that are
responsible for the health care of a
child
or themselves will have authorization to
and that leads to the next paragraph
354 C3
which is parental rights and
responsibility
essentially when a parent arrives here
they will be
allowed to get the health care they need
without having to share that information
I am not really familiar with the term
inconvenient forum
I can see my lawyer friend laughing
circling but
um
the courts our courts will decide
whether this is something they need to
take action on
the
in c54 3 C5 the domestic violence is is
actually a little more complex
because the court is involved with that
in in trying to make a decision based on
the situation of the family on what is
appropriate
the same thing is is true with the
in sections uh three three five four
C colon six the removal of a child from
a parent or Guardian
it comes down to was that removal lung
uh was was done legally and so the
parent that has that child here has has
I'll just read the first paragraph it is
in the public policy of this state that
an out-of-state arrest warrant for an
individual based on violating another
State's law against providing receiving
or allowing their child to receive
gender affirming health care or gender
affirming Mental Health Care is the
so in the paragraph it identifies three
areas
and
we are letting people know is that
we won't inform them
in this state
to bring a person back to that state if
it's associated with
a child getting
in 354 cea
reaffirms what was originally specified
I think that a health care
provider of Health Care Health Care
Service plan or contractor shall not re
release medical information related to a
person or entity allowing a child to
receive gender affirming health care or
in
354 C colon 9.
essentially the record any record of the
information associated with the health
care of a youth will not be shared
the
any records that do not discuss that
under a 3 354 C colon 10 arrest and
extradition
no state county or local law enforcement
agency shall make or in Talent
intentionally participate in the arrest
or recognize any demand for extradition
of an individual pursuant to a criminal
action
related to the law of another state
that criminalizes allowing a person to
receive or provide gender affirming
and 354 C only 11.
observability
um that's another good question for a
legal expert and and um so I mean this
this it covers a number of areas in in
other states as well we're putting I'm
requesting that we put this in place
to protect the family
of a child who moves to this state to
protect them from prosecution from the
state they left
because now they have become a New
Hampshire resident
and the responsibility of our state
thank you I
urge you to vote ought to pass so we can
protect people who move to our state
very much representative I have a
question
questions
thank you for taking my question
um the the are you aware of when you're
similar instances in New Hampshire when
we
stop law enforcements
from other states from doing the
investigation
stop a state from doing an investigation
but we will not provide any information
from this state
if if inquired
it's if they want to do an investigation
of any activity that occurred in their
state they can do so but a any
information associated with the gender
health care of a child
thank you
um
are you aware of other instances when we
don't share
we for what we don't allow Australian
information with law enforcement from
other states
representative
McLean thank you madam chair thanks for
taking my message
um are you aware of any incidence of
arrest or child removal for going out of
state to receive this kind of treatment
um are you aware of any incidences that
this bill would address historically
I I don't know of any specifically this
is this is in advance of these 20 states
that are considering this law currently
um actually I believe that at least one
state already does have a lot I'm trying
to remember if it's Florida or I want
one but there is at least one state that
has this in place I mean has a law that
makes it illegal for gender health care
and uh this is being done in advance to
let those family let families know if
they're looking for a safe haven that
they can move to our state and raise
thank you are there any other questions
from the committee thank you very much
representative
is Kate West here
Kate West
okay fantastic I will hold on to that
one if there's anybody else that you
know is just briefly up please let us
know Journey Lafond
yes would you like to speak thank you
can you push the red button thank you
got it thank you so much everyone
my name is Journey Lafond once again I
am a conquered Community member I'm a
therapist and I'm a parent to a
transgender youth
and I am very thankful to be able to say
that my son is still with us today
and we owe that blessing largely to the
fact that he's been able to receive
gender affirming care in this state
my work with young people in the lgbtq
plus Community has further cemented my
belief that the best care whether mental
health medical or non-medical Services
is care that empowers a young person to
tell us who they are
when a young person discloses to their
family that they are lgbtq plus and the
response is one of invalidation Despair
denial or even anger the resulting
damage can take years to heal if that
to be invalidated or even ostracized by
one's own family creates a wound that
not everyone is able to overcome which
is why we talk about suicide rates rates
of substance misuse and homelessness
trending so high almost lgbtq plus youth
the damage extends beyond the young
person to the family who then feel the
impact of that loss either that
relationship or the young person
themselves
when on the other hand they are met with
validation acceptance and affirming care
the prognosis changes dramatically
these young people are more confident
and engage in healthier habits and
healthier lifestyle why would we deny
young people from other states the
ability to obtain care that affirms who
they know themselves to be
how can we in New Hampshire bar anyone
from the care that they need to live
free and self-actualize lives I am here
to support HB 368 and I'm here to
support lgbtq plus youth that's all for
me but I'm happy to take questions thank
you for your testimony any questions
from the committee
seeing none thank you thank you
thank you
um is
is guanidine Ricard Hayes here
fantastic thank you and then next we'll
have Morgan Brown if Morgan's here
and we're keeping it to three minutes
good morning members of the committee my
name is Gwendolyn Ricard Hayes I'm a
resident of Epping New Hampshire I'm
here today to speak in strong support of
house bill 368. those of us who have
been paying close attention to the
National conversation around trans
people may have noticed something
startling a certain faction of this
country has quickly ramped up the
rhetoric to genocidal levels look no
further than the most recent CPAC
conference where prominent far-right
figure Michael Knowles blatantly calls
for our eradication this is one of a
multitude of examples
should they get their way transness
would be completely eliminated from
public life this is akin to eliminating
Jewish people from public life being
trans is an integral and inherent part
of who we are calls to remove transness
are calls to remove trans people and we
all know how unwanted minority groups
have historically been removed
there's zero doubt about it the far
right are attempting to manifest the
genocide the early stages you're getting
pretty far into accusations could you
please get to more of the content
there's zero doubt about it and the
early stages have already begun as of as
of now trans people trans children are
the focus bills that forcibly
detransition youth punish parents for
seeking life-saving treatment for their
kids along with many more discussing
pieces of legislation that have been
seen in almost every single state
including this one they won't start stop
at targeting kids there's already been
bills introduced to forcibly decent
detransition adults if this goes
unchecked there will soon be Mass Graves
it won't be long until we have trans
refugees personally I have already made
plans in the case that my state decides
to betray me all terrains people have to
consider if their home will be safe for
them in the future those who make the
decision to flee must be welcomed with
open and loving arms with that
established we come to house bill 368.
in essence this would make New Hampshire
a safe safe haven for Trans people it
would ensure that access to gender
affirming care is unimpeded and content
financiality is protected from
out-of-state subpoenas were this to pass
an enormous weight would be lifted off
the back of all trans people living
within the state the amount of stress we
undergo having to see this country
attempts to legislate us out of
existence is debilitating the future as
a trans person in America is scary and
uncertain we are staring down the barrel
of a genocide please show us that you
accept trans people for who we are and
will protect us from the powerful forces
that wish to do us harm vote ought to
pass on House Bill 368 to save the lives
of trans people thank you thank you for
your testimony next time you testify if
he could please be a little less
accusatory to people that would be very
very helpful to the case thank you
any questions from the committee thank
you Morgan Brown and after Morgan Althea
you have three minutes thank you thank
you good afternoon chair and members of
the committee my name is Morgan Brown
and I'm from Dover and I'm here to
testify in support of house bill 368. by
protecting gender affirming care in New
Hampshire for people living out of state
we protect our patients and our health
care providers as well
I've been working in healthcare for
nearly 12 years in a variety of
capacities from being a pharmacy
technician nursing assistant and now
registered nurse
in the past
almost 12 years just shy that
I have had the honor to care for
patients while ages from Pediatrics to
long-term Assisted Living
and I know that I must uphold nursing
ethics by protecting patients
confidentiality and this bill would
protect people from being from being
pressured to share confidential and
sensitive health information
to out-of-state entities
under HIPAA
which
was enacted in 1996 gender affirming
and according to the Department of
Health and Human Services
it the information under HIPAA is
individually identifiable health
information it's information including
demographic data
and it also protects an individual's
past present or future physical or
right now we are seeing legislation in
other states such as Tennessee
that is Banning life-saving Medical
Treatments such as gender affirming
health care and this is gender
discrimination and neglect of proper
Health Care
these people will need to leave their
home states to continue accessing
life-sustaining therapies and New
Hampshire needs to be proactive in
protecting that
safeguarding access to gender affirming
care in New Hampshire creates safer
Healthcare environments for all people
including New Hampshire residents and
New Hampshire health care providers
it is only a matter of time before our
health care providers
or doctors and our nurses are being
questioned by out-of-state law
enforcement about health care treatments
being performed in New Hampshire
bypassing House Bill 368 you would
protect all New Hampshire health care
providers in continuing to protect HIPAA
and avoid ethical and moral dilemmas
and HIPAA violations
I urge you to vote ought to pass on
House Bill 368. thank you for your time
and I will not be taking questions thank
you very much for your testimony is
Athena jacobowitz here
Henry Feldman
is Brady Berry still here
fantastic thank you very much and next
we'll have best care after Brady thank
you thank you and hello again thank you
for your patience today
um as I said a couple of hours ago my
name is Brady Berry I'm a student at the
University of New Hampshire and I am
transgender and non-binary
um in short gender affirming care Saved
My Life
um before I started my medical
transition every day was full of
constant anxiety and a state of
depression
being perceived as a woman when I knew I
wasn't one was an exhausting
never-ending source of stress
waking up daily and feeling no
connection to the body that physically
held me up was deeply disheartening
all of this led me to try and end my
life two separate times because I felt
so hopeless to live in this body
today I stand before you haven't been
having been doing gender affirming care
in the form of hormone replacement
therapy for over two years I can
genuinely say I've never been happier
starting to take hormones began my
journey to becoming my authentic self
and I'm still on that Journey while
testosterone has made my voice deeper my
face more square and given me facial
hair the impact is much deeper than that
the impact is self-love for the person I
am and the person I'm becoming the
impact is significantly better mental
health and easier time focusing and an
easier time holding meaningful
relationships
more than this I'm a college student
from Maine going to school here in the
state of New Hampshire and I get my
hormones here
being able to have access to this care
in the state where I spend most of my
time has made my life significantly
easier and it made it so I don't have to
worry about traveling to a different
state just to feel like myself
while I'm lucky that gender information
care is legal in Maine as well there are
citizens of other states who can't say
the same no one should have to be scared
to seek out the care that is going to
greatly improve their quality of life
and for people in states that allow
gender affirming care that feels fear is
a reality
it is so vital that we keep gender
affirming Healthcare safe and accessible
in this state with so many other states
gatekeeping their gender affirming Care
New Hampshire has the ability to be a
safe haven for so many people
no one is wrong for seeking out gender
affirming care and they should not be
treated as a criminal for doing so
I spent 18 years on this Earth before I
could access the care I needed and it
changed my life for these reasons I urge
you to support hb368 and to support the
lives of other transgender folks
Nationwide
thank you very much for your testimony
any questions from the committee and if
you'd like to submit the written
testimony for the record thank you and
thank you now we have best care and
after that we will have Jay lebreck I
think that's that's scared from Nashua I
was surprised when the lobbyist for HB
619 who was with the organization born
perfect
didn't testify in favor of 619 because
it's all about kids being born perfect
just the way they are
my niece who grew up in a dysfunctional
family situation went on testosterone as
a 17 year old
she thought it would solve her problems
but it only made them worse
she died at 21 from a drug overdose
after threatening suicide
a young California woman Chloe Cole
testified about her experience
transitioning as a minor she began to
transition to a male at 13 she had a
double mastectomy at 15 and she
de-transitioned at 17. from her
testimony despite all these
consultations and classes I don't feel
like I understood all the ramifications
that came with any of the medical
decisions I was making I didn't realize
how traumatic the recovery from my
double mastectomy would be
the worst part about my transition would
be the long-term health effects that I
didn't knowingly consent to at the time
from Lisa Marciano writing in the
journal psychological perspectives
there's plenty of anecdotal evidence
that young people are receiving hormone
hormone prescriptions without careful
assessment
in the study of 200d transition women 65
percent of them responded that they
received no therapy before starting
hormones most who had been so had been
to therapy at only a handful of sessions
before being given a letter for hormones
the median age for starting transition
among those who answered was 17. that's
Carrie Stella a young woman who posted a
video on YouTube about her experiences
both transitioning as a minor and D
transitioning as an adult reports that
no one told her she had any other
options they don't tell you that it's
okay to be Butch to be gender
non-conforming
to not like men
to not like the way men treat you they
tell you about testosterone
Stella asks how many other medical
conditions are there where you can walk
into the doctor's office tell them you
have a certain condition which has no
objective test which can be caused by
trauma or mental issues
or others or societal factors and
receive life-altering medications on
your say so
please don't make New Hampshire into a
sanctuary state where you
where kids and teens are being
fast-tracked
onto into medical transition losing
their dis damaging their bodies
irreversibly and becoming infertile
please vote itl and HB 368
thank you very much for your testimony
representative
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question so in this scenario
if a mind levels greeting some hormonal
treatment or some other
irreversible treatment without proper
uh
identifications and proper understanding
is there any legal way in the future for
that person to go after medical
professionals so other people
responsible for that
did you mean to turn back
yeah I mean
is there any legal recourse for
the transition
to go after people who transitioned
Himachal without proper notifying about
side effects for example
well I mean theoretically they could I
mean Chloe Cole is suing Kaiser
Permanente in California and there's
there's other
detransitioners who are suing and I I
look forward to the day that happens in
New Hampshire too because
there's a lot of people doing bad things
for the kids and and they really
shouldn't you know they really should be
thank you very much seeing no further
questions I'm going to hand the gavel
foreign
okay next up to speak is a Jayla Breck
good afternoon members of the committee
my name is Jay lebreck I was born down
the street in Concord and I've lived in
New Hampshire my whole life
I'm trans non-binary I'm 20 years old
though I can confidently say I feel much
older with the constant weight on my
back of having to prove to people that I
exist
it's exhausting and the pain we
experience is real
but
I must stand up for kids like me
so I am standing here today because I
was allowed to be who I am now and
always have been I urge you to support
368.
in the past few weeks several states
have passed or are considering passing
dangerous legislation that would
prohibit gender affirming care for
minors not only is this cruel and
inhumane but will likely be deadly for
Trans youth in these states I believe
that the state of New Hampshire holds an
obligation to protect any children that
pass within our borders and this
includes protecting their supportive
parents from prosecution
I know firsthand how life-changing and
life-saving it is to receive the care
that you need to exist as your authentic
self before I transitioned I struggled a
lot as a kid to try to figure out what
was wrong with me despite popular belief
no one suggested that there was any
possibility that I could be transgender
I was never ever told about the topic it
was it nothing that ever came up in
conversation and where I live being
gender non-conforming was not
necessarily welcomed with open arms
this was a time where I could have
flourished instead I felt ashamed of
myself I've long thought about what I
could have achieved in public schools if
my trans peers and I had received some
form of gender affirming care or
guidance My Hope Was That by this time
society would have evolved to support
trans kids and allow them to thrive but
it is clear that in many states this is
not the case however as of right now New
Hampshire remains a place where children
can receive the care that they need it
is essential that their parents be
protected from prosecution by their home
States for seeking this care if this
bill is not passed parents may not be
able to legally help their child even
after leaving their home state to do so
losing a child is every parent's worst
nightmare and parents of transgender
youth would have to choose between
risking their child's life and
well-being or being prosecuted this is
an unnecessary choice that no parent
should have to make
thank you thank you
I'll accept any questions any questions
from committee representative McLean
thank you Mr chair and uh thank you for
sharing your story
um I did have one question though in in
the states that you said that are
bringing forth this legislation are you
aware is there a component of that
legislation
um that would legally penalize parents
if they go to another state uh so that
their children can have this kind of
care
yes so uh I have unfortunately I'm a
college student have had a lot of time
to read up on all of them because as far
as I'm aware there are over uh several
hundred of those bills
um just targeting transgender people in
general so I am not aware as to whether
or not that is something that is a
Incorporated in those bills but that's
definitely something to further research
yes
seeing none thank you thank you I have
written testimony yeah yeah please bring
next up to speak is Kim Peasley to be
so that person is
are they here
okay thank you
Courtney Reed is that person still here
okay
and after Courtney Reed will be Sam
Hawkins
picture McDonald and
a knee for giving us so much time to
speak today my name is Courtney Reed and
I'm here on behalf of the ACLU of New
Hampshire and I wanted to test upon
testify in support of HB 368 which as
we've heard would protect out of state
transgender Health Care Seekers from
being prosecuted when they return to
their home States I want to underscore
that New Hampshire should be proactive
in protecting the right for gender
affirming care because the current
political landscape has issued out
numerous attacks on the right to
affirming care for transgender youth in
particular about 58 200 transgender
youth in the U.S are currently at risk
of losing access to care because of
these possible bans and we're seeing in
23 States bills are considered being
considered that would ban gender
affirming care
and we know that medical experts agree
that gender affirming care is medically
necessary and life-saving care
so politicians shouldn't intervene in
these medical decisions that belong to
Children parents and their doctors
and we've also seen recent polling in
deep red States and at the national
level the bans on gender affirming care
are unpopular
recently 71 percent of pulled
kentuckians said they would oppose state
law that restricts bans restricts access
to gender affirming care and 66 percent
of adults Nationwide oppose limits on
transition related medical care for
minors
so I'd like to just reiterate that it's
time that the granite state make things
clear that legislators have no business
telling parents they cannot um
seek life-saving care for their
transgender children
and for many people affirming care is is
necessary for basic survival and
everyone has the right to be themselves
whether it be in school or in other
environments so it's time that we
protect these rights in the granite
state bypassing 368. thank you and I can
take any questions thank you
questions from committee members yes
representative McLean
yeah thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question so I just kind of
want to follow up on the question that
you know I asked Mr lebreck which was
um with the 23 states that you mentioned
that are considering the ban
Incorporated in any one of those 23
considerations is there anything that
would
bring forth civil or criminal penalties
on those folks that left the state to
seek that kind of care for their
children
yeah thank you so
I want to let our
Allied attorneys in the room answer that
question better than my own ability
because I'm not a practicing attorney
but from my understanding
legislation that we're considering today
that would ban affirming care also puts
providers who offer out-of-state
referrals at risk of civil and criminal
suits so if you want to refer someone
seeking gender affirming care in a state
where it is still legal you are subject
to risk of litigation and I think that's
what this bill aims to protect people
seeking care in New Hampshire from
thank you yeah other questions
saying all the questions thank you oh
I'm sorry oh representative Weber I'm
sorry
you're quite all right
so am I right in thinking that the
purpose of this is perspectively to to
protect the rights of parents to parent
their children
and also a medical practitioners
wherever they are located to be able to
treat their patients
in accordance with best medical
practices free from governmental
interference
that's my understanding of the
legislation and moreover it's
enabling that right to care for
I think that's it okay thank you thank
you
next up to speak is Sam Hawkins and then
Stephanie Cowley
thank you for the opportunity to testify
today my name is Sam Hawkins I'm the
public policy assistant at Nami New
Hampshire the National Alliance on
Mental Illness on behalf of Nami New
Hampshire I'm here today to speak in
support of HB 638 368.
uh at this point you've heard the
statistics surrounding depression and
suicide for Trans individuals and you've
heard the solution
access to care
multiple studies show that gender
affirming medical treatment is
significantly associated with lowered
odds of depression and suicide attempts
for transgender and non-binary Youth not
only is the availability of this care
necessity but in light the legislative
attacks both locally and Across the
Nation gender affirming care must be
made safe and protected for the
individuals and families that pursue it
in 2021 the American Medical Association
firmly stated their opposition to the
rise of governmental overreach into
medical care for transgender and
non-binary individuals
Michael souk MD JD and board member for
the AMA is quoted as saying gender
affirming care is medically necessary
evidence-based care that improves the
physical and mental health of
transgender and gender diverse people
and that the organization quote opposes
the dangerous intrusion of government
into the practice of medicine and the
criminalization of Health Care decision
making
gender affirming care is life-saving
care and we must dedicate ourselves to
providing whatever protections are
necessary for its continued practice the
safeguards present in HB 368 help
accomplish this goal and would allow
individuals and families to feel safe
pursuing this Critical Care in the
granite state additionally this bill
would go far in establishing New
Hampshire as a welcoming and affirming
environment for all transgender and
non-binary people in their families
supportive of their physical and mental
well-being for these reasons Nami New
Hampshire urges the committee to vote
ought to pass
I'll take any questions okay thank you
questions from the committee
staying on thank you thank you
next up to speak is Stephanie Cowley to
that person here
not seeing okay Brittany Jewett are you
after Brittany Jewett will be Chris
hertzel
all right thank you my name is Brittany
Jewett I am a UNH Social Work student
master of social work I am also a
transgender veteran if I had not been
afforded the opportunity to reach out to
a helpline and get mental health I would
not be standing here today four years
ago I would have killed myself over a
janitor identity crisis I applaud this
committee for hearing this bill and
those who propose it to protect medical
and mental health
affirming care for all in this state it
is very important that we protect every
individual as we are all humans I
appreciate your day today I know it has
been long I thank you and that is all I
have to say thank you
thank you you're taking questions
any questions
next step to speak is Chris Churchill to
be followed by Malachi Goodwin
thank you chair McDonald and thank you
to the committee and thank you to rep
Cannon for introducing this really
important piece of legislation
um I kind of want to break this down in
a little more practical way than what
we've been hearing so far in the state
of Texas one year ago almost to this
week I think one year ago the Department
of Children and Family Services in that
state began investigating families and
removing with the intent to remove
children from their homes if their
parents were allowing them or supporting
them in obtaining gender affirming
health care and uh as you can imagine
there was a really really scary time for
those families who were actively seeking
out health care for for their children
and and it doesn't matter what your
political beliefs are I think every
single person in this room can relate to
or can imagine can put themselves in the
shoes of someone who's being told that
their kids will be taken from them if
they continue to pursue health care for
their children and what are parents
supposed to do in those situations in
some situations Brave parents have stuck
around and fought and we've you know my
organizations involved in litigation in
Alabama and other litigation has been
going on across the country in states
where they have been outlawing this kind
of health care but other families who
can't afford to be as Brave will leave
that's what that's what a good parent
would do when your doctor says this is
the health care your child needs you
leave and the the purpose of this bill
and the wonderful benefit that it
provides to families who are in this
situation it doesn't say that the states
can't continue to investigate uh you
know and enforce their laws all it says
is that New Hampshire isn't going to be
complicit actively participating in that
investigation into some of the questions
that I heard earlier
um
yes there are investigations that go
beyond this the boundaries of a state
um yes there are other examples where
New Hampshire government does not take
an active role in helping other states
carry out their investigations
conforming to their own laws and
um also there was anyway I'm happy to
take other questions it's just a really
sensible piece of legislation that
protects families oh I wanted to mention
that people who
um refer out so you heard from doctors
today doctors who have ethical
obligations to their patients they're
not going to tell families no you can't
retain health care anymore because our
state outlawed it they're going to say
let me help you find some way to get
health care for your kid and that might
mean going out of state
does New Hampshire really want to
actively participate in Prosecuting
those practitioners who refer people to
other states no of course not that's
what this legislation ensures for
families and um and I'm happy to take
questions
thank you questions
gentlemen
yes representative McLean
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question so just getting you
know to the case for need so what you're
saying is that actually in Texas there
has been active seeking of removal
um
if a family has left the state to
receive care right now currently the
process has been enjoined by a court and
I believe that injunction is still in
place but what happened the day that the
policy went through
um an employee of department and
Children and Family Services has a
transgender kid it was known to other
people in the um in in that department a
staffer was sent to that person's home
with the notice of investigation and
that's when the lawsuit was filed that
stopped it but if that lawsuit hadn't
been filed and if the court hadn't
enjoined the enforcement of it right now
families would be under an investigation
and that investigation would not be
confined to the boundaries of Texas they
would they would investigate to the
extent that they wish to in that state
follow-up
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my follow-up so had that
individual chosen to seek that care in
New Hampshire then that is where this
bill would come into play yes precisely
thank you yes and um
and also I just realized I never
identified myself my name is Chris
archel I'm an attorney with glbtq legal
Advocates and Defenders uh based in
Boston I'm a New Hampshire licensed
attorney sorry for not saying that at
the outset
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
uh just to be clear isn't it true that
dcyf in or their equivalent in other
states
routinely go into other states to
investigate circumstances that relate to
a particular child who uh who who is
or to investigate a parent who is under
investigation for abuse or neglect of a
child
yeah for sure for sure and um and uh I
believe that the domestic violence
provision actually addresses this kind
of situation where where where nobody
wants to impede the investigation of
another state into instances of child
abuse or instances of kidnapping which
are common things unfortunately uh that
that that that cross state lines
um and all this bill is doing is saying
when it comes to a parent who's seeking
health care for their kids outside of a
state where it's prohibited that New
Hampshire is not going to actively
participate in um in in Prosecuting that
crime
okay I'm saying none thank you thank you
the final person I have signed up to
testify on House Bill 368 is Malachi
Goodwin
I'm Malachi I'm 21. um I'm here to
represent myself in both my trans
girlfriend who couldn't make it I didn't
write that on the letter thing but um
I'm here for her as well
so he mentioned the kidnapping because
I'm gonna like really incubate that
Florida like just introduced a bill that
would allow parents to legally kidnap
um you know break the custodial lines
and kidnap a their trans kid
um in case it's the idea of the
possibility not even doing it the
possibility of them receiving gender for
my care they can kidnap their child
across state lines as well
um so I wanted to put that in real fast
uh New Hampshire's motto is live for
your die in House Bill 368 will help
trans people do just that as well as
protect trans refugees across the
country
Oklahoma is trying to ban all gender
affirming care for all ages not even
just trying to protect the children is
all
other states such as Oregon Virginia
Arkansas Indiana Washington Florida
Mississippi South Dakota I can go on
there's like 33 states that have
introduced anti-trans bills in some way
including New Hampshire and that's sad
um
all these states are trying to erase
criminalize and ban the existence of
trans people on the train Sanctuary bill
is more important than ever Canada's
even introduced a refugee bill for those
who are fleeing their state to still be
able to receive gender affirming care
um
you know trying to fleeing to avoid
prosecution or loss of their rights
um you know we can join Illinois and
California in protecting a marginalized
minority that's under genocide and has
many many organizes many organizations
agree that what is occurring is genocide
is attempted modern genocide
um
we need more protection than ever
it's gender from care has shown time and
time again through multiple different
studies from
different countries and different
organizations proving that gender
affirmative care does help
and it reduces suicidal radiation
increases quality of life I can say from
my personal experience that coming I was
suicidal and depressed anxious I had OCD
before coming out and as I've been able
to transition and be more who I am I am
now in remission all my illnesses are in
remission besides maybe my depression
because this is the society that I live
in it is scary I am scared
I'm not certain that New Hampshire will
come to it but you know I believe in us
to not do that but it's scary I have
trans friends that are fleeing their
states I have I've known of many people
being prosecuted
forward trying to take care of
themselves there's other states that are
trying to ban the existence of trans
people in public
making it a felony
we need to protect us like you have 15
seconds please stop wrapping up it's
it's kind of all I have to say is just
New Hampshire's live for your die and
this bill is protecting that right thank
okay I have no one else signed up to
testify on a house bill on this
particular House Bill does anyone else
wish to testify
I'm seeing no one so I'm going to close
the public hearing on this on House Bill
368 and reopen the house the public
hearing on House Bill 619.
and I'll just call out names one at a
time because I know a number of folks
have had to leave it's been a long day
and
georgianne Clipper Piper
and if
yes and after that City councilor Karen
um uh good afternoon Representatives
my name is Zoe Hill I am a 16 year old
Junior at Lebanon High School
I am here today to oppose HB 619.
this bill among many other terrible
things would ban gender affirmation in
schools
I am in a high school and when my
teachers make a point to use my correct
pronouns and change their language to
include me it makes me feel seen and
loved and cared for
but when this doesn't happen when they
misgender me when they exclude me from
their
um
language and when I can't go to the
bathroom in a play in a public place I
feel really terrible about myself and it
really digs up my self-esteem
and
um
all this to say gender affirmation in
schools and in public in general is
extremely important for Trans kids
across the state
so please oppose HB uh 619 for the state
for the sake of trans children all
okay next up to speak is City councilor
Karen layout Hill
is she's okay she is coming here and
good afternoon my name is Karen Leo Hill
I am an 18-year City councilor in
Lebanon and um
most proudly I am the mom of Zoe
I am here also to stand with my trans
child and trans people across New
Hampshire
um I'm very proud to come from a city
where we have adopted an inclusiveness
resolution we are a welcoming City and
it is my hope that New Hampshire will be
a welcoming State HB 619 flies in the
values that we hold dear in Lebanon and
that I believe we hold deer across the
state and so I ask you to vote itl on
this bill and I will add my personal
perspective that
when when we got a report card recently
and Zoe's teachers made the point to use
the correct pronoun
I could see it in my child's face what
it meant to be affirmed in that way and
so even in my child who comes from a
supportive welcoming home
it makes a difference when schools
are a safe place a welcoming place and
so on behalf of all children across the
state I ask you to vote itl on hb619
Lisa Norton McRae
okay
after after this person it'll be Sam
Hawkins
good afternoon I'm Lisa Norton Mercado
and I live in Loudon and I'm a mom of a
cisgendered gay male and a wife as well
and he has quite a few transgendered
friends who have spent quite a bit of
time in my house I'm here to oppose this
bill H.B 619 this is government
overreach the government should not be
dictating to people what to do with
their bodies
and to parents as to how to raise their
children
um
this is in direct conflict with our
the age of consent in the state for many
things is 16 and
for some things it's even 14. you can
get married at the age of 16 in this
state major life decision
you can have children and receive
prenatal care without the consent of or
knowledge of your parents at the age of
16.
okay
um with the approval of a judge you can
even terminate our pregnancy
without the consent or knowledge of your
parents
you can receive birth control
without the consent or knowledge of your
parent at the age of 14.
so if we're saying
that kids are old enough to make all of
these major life decisions having
children getting married
terminating pregnancies
then why can't they have gender
affirming treatment
it doesn't make any sense there are
people who have testified today saying
oh they're so vulnerable their brains
aren't developed yet they can't but
we're letting them do these other things
so if this bill passes when we have to
change all those other laws
at 17 you become can become emancipated
in this state
there are a few people who have
testified today that they have
detransitions
and their stories are valid and they
should be considered by the committee
but we need to be careful that we're not
going to wipe out the rights of an
entire group of people because some
people have chosen to detransition so
please keep that in mind
there's been talk about child abuse
but isn't it child abuse to kick your
translation
yep out of your home
and make them find another place to live
when they're a minor because you don't
I want the committee to consider these
things that I've said
and oppose this Bill thank you very much
next up to speak is Sam Hawkins followed
by Deborah house
thank you again for the opportunity to
testify and thank you for your patience
I'll Bridge my comments in the interest
of time and I've submitted written
testimony for both this in the previous
Bill my name is Sam Hawkins I'm the
public policy assistant at Nami New
Hampshire and I'm here today to speak in
opposition to hb619
uh one more time in 2022 39 of lgbtq
Youth in New Hampshire seriously
considered suicide and 10 percent
attempted it Beyond New Hampshire 82
percent of transgender individuals
across the U.S and Canada have
considered suicide and 40 have attempted
it
so there's no confusion we also want to
be clear that these increased rates of
mental health symptoms are not
inextricably linked with one's gender
identity or sexual orientation rather as
stated by the president of the American
Medical Association it is quote the
result of stigma discrimination and
mistreatment with support at home school
and in the community and with access to
gender affirming care transgender youth
do as well on Mental Health measures as
their non-transgender peers end quote
access to gender affirming Medical Care
is crucial to improve mental health
outcomes for transgender and non-binary
youth multiple studies show that gender
affirming treatment has a significant
association with lowered odds of
depression and suicide attempts
additionally access to Identity
affirming spaces is one of the most
significant ways to promote trans
well-being and reduce suicidality in New
Hampshire only 18 percent of lgbtq Youth
believe their community at large to be
very accepting we expect this to worsen
by the guidelines relating to schools in
this bill
finally Nami New Hampshire remains
firmly opposed to the damaging practice
of conversion therapy and believes that
its prohibition and law must remain
strict last year during testimony on a
similar Bill we heard we heard
repeatedly that conversion therapy does
not happen in New Hampshire however
recent data from the Trevor Project
revealed that in 2022 in New Hampshire
nine percent of lgbtq Youth surveyed
reported being threatened with
conversion therapy and four percent
reported being subjected to it
hb619 seeks to damage the livelihood of
transgender and non-binary youth by
restricting their access to life-saving
care if put into law this bill will harm
transgender non-binary youth in cost
lives
for those reasons Norman New Hampshire
strongly urges the committee to vote in
expedient to legislate for HB 619 and
take any questions
I'm seeing none thank you thank you very
much
Deborah house is okay thank you
the next step to speak will be Stephanie
Preston
okay good afternoon chairman McDonald
and members of the committee I want to
thank you all for your time today and uh
for staying for this long hearing uh I
am Deborah house president of the
American Federation of teachers New
Hampshire we have 4 000 members across
the state mostly in pre-k through 12
education uh in all aspects of that so
teachers para Educators all sorts of
schools support staff we also have a
University faculty in the State
University system and public employees
in different areas of the state and I
just want to bring a few points up
because you've heard a lot of testimony
today we opposed this bill and there
have been many people have spoken
eloquently on why the bill should be
opposed but I want to speak on a couple
of things about the education portion of
the bill that I want to make sure you
understand
you know as teachers as human beings as
professionals covered by the code of
conduct
we are required
and frankly you know we really there's
no other way to operate we treat all our
students with respect that is something
this bill would require us to treat a
segment of our students disrespectfully
and discriminate against them
that's what you're asking us to do and
you'll be asking us to violate our code
of conduct to follow this bill if you
pass it
so we could be in danger of
[Music]
um
losing our job or having disciplinary
action taken against us if we followed
because we would be disrespecting our
students well we could be in danger if
we didn't disrespect the students
because then parents could be final in
complaints against us for violating the
bill so you put us in a horrible
situation besides just the fact that we
need to build respectful relationships
in the classroom with our students
because students do not learn if they do
not feel safe and welcome and accepted
no student is going to learn at a place
where they feel unsafe that's just
Maslow's hierarchy of needs
you're not going to get any education
done if they are always worried about
am I okay here am I going to be teased
I'm going to be bullied um what's going
to happen next if you're not going to
let us get to that if you're going to
force it to be disrespectful to our
students and discriminate against them
education cannot happen so we are urging
you to
about this bill in expedient to
legislate and certainly you should not
be forcing us to choose between
discriminating against our students or
losing our jobs
those are horrible choices thank you
yeah any questions
Stephanie Preston this is Stephanie
Erica
Agro
and after that it will be April Ariel
Moore
hello my name is Erica
New Hampshire I was I was raised here
and I went to college and I'm currently
back currently back here and
um I I'm only testifying for myself but
I have been working in the Merrimack
Cowboy School District as a substitute
working with a bunch of fifth grades K
through six
um just you know for the past bit so I'm
only representing myself but I've been
in the school public school district and
I just I I'm here as someone who
cares a lot about trans people and trans
kids and wants to be safe and I'm here
strongly opposing this bill
um at the beginning of your bill it says
that we're not that it matters um that
New Hampshire is a compelling government
interest in protecting the health and
safety of its citizens especially
vulnerable children and I'd argue that
and it's I'd say it's almost proven that
trans children are one of the most
vulnerable groups of kids and this bills
would make that worse
um and I'm not going to throw a bunch of
Statistics out that other people have
already thrown out but just know that I
do stand
um with the majority of the medical
community and saying that conversion
therapy saves a lot not conversion
therapy sorry gender affirming Care
Health Care saves lives and is effective
and is overall very helpful and a good
resource the Trevor report which someone
had mentioned before but a 2021 survey
of the national Trevor report said that
94 reported that recent politics
negatively impacted their Mental Health
and the and then the state report for
2022 also by the Trevor by the Trevor
report in New Hampshire said that
37 of Tran of lgbtq Youth said that
recent policies recent politics
negatively impacted their well-being and
43 which is the highest percentage in
this poll said that it impacted their
well-being a lot
and it and these are
and as well as harmful being harmful
this bill also
I know that other people had mentioned
the statistics
that you let that you list and I think
we know where that is on that first page
um saying that it's you know for the
0.005
um if you actually look in that study
um which the name of it is I can
actually read that off is um
the gender dysphoria on adults an
overview and primer for psychiatrists if
you go that's that is taken from the
epidemiology section looking at the
history of trans people in transness as
a societal phenomenon and it a couple
seconds a couple sentences later in that
report it says the quote that this
statistic does not reflect the
prevalence of all individuals with
gender dysphoria or who identifies
transgender and to this conclusion of
that same study says that mental health
professionals must fully appreciate that
the focus of treatment for gender
dysphoria is on the dysphoria not the
gender identity
and I just think that this
misinformation is dangerous and
the idea that trans that this kind of
ideas are prevalent in our schools is
simply untrue I myself am non-binary and
I have and not a single person that
works with me in the school district and
especially none of the children that
I've the many hundreds of children that
I've you know substitute taught for know
that because I consistently misgender
myself
and not because I am not wrapping up you
start wrapping up yeah no it's um yeah
and I trust me these kids are scared I
am deliberately making myself
uncomfortable and misgendering myself
because I already fear the consequences
of telling the child of telling the kids
what I identify as so it's not about
medical things it's it's nothing this
builds beyond that it's part of the a
rhetoric that's harmful to everyone and
is stopping people not from getting
medical care or doing medical things but
this is a bill that stops people that
doesn't allow people to be themselves in
any questions
seeing no questions thank you
next signed up to speak is Ariel Moore
I again still representing myself and my
girlfriend
um
earlier we heard someone mention how if
you encourage an anorexic you know they
die if you encourage an anorex if they
die if you encourage transition they get
so fulfilled living they get to they get
to have a fulfilling life
um if it's you know oh like that's the
medical you have to you're paying into
the medical for life just go to therapy
I went to therapy for seven years and it
didn't really do anything if I went with
that path I'd be spending money on drugs
that didn't help and therapy spending
hundreds of dollars on that for years
for forever because it didn't help but
now that I have the care I need I don't
need to spend as much to do it I mean I
still spend a little but nowhere near
the amount that I was spending before
um mostly my biggest issue with this
thing is
the complete Erasure of intersex people
and how this explicitly allows General
mutilations on intersex babies despite
it being
um the title being sorry give me a
second protection against child and
medical psychological experimentation
Act
surgeries on infants is exactly that
they and someone else mentioned how
earlier in support of it I sounded like
saying how oh they have to choose one or
the other no they don't
studies show that forcing intersex
babies to have these surgeries
does exactly what happens trans kids who
don't get to live their life it causes
sexual dysfunction a proven
and overall psychological distress they
have to go to therapy because they rely
to by their parents
um also New Hampshire legally recognizes
other sexes we just had someone who's a
teacher oh how are they gonna they
I don't really have any words for that
because I was kind of taken aback by
that because I was going to mention that
um there's also the use of disorders of
sexual development within this and
that's not what's used by the medical
society they prefer differences because
saying disorder is saying that they are
in the wrong body this bill supports the
idea that intersex babies are born in
the wrong body despite it saying that
kid you know you get what I'm trying to
say sorry I'm really anxious
um
over 70 of intersex people say that
being called disordered
gives them psychological distress they
aren't disordered we're born like this
there's over 20 000 people in New
Hampshire that are intersex that would
be if in the legal gray area due to this
bill
um in it
if Earth it just further stigmatizes
that that the government does believe
that there are babies born in the wrong
body and that they must be surgically
forced into the unnatural categories
that we have created that we're just
genetic screw-ups and mutilated and
mutated all things I've heard to
describe myself
um
20 000 people in New Hampshire how what
stop wrapping up your testimony please
uh that's that's kind of all I have to
say is that this bill is against
um mutilations of sexual kinds while
explicitly allowing it and I think
that's a little bit hypocritical thank
you for listening to me again okay thank
you
Michelle silly foisy
good afternoon chair and committee
members my name is Michelle salifoise
and I live in Temple I am here to ask
you to oppose HB 619
I am a mom of six children from the ages
of 5 to 27. as a parent I strongly
believe that taking control of my
children's bodies and removing them
their bodily autonomy is wrong
I feel as a parent it is my
responsibility to support my children in
the pursuit of their dreams and their
happiest life
I did not become a parent to control
their path and their future only to love
them unconditionally and care for them
with no bounds
I would like to share a quote from a
fellow mom Adrian Robin Robbins who is a
lifelong New Hampshire resident in
Temple
in her words I urge you to oppose HB 619
my child came out as transgender when
she was 16 years old and I have no doubt
that she would be a suicide statistic
without the gender affirming care that
she received today she is an a thriving
19 year old she is happier than she has
ever been with a job and a great group
of friends
our family placed our trust in the
medical professionals helping my child
with her transition my child is alive
and happy today because of that
I ask you to please oppose this bill so
that other children have the chance to
thrive
please I urge you to oppose HB 619 thank
you for listening to my testimony thank
yes sorry for the uh kind of uh camp
counselor enthusiasm I see a lot of
tired faces and I kind of wish I could
do an Energizer but I'm going to stick
all right so I'll keep it quick and
simple I oppose
hb619 I work in the field of prevention
here in the state of New Hampshire and
have been involved in this work ever
since I was a teenager myself in middle
school back in 2001. proudly I've lived
in New Hampshire my whole life except
for my college Years and as have the
eight generations of my family before me
and part of that Legacy is the level of
small town community I have experienced
my whole life I was raised to be a Good
Samaritan and spent most of my youth
volunteering and doing right by my
communities
prevention often leads people to think
of just whether or not children use
drugs tobacco and Other Drugs but it's
also Suicide Prevention and building
Community is the root of all prevention
that we do here in the state and Beyond
for over 20 years I have witnessed year
after year of what being open with who
you are can do for creating youth
leadership joy and connectedness in
communities all over the state teens
that attend our programs take advantage
of our safe community space to express
their authentic selves for which many
include gender expression different than
what they were assigned at Birth
and after over 20 years in the field I
have seen teens of all genders CIS and
trans and non-binary discuss their
experiences and traumas in safe spaces
and what the root causes are of why they
feel disconnected and isolated from
their families and communities being
misunderstood neglected abused
mistrusted are all a part of it being
affirmed of trans and non-binary
identities is not one of those traumas
that I hear about
additionally affirming these children
and teens that trans or non-binary bring
about some of the best leaders I've come
to know because there is nothing braver
to live as your authentic self in the
face of hateful rhetoric and bills such
as this and that inspires and uplifts
people from all walks of life with all
different experiences and struggles
regardless of gender additionally please
know that I hear and internalize all of
the experiences I heard today and
believe care should be nuanced and leave
options open for shifts in self-identity
as one grows older but outlying all
gender affirming care for those under 18
only dissolves that trust cuts out
necessary resources and leads to Greater
isolation and harm thank you for your
next step to speak is Kate West
Allison Yeager hello I'm checking stock
I strongly oppose this bill and I would
love to tell you some more about why
why so one of the things that I think
hasn't been touched on quite enough in
the discussion of this bill is the
reinstating of conversion therapy and
I've heard a lot of supporters talking
about following the science and how
there isn't enough science to talk to
show that gender affirmative care really
is life-saving or that doesn't really
that doesn't have long-term effects but
what we do know is the damage of
conversion therapy if you go and just
Google convert conversion therapy PubMed
PDF to really just filter out all of the
negative results I found at least 17
just on page one sitting in this room
right now
um and speaking for my mother who's a
public health professional who owns a
public health company based in New
Hampshire
uh every single
Medical Association that was not formed
with an agenda against trans Health Care
agrees that trans affirming care
including for youth which is not the
dramatic things that are laid out in
that bill that highly scare mongering
the situation they're not just handing
out surgeries like that believe me I
wish they were for my own sake
the American Academy of Child and
Adolescent psychology the American
Pediatric Association the American
Medical Association the American Academy
of Pediatrics all of these groups with
significant membership and significant
respect across the medical community do
agree the groups that were founded
specifically to push one particular idea
of course are going to push the idea
that they were founded to suggest
um going over some statistics again 85
percent of transgender and non-binary
youth and 66 percent of all lgbtq youth
say that recent laws just about these
debates having these debates whether
these laws are passed or not of which
there have been hundreds introduced just
in this year of 2023 significantly
impact their Mental Health 52 percent of
trans and non-binary youth seriously
considered suicide in the last year and
one in five attempted
I was one of those when it was me
36 of lgbtq Youth reported that being
physically threatened or reported being
physically threatened or harmed due to
their sexual orientation or gender
identity something that would be
worsened if schools are not allowed or
not permitted to teach anti-hate when I
was in school and I faced bullying based
on my race our teachers took the time to
teach everybody about racial differences
to teach things about cultural
differences to try to protect me to try
to protect other students this bill
would remove that protection from trans
students to say teachers cannot speak up
against these bullies and they are
prohibited from doing so
in fact teachers are required to be part
of the bullying themselves which is
something that is completely
unacceptable in every other field
use it just using I have a close family
friend who's 12 and is trans and seeing
the smile on his face just when I use
this pronouns correctly makes everything
worth it makes it worth it to be here
today and hear all the hate that I've
heard today
finally I want to address the uh
issues of
um all the sphere mongering about this
being like a mass system and that
everyone is talking about how to talk
kids into care so I'm on Tick Tock
because I'm an educator and I'd like to
know what kids are up to yeah for three
minutes if you could wrap up please yes
um one you know I see a lot of surgeries
being post bushed particularly nose jobs
right everybody talking about deviated
symptoms you can get your insurance to
cover it no one is legislating that
those jobs can't be allowed in fact they
are permitted with parental permission
it's something that this would take that
away and it has a much higher negative
result rate and a much higher regret
rate so unless we're going to be
consistent let's say this for what this
is this is a bill that is discrimination
against trans people
full stop and I'm sorry if it hurts
people's feelings to be told they're
being hateful when they aren't hurts
people's feelings to be called
pedophiles and groomers but here we are
have a nice day thank you
and the final person I have signed up to
speak Mitchell
piles
good afternoon good afternoon thank you
all for all your patience and listening
to everyone my name is Mitchell piles
I've lived in this
paid since I was five years old I'm 37
now
um went to keen and UNH
licensed independent clinical social
worker for over the past 10 years
um
and also a trans person I a lot of what
I had to say has already been said I
wanted to add a couple things one of the
things in the bill talks about how
teachers can't refer to or wouldn't be
able to refer to other students other
than their biological or name assigned
at Birth I have an uncle whose birth
name was Leonard
um and went by Alan
um because he really hated the name
Leonard would
and that happens where a lot of kids
have either nicknames or different names
that they want to use but this bill is
really focused on folks who
um are trained trans so un unfairly is
targeting them in their preferred names
versus cisgender people and the
nicknames they have
a part of my work as a licensed clinical
social worker is I work with
um in emergency services I meet with all
of these uh folks that um we're
referring to these kids that attempt or
have suicidal ideation on a daily basis
I can tell you from my personal work
doing this work that the kids that we
see who show up with suicidal ideation
alone are versus kids that have actually
attempted suicide the difference is that
they have their support a supportive
person in their lives whether it's their
teacher or their parents who want to get
them the support that they need versus
the kids that have gone through and
attempted suicide whether either by
hanging ingesting pills wishing that
they could die is because they don't
have a supportive person I've been that
I've been an individual who have talked
to these kids looked at them in the face
and they're telling me they have no hope
because they don't have a supportive
person they and so I think partially why
I'm referencing this is to be able to
that
to not be able to have teachers for them
to talk to or to share this in schools
really would put I would see much more
instead of kids showing up at the Ed in
the emergency department
because they're feeling suicidal and
they told the teacher and then they can
get help I think that we're going to see
more actual attempts and suicide
completions which I also help support
those families and so from I know it's a
lot of for folks it's all these stories
but I see it every day in the emergency
department in the Seacoast
um and so just I know you've heard all
this but wanted to share those those
things
um one of those quick three Second Story
is that one of the teenagers I saw who
did attempt
suicide
got brought into the hospital it was
June so they saw their pride flies in
the emergency room and they said that
was the first hope that they had ever
that they had had in two years because
they knew that they weren't Us in the
emergency room would be supportive they
had no hope for their future and
um but talking with us I also have a
trans and LGBT pen I wear in my badge
and so they opened up to me even though
they begged me not to tell their parents
because their parents had hit them
because of trying to share their
identity their trans identity and so
just being able to cry with me to say
that they really
that they want to be able to grow into
an adult but they're not sure they can
is a really beautiful experience that I
get to
offer the support and I really hope that
you all take these all of this into
consideration before moving this forward
I am open to questions thank you any
questions
saying none thank you thank you
okay you know what else is signed up to
testify does anyone else wish to testify
uh sure if it's a quick if it's a quick
sniffer
Ence because I'm really anxious sorry
but there was a lot of people mentioning
like oh all these kids are Autistic or
ADHD the implication that we cannot
consent or understand what we are
consenting to
um is ableism straight up like I I can't
really say anything more than that but
to say that we can't that to you have to
prevent it or to stop all these autistic
people getting these surgeries is
implying that we don't that we aren't
able to consent that we aren't able to
understand
and I don't understand why
um besides ableism
um yeah okay thank you
okay I am going to close the public
hearing on House Bill 619. those are the
only two bills we had noticed for today
for public testimony and for public
hearings I want to thank all of you who
have stuck it out with us today and and
been so patient and
participated and yeah actually you can
clap now the day is over
but uh again thank you for coming out
we've collected all of your testimony we
will go over it very carefully the clerk
is does an excellent job of taking notes
and we will be voting on this bill in
the next week or so and and again we'll
take everything you've take you've said
to you today very seriously and consider
it very carefully have a nice evening
and drive home safely get plenty of food